♪
Bonsoir Mesdames et Messieurs,
ici Patrice trois et toute
l'équipe de l'information de
Radio-Canada. Une campagne
tellement serrée du début à la
fin que nous avons hâte de voir
ce que la population a choisi,
ce que vous aurez choisi, parce
que c'est un moment important,
c'est votre moment, une étape
importante nous choisissons nos
députés, contre notre
gouvernement. Après ceux de
Terre-Neuve, les bureaux de vote
viennent de fermer dans les
trois autres provinces de
l'Atlantique, ils ferment au
Québec et en Ontario, partout
sauf en Colombie-Britannique,
dans deux heures. Les gens sont
allés voter toute la journée, on
aura un taux de participation un
peu plus tard à vous donner en
fin de soirée. Madeleine,
l'important, les résultats
d'abord, il y en a déjà qui sont
entrés dans les Maritimes.
- Oui, ça fait une demi-heure
que les bureaux de vote enfermé
à Terre-Neuve et au Labrador, il
y a sept sièges qui étaient
rouges, en fait, l'Atlantique
était rouge de Bora Bora 2015,
on attend de voir ce qui va se
passer, entre autres ici, parce
que c'est là que la Nouvelle-
Écosse... les néo-démocrates
avait des espoirs ici, à Saint-
Jean est, mais on attend
toujours les résultats. Sinon
dans les six autres sièges à
Terre-Neuve-et-Labrador, pour le
moment, les libéraux sont en
avance on attendra dans les
prochaines minutes les résultats
dans les autres provinces de
l'Atlantique.
- Très bien, maternel Labrador,
les libéraux ne craignaient pas
d'en perdre beaucoup, c'est très
intéressant de surveiller en
Nouvelle-Écosse et au Nouveau-
Brunswick. Je vous présente mes
camarades ce soir, analyste et
axes. D'abord les analystes :
Michel C. Auger, Josée Legault,
Kheiriddin et Alec Castonguay
bonsoir. C'est le thème de La
Boîte à surprises.
- Au niveau du vote populaire,
les deux partis principaux ont
commencé au coude à coude et
finissent au coude à coude, ils
finissent qu'ils ont commencé,
mais finissent encore coude à
coude. Cela dit, ça avantage les
libéraux, il y a beaucoup de
vote non inefficace pour dire
des votes perdus dans les
provinces des Prairies pour les
conservateurs, c'est un peu
comme le West Island dans une
élection provinciale Québec. Il
y a un léger avantage en termes
de sièges libéraux, mais tout
peut se produire et probablement
qu'on devra attendre la
Colombie-Britannique pour régler
tout ça, et après tout le monde
sait à un gouvernement
minoritaire, quelque chose de
très serré.
- C'est ce qui fait que les gens
sont davantage intéressés à
cette campagne, on ne sait pas
qui va gagner, ça rend les
choses plus intéressantes.
- Oui, ça nous monte en
situation multipartite, tout
peut arriver dans cette campagne
électorale. Ce qui me frappe le
plus en ce qui concerne Justin
Trudeau de ce qu'on a
l'impression que le mes premiers
ministres ont appris son
prochain mandat comme acquis.
Malgré les SNC-Lavalin, etc. Et
pourtant, l'électorat, depuis
quelques années, envoie des
messages gouvernement : votre
deuxième mandat, vous allez
devoir le mériter, nous n'allons
pas vous le donner de manière
automatique. On l'a vu avec
Philippe Couillard, même à
Montréal avec Denis Coderre,
Pauline Marois aussi a goûté à
cette médecine. Alors je pense
que l'électorat est devenu très
invisible imprévisible,  il y a
une leçon d'humilité à prendre
pour le gouvernement qui se
présente pour un deuxième
mandat.
- Ce qui était une règle non
écrite gouvernement sortante
avait automatiquement un autre
mandat, ce n'est plus la règle,
qu'est-ce qui vous frappe?
- C'est le fait que l'importance
du bloc, c'est de décider qui va
avoir un gouvernement
minoritaire. On ne sait pas
quelle couleur ça va avoir,
c'est le reste du Canada, et le
NPD joue aussi un très grand
rôle là-dedans, mais dans le
reste du Canada, je pense qu'on
ne parle pas assez du Bloc,
quoique le bloc a en décidant
que c'est minoritaire le
gouvernement. Ils savent que
c'est très important parce que
gouvernement minoritaire libéral
va dépendre des politiques du
NPD pour son soutien, il ne va
pas danser avec le bloc. Il va y
avoir un grand non plus à gauche
que si on avait pas cette
situation. Sachant que la
dynamique, aussi la question du
vote populaire, la faction
construite sur la chambre des
communes, PDV qu'on change le
mode de scrutin, comme on peut
le faire au Québec. Il va être
dans cette direction.
- Qu'est-ce qui vous frappe dans
cette campagne?
- À partir du moment où le Bloc
québécois est monté, les
libéraux et les conservateurs
ont perdu l'espoir d'avoir une
majorité. Plus le bloc monté,
c'était les consommateurs, plus
le bloc continuait à manger
monter, les libéraux perdaient
des champs d'avoir une majorité.
Le NPD monte, plus il divise les
votes, à ce moment-là, ça
devient une boîte à surprises.
C'est drôle, le bloc et le NPD
ne peuvent pas former le
gouvernement, mais ils ont une
énorme responsabilité sur le
type de gouvernement qu'on va
voir ce soir, libéral ou
conservateur minoritaire, c'est
presque certain dans la
dynamique actuelle.
- On attend les résultats dans
les trois autres provinces de
l'Atlantique, Terre-Neuve-et-
Labrador, nous avons des
résultats dans toutes les
circonscriptions sauf celle où
le pourrait faire un gain. On
suit cela, on a toujours un oeil
là-dessus. Je vous présente mes
textes à moi pour cette longue
soirée : Yolande James l'ex-
ministre du gouvernement
libéral, Michael Fortier, ex
ministre conservateur, vous avez
une expérience dans un
gouvernement minoritaire, ça
pourrait nous servir tout à
l'heure.
- J'espère, parce que vous
m'avez invité!
- Gilles Duceppe, ancien chef du
Bloc québécois. Ce n'est pas une
qui va passer à l'histoire,
chaque avait des défis à
relever, plusieurs n'ont pas été
relevés justement.
- C'est intéressant de voir la
première journée de campagne,
Justin Trudeau a pris la peine
de vouloir bien dessiner Andrew
Scheer, il a voulu positionner
sa question de l'élection comme
étant le choix entre lui et
Andrew Scheer. Andrew Scheer a
fait exactement la même chose.
Mais c'est quand ils n'ont pas
voulu venir le bloc, pourtant,
on le sait, le vote est
tellement volatil, la campagne
compte, le chef et le récit est
tellement important, alors on
lui a donné toute la place à
Yves François, évidemment, ça
été un collègue à l'assemblée.
- Non seulement à l'assemblée,
mais aux ex.
- c'est un très bon politicien,
très bon débatteurs, il a pris
toute la place, mais on lui a
laissé, même au débat avec vous,
et n'ont jamais pris la peine de
définir son adversaire politique
c'est très important.
- M. Scheer à laisser de la
place au Québec?
- Je pense que M. Rayes aurait
dû avoir son propre de se faire
sa propre campagne. Tout à
l'heure, on faisait mention du
fait qu'il avait recruté
beaucoup d'excellents candidats,
M. Rayes s'est beaucoup investi
dans la campagne, on aurait dû
prévoir que c'était trop beau au
Québec, que les voies étaient
trop inoccupées, on aurait dû
profiter du fait qu'à l'élection
de 2011, on a fait élire que
cinq Québécois pour le Parti
conservateur et ce n'est pas ce
qu'on voulait cette fois-ci, on
voulait un gouvernement
fortement représenté du Québec.
Le premier bulletin de notre
émission ce soir que ça commence
les Maritimes. Les
conservateurs, il faut qu'il
commence à gagner des comtés, en
vous dit qu'on va attendre la
Colombie-Britannique, on
attendra pas si les
conservateurs gagner des comtés
dans les 30 dans l'Atlantique,
on va le savoir bien avant 11
heures. Je vais rester jusqu'à
11 heures!
- Merci, vous êtes gentil.
Vous êtes avec M. Fortin, du
Bloc.
- Réinventer, député sortant de
la rivière tenan. Comment vous
vous sentez aujourd'hui?
- Très bien, fatiguée mais en
excellente forme. La campagne
électorale est magnifique. C'est
une occasion de retourner vers
devant nos mandants, aux
électeurs, je vois ça comme une
reddition de comptes au dernier
mandat. Êtes-vous content ou
pas, en même temps, une espèce
de laque à l'épaule sur épaule,
vous attendez quoi de nous, et
la réponse est excellente. Les
gens sont contents, quand je
regarde les chiffres, ça semble
dire qu'effectivement, les
choses vont bien. On célébrera
pas avant le temps, mais je me
sens heureux de ma campagne,
heureux de ce que j'entends sur
le terrain.
- Je sais que vous ne voulez pas
faire de production précise,
mais vous êtes rendu ou dans
votre tête en nombre de sièges
au Québec?
- Janvier 12, ça fait quatre ans
qu'on se bat à 10, pas de
budget, pas de temps dans les
comités, pas de questions dans
les comités, pas de vote dans
les comités, ça, c'est terrible.
On a fait la job, je suis
particulièrement fié du travail
qu'on accomplit durant le
dernier mandat. Si on est 12, le
budget va être lighter êtrla. On
s'entend que ce que j'entends,
c'est pas mal puisque 12. On va
te livrer la marchandise pour
les Québécoises et les
Québécois.
- Merci beaucoup.
- C'est bien, d'autres que ça
fait éclater de rire les gens,
on pense que ce sera plus. Le
chef a dit : ben, je vais
considérer que c'est une
victoire.
- Qui mène à l'Île-du-Prince-
Édouard, une reprise en ce
moment, mais un seul bureau de
scrutin a été dépouillé. C'est
la seule circonscription avoir
changé mais au cours des
dernières années, c'est là que
Galtier avait été ministre des
pêches au gouvernement.
- Dans le fameux résultat dans
la circonscription de Saint-Jean
est-ce que les néo-démocrates
pouvait pouvoir prendre ce soir,
il n'en a pas, quand il y en
aura on verra, sinon les
libéraux ont conservé toutes les
circonscriptions. Les libéraux
avaient toutes les
circonscriptions des Maritimes
Atlantique, 32 heures 30 :
Madeleine, il serait fort
étonnant et ne s'imaginait pas
reproduire l'exploit.
- C'était un balayage en 2015,
c'est difficile de refaire
l'histoire deuxième fois parce
que c'était une première
historique en 2015. Il
s'attendait départ ce soir, mais
ils veulent limiter les pertes,
limiter l'érosion de leur vote,
à mon Atlantique, partout au
pays, parce que c'est comme ça
qu'ils pensent qu'ils vont peut-
être pouvoir garder le pouvoir
s'ils réussissent à limiter les
dégâts un peu partout.
- Françoise Boivin, je disais
plus tôt que vous avez eu un
pied chez les libéraux, puis au
NPD, vous avez des antennes un
peu partout. Jagmeet Singh,
beaucoup de gens l'ont trouvé
sympathique, mais suffisant pour
faire une bonne performance?
- Cette procession, avec le taux
de participation et voir comment
les comtés compensent vont
passer dans d'autres camps, est-
ce que ces autres parties comme
par exemple le bloc, qui avait
moins d'argent que dans les
bonnes années de Gilles, est-ce
qu'ils vont être capable de
faire sortir leur vote tel qu'on
les voyait dans les sondages?
Même chose que le NPD à
plusieurs égards. Alors, est-ce
que c'est courant de sympathie
que les deux parties de tête
n'ont jamais vu venir parce
qu'en politique, quand on sous-
estime ses adversaires, on
commet la plus grosse erreur de
sa carrière. À mon avis, les
conservateurs et les libéraux
ont fait cette erreur, et non
pas regarder dans le rétroviseur
et à un moment donné, sont
arrivés dans le point mort. Est-
ce que ça puisse transposer avec
les votes, l'avenir nous le
dira.
- On a deux élus au Nouveau-
Brunswick : Scott Eames, un
sixième mandat, un vieux routier
pour les libéraux. En bas de
l'écran, les conservateurs
mènent dans trois
circonscriptions, des Nouveau-
Brunswick, je crois, Madeleine.
- Onalit Île-du-Prince-Édouard.
- C'est une histoire facile pour
les libéraux ce soir. C'était la
secrétaire parlementaire de
Mélanie Joly.
- Catherine Gauthier, on va
surveiller... Madame Gauthier,
rester avec nous, mais ramifie
grand les, c'est une
circonscription libérale, ce
serait un gain conservateur
Nouveau-Brunswick.
- Tout ce qui est bleu en
Atlantique serait des pour le
Parti conservateur, parce que
les libéraux avaient balayé
l'Atlantique, c'est Peggy
MacLean qui mène par trois fois
devant les libérales, mais ce
sont des résultats très
fragmentaires, un seul bureau a
été dépouillé.
- Catherine, ce ne sera pas très
long, allez-y, vous êtes là, à
Montréal, y aura des
circonscriptions fort
intéressantes à surveiller.
- Entre autres un corridor
orange, va-t-il rester orange
que c'est ce qu'on surveille ou
je me trouve dans Rosement-La
Petite Patrie. Vous savez que
c'est la circonscription qui est
représentée par le chef adjoint
au NPD, Alexandre Boulerice, qui
avait obtenu 49 % des voix en
2015. Va-t-il réussir à se faire
élire, c'est un symbole, est
très connu au Québec, il a
travaillé très fort durant cette
campagne, va-t-il réussir à
garder cette circonscription? Un
peu plus au sud, si on poursuit
ce corridor orange, ses lauriers
Sainte-Marie, circonscription de
Gilles Duceppe, mais c'est
Hélène Laverdière qu'il avait
vaincu en 2011, puis en 2015.
Elle prend sa retraite, donc on
va tenter d'être élu pour le
NPD, mais c'est là que se
présente le comptable des
libéraux, Steven Guilbeault. Et
à, c'était un néo-démocrate, la
députée ne s'est pas représenté,
il y a beaucoup de rouge parmi
les 18 circonscriptions
montréalaises, il y avait 14
circonscriptions qui étaient
détenues par les libéraux
dernières élections, entre
autres Justin Trudeau, Mélanie
Joly et Pablo Rodriguès.
Historiquement, il y a beaucoup
de libéraux sur l'Montréal.
- On a les premiers résultats
dans Saint-Jean est,
effectivement, c'est Jacques
Harris, il est en avance, il
veut ravoir cette
circonscription, il a déjà été
député du NPD là-bas, ce serait
une perte pour les libéraux.
Canette McDonald, qui est réélu
facilement à Avalon,
circonscriptions rouges.
- C'est la circonscription, des
circonscriptions comme ailleurs
en Atlantique où il y avait eu
démarche assez élevée, 16 000
voix en 2015. Il n'avait pas été
élu dans une partielle.
- Je vais juste revenir sans
commentaire que Françoise a fait
sur Jagmeet Singh, les
principaux partis en avance non
pas, on sous-estimait M. Singh,
mais on peut les excuser, parce
que les néo-démocrate sous-
estimait M. Singh, je ne
comprenais pas comment ça se
fait qu'il n'arrivait pas à
percer plus, mais je pense qu'on
peut excuser les partis
principaux parce que vous-même
était en train de l'assassiner.
- On pensait que ça allait être
extrêmement difficile, mais je
pense que la soirée va prouver
que j'avais raison. Je vais
sauver sa job ailleurs par
l'Ontario de la Colombie-
Britannique.
- Gilles Duceppe, c'était tout
un au contexte il y a quatre
ans, vous sentez quoi, vous
voyez quoi?
- Je pense que c'est une lutte
entre M. Guilbeault et M.
Dussin, c'est très serré, 2 %
qui se jouent. Le NPD n'est pas
vraiment là, non en arrière, le
jour d'une élection, cette;
c'est beaucoup. On va voir
comment les gens font réagir,
surtout sur le plateau, parce
que l'ouest du comté vote
libéral, le bas du comté vote
pour le NPD, et le bas du
plateau, le bloc a des chances.
- D'Hochelaga, je pense que le
bloc est nettement en avance.
- M. Nantel a choisi de
représenter dans Longueuil les
verres, il est avec notre
collègue, j'ai hâte de
l'entendre.
- Oui, je me trouve dans le
vieux Longueuil au bureau
électoral de M. Nantel, vous
voyez derrière moi ces militants
qui sont toujours en train
d'essayer de faire sortir le
vote, il restant quand même
encore une heure et demie avant
la fermeture des bureaux Québec,
j'ai le député sortant, Pierre
Nantel, à côté de moi, qui a été
élu deux fois ici dans Longueuil
Saint-Hubert pour les néo-
démocrates. Il a fait le pari de
passer au vert, les verts qui
n'ont eu que 2,5 % des votes, M.
Nantel, c'est tout un défi que
vous vous êtes donné. À quoi
vous attendez ce soir?
- On a eu un feed-back tellement
positif des gens de la
population qui dise qu'on est
heureux d'avoir le climat en
priorité. Est-ce qu'on part d'un
pointage de 2,5 % 2015, c'est
sur la côte est longue, mais on
travaille très fort, tous ces
gens qui sont là n'ont jamais
fait ce travail, ce sont des
passionnés de la question de la
crise climatique, on est là pour
ça.
- Vous êtes souverainiste, est-
ce qu'au cours des dernières
semaines, il y a pas des fois ùu
vous pouvez dit : j'aurais peut-
être dû passer au Bloc
québécois?
- Jamais, parce qu'actuellement,
la priorité à la crise du
climat. Pour le reste, on verra.
- La campagne des verts, le
discours de Madame, votre
plafond, certains disent qu'il
n'y a peut-être pas eu l'Impact,
ça ne peut peut-être pas, levez
autant qu'on aurait pu penser.
- Mme May, pour des raisons
climatiques, voyagent
essentiellement en train. Elle
doit s'écarteler entre toutes
les provinces du Canada avec ses
moyens, alors évidemment, il y a
eu une offensive un peu moins
radicale ou professionnelle,
disons.
- Merci beaucoup, M. Nantel.
- Envoi des images de Justin
Trudeau, c'est la tradition, on
évite un caméraman quelque
minute, ils sont toute la
famille dans une suite en train
de regarder les résultats, on
les salue. Voilà, ils ont
d'habitude deux ou trois télés,
alors je dois bien tomber, doit
nous regardait également. M.
Trudeau, difficile de lire dans
sa tête, mais en tout cas, notre
collègue disait tout à l'heure
que les libéraux sont un peu
plus optimistes maintenant qu'il
ne l'était il y a une semaine en
tout cas.
- L'exemple des verres avec
l'entrevue de Pierre Nantel, ça
met la table. Rappelez-vous en
début de campagne, c'est vrai
que les libéraux voyaient
évidemment Andrew Scheer comme
un adversaire, mais craignaient
aussi les verts. Elizabeth May,
on s'attendait, ça devait être
la campagne sur les changements
climatiques. Alors M. Trudeau
dans sa campagne voulait tenter
aussi de faire positionner son
plan pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques, mais on
a vu avec Madame et à quel point
justement avec la saga Nantel
souverainiste fédéraliste qui
n'était pas sur ces messages qui
a fait en sorte que encore une
fois, c'est le bloc qui a pu
occuper cet espace.
- Quand M. Nantel a prie sa
décision, le bloc n'était pas là
où ils sont aujourd'hui.
Réélu dans Bonavista, M. Rogers,
c'est la circonscription qui a
reçu la plus forte majorité pour
les libéraux en 2015, quelque
chose comme 80 % au plus.
C'est une réélection facile.
- Et c'était lui qui avait été
réélu dans une partielle, mais
Mme Foote avait eu reçu 82 % des
voix.
- Madame qui est réélu au
Labrador, ce n'est pas une
surprise. Globalement, les
libéraux perdent des
pourcentages, même maternels,
ils perdent le vote populaire
baissent à Terre-Neuve.
Soulignons le important que vous
le sachiez, c'est un présage, on
verra dans quelle mesure, mais
c'est important, même s'ils
récoltent des circonscriptions
très rouges, le pourcentage
baisse. À noter.
Vous pouvez à la maison
personnifiée cette soirée,
Madeleine, c'est un instrument
très facile à utiliser.
- Vous pouvez utiliser
aCanada.ca/résultats, votre
tableau de bord à vous. Si vous
avez des circonscriptions que
vous voulez suivre de plus près,
celle de votre mère par exemple,
vous pouvez cliquer dessus,
c'est très facile à utiliser,
vous pouvez continuer à de nous
écouter, Gilles Duceppe nous a
dit que peut-être il y en a une
qui voulait surveiller au lac
Saint-Jean celle de son fils,
c'est facile à utiliser, vous
pouvez mettre plusieurs suivra
favoris et les résultats entre
quasiment en temps réel.
- M. Biden qui est en avance sur
les libéraux.
- C'est un conservateur qui est
en avance encore une fois au
Nouveau-Brunswick, une avance de
cette voie, après le
dépouillement d'un bureau de
scrutin.
- Il y a cinq entre les
conservateurs, croque-morts et
en avance, c'est un match
revanche également, sauf erreur,
contre Madame Lockhart.
- Une circonscriptions presque
complètement conservatrice. Ici,
c'est Armstrong qui mène
points.
- Ici, c'est altimètre qui est
de l'avant, c'est pas beaucoup,
une petite avance de 3 votes
devant le libéral. Les deux
circonscriptions du Cap-Breton
étaient laissées vacantes.
- En maritime Atlantique, 11 ont
été lu pour les libéraux, 7 ans
d'pour les conservateurs et un
au Labrador, en suffrage : 48 %,
les libéraux avaient fait au-
dessus de 50 % et plus en
Atlantique, donc il y a un recul
du vote libéral même s'ils
maintiennent la plupart de leurs
acquis. À suivre.
- Si ça se divisait ailleurs,
les libéraux auraient des
problèmes.
- C'est peut-être un présage,
vous le voyez, ils sont apparus,
les petits carrés qui ne suivent
tout au long de la soirée, c'est
le, on a que les Maritimes que
c'est très important de ces
chiffres, parce que dans
l'éventualité d'une quasi
égalité, le suffrage populaire
sera important, on aura le temps
d'en reparler.
- Les libéraux disaient au début
de la campagne que si on n'en
perd plus que 10 ans les
Maritimes, ce serait un très
mauvais signe. On est rendu à
neuf. Il y a des
circonscriptions, il y a deux
libéraux dans l'histoire, mais
il y a des comtés qui,
normalement, par exemple, qu'ils
auraient dû garder, c'est à
compter que les libéraux, depuis
le départ de M. Crosby, qu'ils
avaient investi. Mais là, ça
fait mal. Un moment donné, c'est
plus de 10 ans que ça peut être
une longue soirée ici.
- Les conservateurs pensent
avoir huit sièges, selon les
stratèges, c'était leur but, ils
en ont plus, ça va être pire,
mais c'est le suspense,
il y a toute une question de
pancartes qui ont été détruites,
c'était une lutte assez féroce
s'est fait entre le libéral et
le conservateur là-dedans.
- Vous êtes à la fin de la
campagne, il se disait...
- il vous lévite, on va voir
s'ils en ont plus.
- Il ne faut pas oublier que
lévite en avance à ce moment-ci
des conservateurs, je ne pense
pas que c'est nécessairement dû
à la campagne de M. Scheer, ce
qu'il ne faut pas oublier, c'est
que les gouvernements des
Maritimes étaient des
gouvernements libéraux et que ça
a changé. Ça, c'est important
parce que ce sont les mêmes
militants. Alors, il y a eu un
changement de population. Alors
ça, ça joue énormément.
- Et le fait que le NPD n'est
pas venu au bout Nouveau-
Brunswick avec son chef.
- M. Singh a découvert le
Nouveau-Brunswick.
- Parfois on n'a pas besoin
d'envoyer le chef visité pour
aller chercher.
- Si M. Singh avait été, ça
jouerait encore en défaveur des
libéraux et ça aiderait les
conservateurs.
- Le candidat néo-démocrate et
troisième.
- Dans Beauséjour, Dominic
LeBlanc qui est en avant, on lui
souhaite bon rétablissement, et
un traitement contre concert à
Montréal actuellement, il va
s'adresser à ses partisans par
un moyen comme festin ou
vidéoconférence.
Dans Saint-Jean C, le libéral
est en avance.
- Il aimerait faire un retour
dans la chambre des communes,
c'est un match revanche dans sa
part, mais il y a trois bureaux
de scrutins qui ont été
dépouillés. Ici, c'est M. Fraser
qui mène par 61 voix, qui
aimerait avoir un deuxième
mandat.
- Ce sont neufs en avance pour
les conservateurs. Charlotte
tempsde, M. Christi est en
avance. Madeleine, montrez-nous
les couleurs qui sont en train
de changer en Atlantique
maritime.
- En 2015, c'était au rouge,
un balayage complet de la part
de Justin Trudeau.
Le bleu a fait son apparition
au Nouveau-Brunswick, en
Nouvelle-Écosse ici, un siège
orange à Saint-Jean est.
Jusqu'à maintenant c'est des
sièges qui sont soient en retard
ou des élus qui ont été élus
peut-être le Parti conservateur.
C'est un début de soirée qui est
assez difficile pour le Parti
libéral qui aurait voulu limiter
ses pertes en Atlantique.
Là, ça dépasse largement.
- On est à 10.
Neuf, c'est un peu le seuil pour
les conservateurs pour espérer
avoir un gouvernement
minoritaire. S'ils avaient en
deçà de neuf, vous disiez huit.
Moins de neuf, les conservateurs
n'ont jamais réussi à former
le gouvernement. Avec neuf, ils
ont déjà formé un gouvernement
minoritaire. Alors on verra mais
en tout cas, ça souligne ce
candidat connais pas le résultat
de cette élection parce que tout
peut arriver. Si les libéraux
étaient à ce moment-ci à 25, ce
serait toute une autre histoire.
- Tout à fait et en regardant
les chiffres va bientôt arriver
au Québec, en parler tantôt même
si les conservateurs ne font pas
de gants c'est que les libéraux
vont subir d'énormes pertes.
Donc leur numérateur va
descendre. Celui des
conservateurs ne monteront pas.
Quand on voit se rendre en
Ontario c'est là où ça va jouer.
Au Québec ça va très important
pour les conservateurs de tenter
de maintenir le statu quo, s'il
y a des pertes que ce soit une
poignée de pertes mais pas de
ou 8 comptés.
- En 2015 en voyant le résultat
sortir en attente concédée :
c'est fini. On sentait que
c'était une vague rouge. Et ce
soir ce compte depuis des
semaines, ça aurait pu être une
vague rouge et on se serait dit
les sondeurs se sont trompés pas
à peu près.
Là, ça nous confirme qu'on va
avoir une soirée excitante qui
justifie qu'on soit tout ça pour
en parler pendant des heures et
des heures.
- C'est pour ça qu'on vous a
réuni. Je vais aller dans Saint-
Jean Est le guide Jack Harris du
NPD, il creuse son avance.
Même s'il y a peu de bureaux de
scrutin, Mesdames et Messieurs,
quand il n'y a pas de
croisement, s'il était devenu
deuxième, là on peut dire...
quand il se maintient premier
dès le début c'est un signe
qu'il va, peut-être pas,
certainement, les probabilités
sont bonnes que Jack Harris sur
le prochain député.
- Médecine doit sourire parce
que c'était un des objectifs du
parti néodémocrates de faire un
retour en Atlantique.
- C'est un début intéressant.
- Quelle boîte de scrutin...
mais dans le vote par patient,
les libéraux n'ont pas connu
le type de campagne qu'il aurait
voulue. Or la dernière semaine
libérale a été beaucoup plus
profitable pour les libéraux
notamment parce que le spectre
gouvernement conservateur est
devenu concret après le vote par
antipathie au milieu de la
semaine dernière. Ce que les
libéraux mes textes c'est qu'ils
espèrent que les prochaines lois
soient plus révélatrices que les
premières où on a le vote par
patient anticipation.
- Dans les derniers trois jours
avec le nouveau problème
d'Andrew Scheer vous avez le
parti populaire, la controverse
qu'il a subie, que les libéraux
ont senti une petit élan.
- J'ajoute à ça qu'il faut tenir
compte des réalités régionales.
Je sais pas si ce comté à des
réalités régionales différentes
si on prend Rivière-du-Loup
Montmagny, c'est des réalités
différente. D'où viennent les...
- D'où la prudence du début.é
je me rends en Mauricie parce
que ce soir il y a plein de
circonscriptions à surveiller
dans certaines en Mauricie.
Je pense à Saint-Maurice qu'on
ne pensait pas mettre dans la
liste des "à surveiller".
On se disait que le ministre
champagne allait passer mais on
ne le sait plus?
- On ne sait plus. Au départ
dans Saint Maurice Champlain
n'avait aucun doute on croyait
qu'il remporterait ce deuxième
mandat facilement, mais la
course s'est resserrée
maintenant rien n'est gagnée
pour François-Philippe Champagne
qui a dû vraiment batailler
jusqu'à la dernière minute pour
aller chercher les votes un à
un. En ce ton à Trois-Rivières
qu'on surveille parce qu'on
pourrait s'attendre à une percée
conservatrice, ce candidat
vedette flamboyant qui est
l'ancien maire de Trois-Rivières
qui se présente pour essayer de
remporter un premier mandat au
fédéral.
Et enfin ici dans Berthier-
Maskinongé, on surveille bien
sûr Ruth Ellen Brosseau qui est
cette candidature avait été
parachuté en 2011 un peu les
comptes de la vague orange. Elle
n'avait même pas fait campagne,
elle sollicite un troisième
mandat. Elle a su gagner le coer
des électeurs et ce sera très
serré pour elle ce soir ici.
- En tout cas Surveiller avec
tellement d'intérêt on a parlé
un peu plus tôt, Ruth Hélène
Brosseau qui est devenue, qui a
incarné cette grande vague du
NPD et qui a été très courageux
et est devenu vraiment une
députée appréciée. Josée Legault
en parler plutôt, qui a de la
famille dans le coin je me
souviens, donc une députée
appréciée tant à Ottawa que sur
le terrain et qui a mérité,
entre guillemets, son poste qui
a été à la hauteur de son poste.
On verra, on va suivre avec
beaucoup d'intérêt merci
beaucoup.
- On pourrait dire qu'elle s'est
enracinée dans le comté.
Donc, on verra pour le résultat
final, mais je peux vous dire
que si jamais elle n'était pas
réélue, il y aurait bien des
coeurs brisés dans son comté.
- On dit que le candidat dans
certaines circonstances comme
pour beaucoup, bien sûr que
l'eau qui monte pour le parfum
général et des fois les gens qui
ont élu, ils étaient là au bon
moment, mais le candidat dans un
terrain coin, 50 la relation
avec les citoyens, ça compte.
- Je suis allé dans Berthier-
Maskinongé, tout à fait d'accord
avec José elle est une vedette
locale Ruth Hélène Brosseau,
elle s'est construite elle-même
c'était quelqu'un qui est
inconnu qui parlait à peine
français et a été élu et depuis
elle a adopté, elle vit sur une
ferme, elle fait des
rassemblements dans des granges.
Il fait partie du tissu social
de Maskinongé possède de qu'elle
va gagner mais quand la marée
baisse parfois ce type de
personnalité risque de s'en
sortir.
- Avec nous En direct de
l'univers Mélanie Joly candidate
libérale Ahuntsic-Cartierville.
Bonsoir à vous!
- Bonsoir!
- Je sais pas, vous devez avoir
les résultats très près de vous,
mais les conservateurs très
mêmes vous en enlèvent, c'était
huit, sept et neuf, on n'a pas
les résultats finaux mais
qu'elle début de soirée avez-
vous.
- C'est sûr qu'en tant que
député je me concentre
présentement sur la réélection
ici ça se passe très bien.
Comme vous pouvez voir, les gens
n'ont pas fini de travailler
n'est encore sur le terrain.
D'ailleurs on essaie de les gens
à aller voter parce que au
Québec jusqu'à 21 heures 30.
Quant aux résultats, ils sont
préliminaires plusieurs d'entre
vous l'haver mentionné alors on
va avoir une longue soirée,
une soirée avec une certaine
fébrilité mais on est confiant.
- Au milieu de la campagne, est-
ce que vous avez été découragé?
Est-ce que vous vous êtes dit :
on est en train de l'échapper.
Ce qui était naturel au Canada
par un gouvernement majoritaire
de se faire réélire ne
devenaient plus naturelles
comptes tenus du manque
d'inspiration. Racontez-moi le
moment où vous vous êtes dit,
vous haver douté même?
- Vous savez, c'est rare qu'un
gouvernement libéral a été
capable d'obtenir une majorité
alors que la droite est unie.
La dernière fois, j'ai beaucoup
lu sur l'élection de 1972, et
puis, ce que je me suis dit,
c'est que vraiment, le plus
important c'était de faire le
boulot. Je vous donne un exemple
au cours des trois derniers mois
ici dans la circonscription,
on a fait 150 000 tentatives de
contact, on a fait en sorte de
parler, au final, soit en porte-
à-porte ou en appel à 63 000
personnes, on a 80 % de tous nos
électeurs avec qui on a une
conversation. Et ça, c'est
l'exemple d'une circonscription
à Montréal, mais on n'a jamais
été aussi organisé au Québec et
au pays, donc dans des courses
très, très serré, ce qui va
faire la différence
nécessairement, c'est
l'organisation électorale.
- En terminant rapidement Mme
Joly, au début de la campagne ce
n'était pas un secret, les
libéraux pensaient faire des
gains, 8 à 11, ça dépend des
actions par la mais vous n'êtes
plus dans le même film?
- On a toujours gardé vraiment
notre objectif en tête, on a
travaillé beaucoup beaucoup pour
faire réélire nos députés, mais
allez faire des gains. Ça va me
faire plaisir de suivre avec
vous le résultat sachant qu'en
ce qu'on a fait du bon boulot.
- Fait plaisir d'entendre ça
merci beaucoup Mélanie Joly et
bonne fin de campagne.
- Merci à vous!
- On va voir les libéraux en
avance au dans les Maritimes
avec Saint-Jean...
c'est M. Reagan qui est
nettement en avance, un ami
assez proche de M. Trudeau.
Pour la petite histoire M.
Trudeau, et lui a conseillé
fortement d'aller chercher de
l'aide, il a nommé ensuite
ministre il devrait pas avoir de
problème pour Saint-Jean sud.
Lawrence MacAulay, il est à son
10e mandat, alors lui, pourrait
presque être réélu. Et avec M.
Plamondon à une élection de plus
que lui du Bloc québécois donc
il est le deuxième.
Deux tout à l'heure et on le
saluait Dominic LeBlanc,
vous êtes en avance dans
Beauséjour au Nouveau-Brunswick
sans aucune surprise. Par contre
il y a des ministres en
difficulté comme Mme Jordan.
Elle traîne de la patte.
C'est à suivre. Et voilà c'est
fait pour simuler au Reagan
ministre aux services
autochtones, c'est réglé, voilà.
Portrait d'ensemble vous le
voyait en Atlantique, 23 les
libéraux ont repris un peu du
poil de la bête, 23 élus ou en-
têtes. Six pour les
conservateurs on est plus dans
neuf, et un pour le NPD.
C'est ça une soirée électorale,
ce sont des montagnes russes.
Imaginez les stratèges
conservateurs qui se disaient :
yes! On a peut-être neuf dans
les Maritimes!
- Sans voix de différence
entre... c'est pas fini.
- D'où les montagnes russes.
Alors voilà, Madeleine, ça
change de couleur mais le NPD à
Terre-Neuve-et-Labrador n'a pas
changé, Jack Harris est en voie
de...
- I creuser son avancée voulait
faire un retour à la chambre
commune. Il avait été poussé
vers la sortie en 2015 lorsque
la vague rouge avait déferlé sur
l'Atlantique. Jusqu'à maintenant
ça se porte bien pour lui sinon,
en Nouvelle-Écosse, c'est là où
en ce moment, les libéraux
essuient le plus de pertes
potentielles. La soirée et je ne
sais pas encore définitif
amélioré quatre sièges pour le
moment, on est peut-être passée
à trois au moment où on se
parle, au Capbreton ici on est
en Nouvelle-Écosse c'est celui
de Cumberland Colchester,
c'était un siège qui avait été
conservateur dans le passé
c'était Bill Caissy qui avait
été élu il a été élu ensuite
comme indépendant et a été élu
libéral. Comme quoi Nouvelle-
Écosse, les députés, ça compte.
Les électeurs s'attachent à
leurs députés. Ici on est dans
Nova Ouest, c'est un siège pour
le moment qui est bleu. Ce
serait potentiellement un gain
conservateur. Au Nouveau-
Brunswick on limite les dégâts
pour le moment pour le parti
libéral, il y aurait deux sièges
qui seraient bleus celui de
Tobique Mactaquac.
On continue. Alors ici ce serait
Fuundy Royal.
- Alors d'où ces renversements
mais regardez, je dis cette
phrase, les conservateurs sont à
cinq. Ils étaient à six.
On va suivre ça mais d'ici une
vingtaine de minutes Hors-combat
avoir une pas mal de meilleures
idées des forces en présence en
Atlantique dans les Maritimes.
Louis Blouin avec les libéraux,
on regarde et on applaudit, on
est déçu pour d'autres coûts.
Mais pour l'instant on est dans
un moment plutôt positif.
- Absolument et les libéraux
sont très confiants par rapport
au dernier droit de campagne
qu'ils ont menée. Ils ont été
très, très présent sur le
terrain beaucoup d'arrêt, 40
circonscriptions depuis le
dernier débat, ça vous donne une
idée. Ça été très intense au
cours de la fin de semaine et
ont vu beaucoup de gens dans le
rassemblement que ce soit en
Ontario et à Calgary Skyview,
on a senti que ça leur a donné
de l'énergie et je peux vous
dire qu'il y a quand même une
très grande tension dans le camp
libéral parce qu'on s'est fait
un début de campagne scellée une
année difficile pour Justin
Trudeau et sa légitimité qui
était questionnée.
- Pardonnez-moi Hors-combat des
images Jagmeet Singh avec sa
famille, il est en train de
regarder cette soirée
électorale, il se croise les
doigts pour l'instant.
Il y a un deuxième qui est
apparu ça doit être au Nouveau-
Brunswick. On vérifiera mais il
doit se croiser les doigts en se
disant : j'espère que toute la
sympathie que j'ai vue devant
moi et les gens qui me disaient
: on vous découvre. Il faut que
ça se traduise en voix et en
circonscriptions garnies.
À suivre. Il regarde la soirée
électorale. Voilà!
- M. Trudeau qui est avec sa
famille tout près du palais des
congrès ce soir avec ses enfants
et a pris le temps de faire un
jogging sur le Mont-Royal peut-
être pour se détendre un peu
penser que ces conseils sont
autour de lui ce soir les gens
qui sont avec lui depuis le
début on pense notamment avec sa
chef de cabinet et Gerald Butts
qui devrait être ici ce soir. Il
veut voir sa garde rapprochée
autour de lui parce que si il
aura peut-être des décisions à
prendre.
- Très bien, je vous disais
qu'il y en a deux au NPD le
deuxième c'est en Nouvelle-
Écosse, Madeleine c'est...
- C'est tout juste à côté de
Halifax et Emma Norton qui mène
par de petites voix devant
Darren Fisher, le député sortant
plutôt à Halifax ou les
néodémocrate veulent faire des
gains.
- Tout de même ça montre que ce
sera serré.
Il y a des retournements. Les
conservateurs sont à sept.
Ils étaient à cinq il y a trois
minutes. Alain... est avec nous
bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Vous avez dû changer votre
manuel de campagne en plein
milieu que les bleus tissent non
seulement été plus dans votre
rétroviseur mettaient devant
vous?
- Pas tout à fait parce que
depuis le début de la campagne,
dès mes premières entrevues en
région à l'extérieur de Montréal
le bloc était un adversaire. On
voit comme tous les mendiants
constatent leur montée dans les
différents sondages, mais ça n'a
pas diminué notre détermination
travail sur le terrain qu'on a
monté une équipe extraordinaire?
Femme d'exception. Je pense que
tout le monde reconnaît que
l'équipe des candidats et
candidates au Québec étaient de
haut niveau. Donc on espère
faire des gains pendant cette
soirée au Québec et avec le
mouvement qui est parti un peu
ailleurs dans les autres
provinces du Canada, de former
le prochain gouvernement, le
gouvernement conservateur.
- Vous dire : on espère faire
des gains. En fait vous avez
besoin de faire des gains au
Québec pour arriver au
gouvernement?
- Oui tout à fait et c'est pour
ça comme je vous dis qu'on est
confiant de réussir avec le
travail qui a été fait sur le
terrain. Le fait qu'on a
commencé à travailler à l'avance
et contenait des équipes pour
faire sortir le vote dans les 78
reconstructions. D'avoir des
gens connus je pense à Yves
Lévesque en Mauricie et à
Richard Lehoux en Beauce c'est
avec des hommes et des femmes
comme ça qu'on peut faire une
différence. Vous avez il y a des
gens qui votent pour les
chapiteaux qui votent pour les
programmes et d'autres autres
pour des particuliers mais aussi
plusieurs vote pour des
candidats et des candidates, des
hommes et des femmes de
l'additionner avec le travail,
avec les promesses qu'on a
faites, mettre plus d'argent
dans les poches des gens pensent
faire de belles surprises
partout Québec.
- Bonne fin de soirée M. Rayes.
Va suivre ça ensemble, merci!
- Ça fait plaisir et bonne
soirée!
- Philippe Vincent Foisy vous
êtes rassemblement des
conservateurs à Régina, je le
rappelle, ils sont rendus à huit
conservateurs pour les
Maritimes. Le seuil de 9 serait
important pour espérer traverser
le Canada et se rendre au
gouvernement.
- Oui disons que ça commencerait
bien la soirée je parle avec des
conservateurs il y a quelques
minutes qui me disent : 8/32
c'est l'objectif qu'on s'est
donné. Ça ferait en sorte qu'on
soit capable d'aller un peu plus
loin d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de sièges à cette
élection. Ça ne met pas le
chemin vers la majorité, sans
prendre un peu plus pour
atteindre la majorité, pour les
conservateurs, on se dit que
huit heures 32 ce serait un bon
chiffre pour partir la soirée.
Pour l'instant se dit confiant
on dit que ça va quand même bien
on regarde ça de très près mais
vous le voyez derrière moi, il y
a encore personne ici à Régina
on n'y deux heures plus loin
donc on a encore deux heures
avant d'arriver à être un peu
plus tard d'avoir ce
rassemblement pendant que Andrew
Scheer est avec sa famille.
On devrait avoir un peu plus de
monde tantôt. Quand on va voir
les résultats qui vont sortir au
Québec, en Ontario dans le reste
du pays sauf la Colombie-
Britannique. C'est là que ça va
se jouer pour les conservateurs.
- Très bien je souligne qu'on a
des résultats dans presque
toutes les circonscriptions les
Maritimes et Atlantique, il en
manque une pour l'instant je
vous rappelle qu'il y en a 32,
c'est à Moncton qu'on n'a pas de
résultats merci Michel.
Avec Louis très heureux de lui
parler, Louis Plamondon, vous
êtes le doyen. Bonsoir M.
Plamondon.
- Oui bonsoir.
- Vous avez tous connus, vous
avez connu la naissance, vous
avez connu les différents, l'âge
d'or, la quasi mort, et là,
êtes-vous en train de connaître
la résurgence du Bloc québécois?
C'est quand même quelque chose
comme histoire?
- Je dirais même la
résurrection.
Vous savez on s'était donné
comme objectif de doubler le
nombre de députés, donc de
passer de 10 à 20, alors tous
députés élus en haut de 20
députés, bien, ce sera un
supplément. Mais pour le moment
notre objectif est toujours
d'arriver à 20.
Mais avec les sondages qui ont
eu lieu on peut espérer plus
mais on serait extrêmement
satisfait déjà.
- On verra combien, on ne fera
pas de pronostic.
Qu'est-ce qui a lancé cette
poussée du Bloc.
- L'arrivée de Monsieur Blanchet
à tout changeait.
On avait 60 000 $ dans le compte
de banque. Quand il est arrivé
immédiatement, les fonds sont
entrés dans chacun des comtés.
A été extraordinaire son
arrivée. Et son premier débat,
ça a été le coup de grâce. En
effet partie des 18 ou 19 %. On
est monté à 25 %. Et là tout
était possible.
- Qu'est-ce que ça va changer
vous croyait dans le jeu
politique que vous soyez 15 ou
16 ou 17?
- Le fait d'être reconnu,
d'avoir un minimum de 12, anodin
des budgets de recherche pour
être beaucoup plus efficace et
anodin des droits des paroles
supplémentaires en chambre.
Incessante, le point de vue du
Québec va être entendu.
- Louis Plamondon, je vous
salue. Bonne suite de soirées
électorales!
- Très confiant pour le reste de
la soirée.
- Valérie vous et avec Monsieur
Bernier.
- Une première campagne
électorale pour Maxime Bernier
du parti populaire du Canada en
tant que chef. C'est le
cinquième mandat que vous
demandez, que vous sollicitez au
beauceron. Vous avez fait une
campagne comme candidat mais
également comme chef. Comment
vous avez trouvé cela?
- Ça été une belle campagne.
Mais on a vraiment senti la
campagne de salissage du parti
conservateur. On voulait
beaucoup faire la promotion de
nos idées. Mais avec ce que les
conservateurs ont fait partout à
travers le pays, on a dû lutter
contre des propos qui n'étaient
pas finalement des propos basés
sur la réalité en parlant de
fait que nos gens étaient des
racistes ou des xénophobes. On a
été sur la défensive pendant une
partie de la campagne. C'est
déplorable. Mais l'important
pour nous est de continuer à
parler de nos idées.
- Avez-vous l'impression que
même ici en Beauce ça va vous
nuire? Vous avait gagné
auparavant avec des majorités
ici à 67 %. On sent que c'est
une lutte chaude contre votre
adversaire conservateur.
- Je pense que les beaucerons
ont apprécié de mon travail.
Pendant quelques heures. Je suis
très confiant. Mais comme vous
le dîtes c'est une lutte un peu
plus serrée. Si le taux de
participation est très élevé en
Beauce, ça devrait bien aller.
Je suis confiant.
- Ces derniers jours de
campagne, vous les avez passées
en Beauce en compagnie de votre
père. Est-ce que justement c'est
devenu une campagne de famille
chez les Bernier?
- Ça a toujours été ça. Mon
opposant à parler que ma famille
m'aidait mais je défends les
galères conservatrices, les
valeurs de liberté et de
responsabilité et les valeurs
Bouches-du-Rhône qui sont les
valeurs familiales. Mon père et
ma famille m'ont aidé dans
toutes mes élections. C'était
bien prévu qu'on finissait la
campagne en Beauce. J'ai
commencé la campagne à
l'extérieur de la Beauce en tant
que chef de parti. On a terminé
la campagne ici.
- Merci beaucoup. Bonne chance!
- Sa présence aux débats aussi à
changer la donne. Il n'était pas
invité au départ. Premier élu
pour le NPD de la soirée. Jack
Harris qui réussit son match
revanche contre le libéral. Il
revient à la chambre des
communes pour le NPD Saint-Jean
est.
- Une première bonne nouvelle
pour John médecine ce soir. Il
voulait ce siège.
- Dominique Leblanc est réélu
dans Beauséjour au Nouveau-
Brunswick.
- Pour un septième mandat. C'est
l'homme fort de l'Atlantique
pour Justin Trudeau.
- On parlait de famille tout à
l'heure avec Monsieur Bernier.
Lui aussi son père, très ami
avec le père Trudeau. Lawrence
MacAulay, c'était évident aussi.
Vieux routier. Il en est à son
10e mandat. Monsieur Plamondon
en a un de plus que lui.
- Il est élu sans interruption
depuis 1988.
- Geoff est réélu à Halifax. De
vieux routier. C'est son
huitième mandat.
Classement en Atlantique. Ce
qui nous donne maintenant 24
pour les libéraux, 16 pour le
parti conservateur est un élu...
six pour le parti conservateur
plutôt. Et un élu pour le NPD.
C'est une baisse de 12 % pour
les libéraux en Atlantique.
C'est important. 31 % pour les
conservateurs. 17 % pour le NPD.
Cette pour cent pour les Parti
vert et deux pour les candidats
autres ou indépendants.
Voilà pour le portrait général.
La baisse de suffrage est
importante pour les libéraux,
même s'ils maintiennent comme on
le voit leurs acquis pour
l'essentiel. C'est à suivre.
Pascal Québec, bonsoir!
Des circonscriptions à
surveiller chez vous.
- Tout à fait.
Ici en 2015, ça a vraiment été
une carte bleu foncé. On peut la
voir ensemble. Les conservateurs
au Québec ils sont en majorité
les députés ici dans la grande
région. Sur nos 11
circonscriptions en 2015, il y
en avait neuf qui appartenait au
conservateur. Évidemment que
pour les conservateurs, ils
veulent maintenir leurs acquis.
Il y a de petites taches rouges.
Joël Lightbound et Jean-Yves
Duclos dans Québec. Le bloc
n'est plus représenté dans la
grande région ici depuis la
vague orange en 2011. Par contre
on se verra ce qui pourrait se
passer. Le bloc a ciblé de
circonscriptions où il pense
pouvoir faire des gains. La
circonscription des Québec où il
y a Christiane Gagnon qui a été
élu pendant 18 ans. Le bloc
pense pouvoir percer dans ce
comté. Pour ce qui est de la
circonscription Beauport-Côte-
de-Beaupré-Île d'Orléans-
Charlevoix, Caroline Desbiens
qui affronte Sylvie Boucher et
Manon Fortin. On va suivre cela
attentivement ce soir.
- Christiane Gagnon qui veut
revenir à la chambre des
communes. Il y a beaucoup
d'match revanche ce soir.
- Il y a M. Bergeron. Madame de
Bellefeuille. Est-ce que j'en
oublie d'autres%
ce sont ces trois-là. Ils ont de
bonnes chances.
- La région de Québec ça n'a
jamais été facile pour vous.
- Ça vient et ça va. On a déjà
balayé le Québec deux fois. Ils
sont ensuite passés au
conservateur puis au NPD.
- Est-ce qu'ils avaient eu de la
difficulté à trouver des
candidats au début de la
campagne?
- C'est plus difficile au
printemps bien sûr. Madame
Gagnon s'était déjà annoncée à
ce moment-là. Si les sondages
avaient été les mêmes au
printemps quls le sont
maintenant, il y a eu plus de
monde. Ça va de soi.
- C'est vrai pour tous les
partis. Mais où il faut aussi
voir la force des organisations.
On l'a vu pour le NPD le Bloc
québécois qui sont en montée.
Quand on regarde les
conservateurs et les libéraux,
Mélanie Joly tout à l'heure, les
candidats investis ont des
objectifs de financement, et
d'identifier des électeurs pour
ne pas avoir à subir un autre
investiture ouverte. Le jour de
l'élection, le jour J et ça fait
la différence parce que tu va
identifier ton vote et tu es
capable d'aller faire sortir
l'électorat.
- Ce n'est pas toujours vrai.
- Mais ce soir on va voir si
c'est vrai.
- Les libéraux ont réussi à
avoir leur majorité parce qu'ils
ont monté le taux de
participation, particulièrement
les jeunes. Si ces gens ne
sortent pas, on peut bien
vouloir le faire sortir mais ils
ne veulent pas sortir...
- j'ai vu des machines du Bloc
bien jubiler ce coup ici avec
énormément de monde sur le
terrain. En 2011 je peux vous
dire qu'on sortait du vote qui
allait voter contre nous!
Les comtés qui ont mieux fait
été les comtés qui ont dit : on
arrête de sortir du vote parce
que notre votre participation
est plus fort. Donc il faut
relativiser.
- On parlait de Mme Brosseau.
Elle n'avait pas d'équipe.
- À la fois s'il vous plaît.
- Les machines ça compte sauf
quand il y a des mouvements
irrépressibles si on peut dire.
Comme l'ADQ en 2007. C'était
zéro machine au Québec. Les
libéraux sortaient leur vote.
- La CAQ n'avait pas une grosse
machine non plus. Un député va
en moyenne sortir 5 % par lui-
même. Mais cette pour cent peut
dire la victoire et 4 % la
défaite.
- On va savoir tout cela à neuf
heures 30 avec la fermeture.
Je rappelle que les bureaux de
scrutin au Québec dans le reste
du pays sauf la Colombie-
Britannique ferme à neuf heures
30. Donc dans une heure
exactement. On aura alors le
début des résultats. Maritimes
et Atlantique c'est intéressant
parce que ça fluctue. Il y a eu
beaucoup de courses serrées. Ça
se cristallise un peu du côté
des libéraux avec 25, 6, et un
élu pour le NPD. Il y a encore
des courses à finir. C'est loin
d'être terminé.
- Il faut quand même noter une
chose. En Nouvelle-Écosse
actuellement ses neuf libéraux,
de conservateur. Il y a des
comtés traditionnellement
conservateurs...
qui ne sont pas capables d'aller
chercher cela. Ce n'est pas de
bonne nouvelle pour les
conservateurs.
- Il y a un autre match revanche
au Nouveau-Brunswick.
...
Il mène par 48 %.
- Il y a cinq circonscriptions
où le cadre est moins de 100.
Ce qui explique que ça
permettait beaucoup. Mais vous
avez quand même remarqué que les
six reste là depuis quelques
minutes.
Les libéraux ont baissé en
suffrage pas mal. Mais il garde
leurs comtés. Si ça se
maintient, on les disait tout à
l'heure, les Maritimes c'est
important. Ça donne l'air de la
soirée. On n'a pas toutes les
réponses mais on a début de
réponse dans l'histoire que l'on
vous raconte ce soir.
- S'ils ont six les
conservateurs seront déçus. Pour
avoir le cumul de sièges
nécessaires pour les minorités,
ils doivent commencer là avec au
moins huit comtés.
- Il sera intéressant de voir si
la perte de pourcentage des
libéraux est dus au vote NPD ou
au vote conservateur.
- Les Verts aussi.
- Au Nouveau-Brunswick il y a un
vert.
- Ils sont à huit actuellement.
- La division du vote
progressiste favorise les
conservateurs évidemment.
- Très bien. Tout va bien. Vous
êtes passionné, c'est pour cela
que l'on vous a invité.
C'était charlatan qu'il ciblait
le Verts. Charlottetown.
- Vous êtes allé au Nouveau-
Brunswick faire votre mission.
- Absolument.
- Béguin pour Richard Bragdon.
Again conservateur. Ça fait
parti des six.
- Dans une circonscription qui
avait été vacante par TJ Harvey.
Traditionnellement
conservatrices cette
circonscription.
- Le Bloc québécois à zéro.
C'est que les circonscriptions
aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine sont
ouvertes. C'est pour cela que
notre affichage s'adapte et ça
vous montre que le vent arrive
vers l'Est tranquillement et les
résultats avec.
- Un autre Nouveau-Brunswick.
John Williamson qui était le
directeur des communications de
Stephen Harper qui s'était fait
battre dans son comté en 2015:1
match revanche réussi pour lui.
- Mathieu est avec Steven
Guilbeault dans Laurier Sainte
Marie. Pendant qu'on voit que
dans Acadie-Bathurst Serge
Cormier est réélu.
Steven Guilbeault a décidé de
plonger avec les libéraux.
- Tout à fait. Monsieur
Guilbault qui vient de rentrer
de faire sortir le vote.
Bonsoir!
À quel point l'environnement,
c'est le combat de votre vie. Ça
se voit même dans votre local
électoral. Sentez-vous qu'on a
assez par l'environnement durant
cette élection?
- On peut dire sans se tromper
que c'est certainement
l'élection fédérale où on n'en a
parlé le plus.
Ça été le sujet dans plusieurs
des débats. Il y a eu la grande
marche en plein milieu de cette
élection. Dans notre cas le
Parti libéral nous avons dédié
une semaine complète de la
campagne sur des engagements qui
ne portaient que sur la question
de l'environnement et des
changements climatiques.
Il y a quatre parties qui ont
beaucoup parlé d'environnement
il y en a un qui en a parlé à
peu près pas parti n'a rien à
dire sur cette question, le
parti conservateur. Je me
réjouis du fait que peu importe
le résultat de l'élection ce
soir ce sera l'élection où nous
en aurons parlé le plus.
- Est-ce que c'était un des
thèmes centraux de cette
campagne?
- Absolument.
On a cogné aux portes de plus de
12 000 personnes dans la
circonscription de Laurier
Sainte Marie.
Dans la très grande majorité des
cas, la première chose dont les
gens nous parlaient c'étaient de
l'environnement.
On est à sept ou huit personnes
sur 10 pour que la première
chose dont elle nous parlait de
l'environnement.
- Parlant environnement, la
lutte a été féroce ici. Vos
adversaires sont venus même
déposer un faux pipeline pour
rappeler l'achat du gouvernement
du pipeline Trans Mountain. À
quel point ça été plus difficile
que vous pensiez faire campagne?
- N'ayant pas d'expérience, je
n'avais pas beaucoup de
référence. C'était pas mal ceux
à quoi je m'attendais.
Que ce soit au niveau
médiatique, par rapport aux
autres parties, je suis heureux
que de façon générale, dans le
comté, les débats se sont faits
beaucoup sur la base des idées
plutôt que sur des attaques
personnelles ou ce genre de
choses.
Je pense qu'il faut s'en
réjouir. De confronter nos
idées, de faire en sorte qu'on
finisse par quelque chose de
mieux au total.
- Merci Monsieur Guilbault!
Une lutte serrée donc dans
Laurier Sainte Marie.
- Premiers résultats au Québec.
Gaspésie Les Îles de la
Madeleine, Diane Lebouthillier.
Un bureau de vote dépouillé sur
214. Son adversaire du Bloc est
un ancien maire de Gaspésie.
Fredericton, Andrea Johnson
Akeem Haynes sur la candidate
verte. C'est très proche.
Vous les disiez Michel, vous
êtes allé, vous avez de bonnes
antennes!
2e les Verts, c'est bon.
- C'est un siège vert au
provincial. On surveillait
également le siège de
Fredericton. Savamment que c'est
très serré en ce moment.
- À suivre.
Claire Kelly qui est deuxième
dans Moncton Riverview Dieppe.
- Derrière la ministre de la
santé.
- On voit cette poussée verte.
Arrivera-t-elle à se
matérialiser? Beaucoup sur la
côte ouest qu'on attendait
députer verts.
On a beaucoup parlé de la
possibilité d'un gouvernement
minoritaire. On verra. On ne
fait plus de pronostiques. Mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a
eu toutes sortes de théories
échafaudées. Est-ce que M.
Trudeau aurait le droit, s'il
avait un siège de moins que les
conservateurs, aurait-il le
droit de continuer à gouverner?
La réponse est oui. Les
conventions conditionnelles lui
permettraient. Il faudrait voir
le suffrage parce que
politiquement ce serait une
autre histoire. On n'en est pas
là mais quand même on a invité
Brian Gallant, ex-premier
ministre libéral du Nouveau-
Brunswick. Bonsoir à vous!
- Merci lévitation!
- Vous avez essayé de faire ça.
Vous aviez -2 circonscriptions
mais vous aviez plus de vote
populaire et vous vous êtes dit
: je reste premier ministre et
on va essayer
ça n'a pas marché. Avez-vous
appelé M. Trudeau en lui disant
: c'est pas mal plus compliqué
qu'on le croit?
- Lorsque l'élection a eu lieu,
nous avons gagné le vote
populaire de six points.
Mais lorsque ça venait au siège,
on avait 21 sièges contre les 22
des conservateurs. Le troisième
parti, le Parti vert et le
People Alliance ont eu trois
sièges chacun. Nous avons tenté
de voir si ça aurait été
possible de maintenir la
confiance de l'assemblée
législative. Il aurait fallu que
le Parti vert nous appuyer, ce
qu'ils ont fait ultimement 24
heures avant le vote sur le
discours du Trône. Il aura aussi
fallu qu'un conservateur, un
vrai progressiste qui ne voulait
pas former le gouvernement avec
le parti People Alliance...
alors ça n'a pas fonctionné de
notre côté mais comme vous avez
disait possible.
- Vous avez le droit de le
faire.
Mais dans la pratique n'est pas
aussi simple que cela. C'est un
peu ce que vous nous dîtes.
- Exactement.
Lors des dernières semaines,
lorsqu'on regarde les sondages
et la possibilité d'une
situation minoritaire, plusieurs
personnes est : Trudeau pourrait
peut-être former un gouvernement
avec le NPD ou le Parti vert. On
a essayé de faire cela avec le
Parti vert et ce n'était pas
facile. Essayez d'avoir deux
autres parties qui pourraient
travailler avec pour essayer
d'avoir la maintenance de la
confiance à l'assemblée
législative, ce serait plus
difficile.
Lors des dernières semaines,
j'ai fait l'argument que les
progressistes, les gens qui
veulent avoir un gouvernement
qui va être progressiste,
je pense qu'il aurait fallu
penser à leur vote et voter
stratégiquement.
Le Parti vert est souvent en 2,
Place au Nouveau-Brunswick.
- C'est Monsieur Trudeau vous
appelle dans la nuit et vous
demande si c'est une bonne idée,
vous dîtes quoi?
- J'espère qu'il va pas nous
réveiller moi et mon épouse.
Je vais certainement prendre
l'appel.
Je vais lui dire exactement
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit.
Vous avez très bien analysé.
Constitutionnellement, vous avez
le droit. Si ses proches, il
doit prendre le temps pour y
réfléchir et ne pas prendre une
décision trop vite. Qu'est-ce
que les chefs des autres parties
veulent et par une décision bien
informée dans les jours à venir.
Il a le droit de la faire.
Évidemment, techniquement
parlant, ça peut se compliquer,
mais constitutionnellement, il
aurait droit de le faire.
- Monsieur Galland, on promet
qu'on ne va pas vous réveiller à
une heure du matin si on est
devant ce scénario. Merci de
nous avoir parlé. C'est très
sympathique.
- Merci à vous. Bonne soirée.
- Catherine Gauthier est en
compagnie d'Alexandre Boulerice
du NPD. S'il y a quelqu'un
qui veut ici le NPD veut voir
quelqu'un remporter un siège au
Québec, c'était lui.
- Tout à fait, Patrice.
C'est le candidat néodémocrate
plus connu. Bonsoir. Êtes-vous
satisfait de votre campagne
électorale.
- Très satisfait. Je pense que
les néodémocrate, on est très
fier de la campagne qu'on
amenait. Une campagne positive
et constructive. On a mis de
l'avant des solutions sur
l'urgence climatique, et disons-
le, Jagmeet Singh a créé la
surprise, il s'est vraiment
dévoilé. Beaucoup de gens l'ont
découvert et ont trouvé
quelqu'un de fort sympathique,
de très humain, deux très
proches des gens et ça nous a
fait remonter partout dans les
sondages.
- Il faut le dire, c'était un de
vos défis, c'était de faire
connaître votre chef entre
autres ici au Québec. Vous être
très connu. Vous pensez que vous
avez réussi?
- Je pense qu'il a ouvert des
portes pour l'avenir, on a semé
quelque chose aujourd'hui qui va
nous servir comme progressiste
pour l'avenir. On verra les
résultats de ce soit Jagmeet
Singh a donné une très bonne
impression aux Québécois. Je
pense que les gens se sont dits
: on va écouter ce qu'il a à des
parce qu'il a l'air sincère et
authentique, il a l'air d'être
prêt à aller se battre pour
nous. On n'a pas...
- êtes-vous nerveux?
- On est toujours un peu
nerveux. Mais aujourd'hui,
j'étais dans l'épargne, au métro
Rosemont et Beaubien, la réponse
est très bonne. Mon équipe me
disait que je pouvais avoir
confiance. Mais tant que ce
n'est pas fait, ce n'est pas
fait. Ce qui ne sont pas allés
voter, vous pouvez le faire.
- Merci. Ça se passe ici au
théâtre Plazza.
Alors, on suit cela pour vous
bien sûr.
- Merci. Ça bouge en Atlantique.
Vous avez vu un vert,
apparaître, c'était à
Fredericton. Ce serait, pour les
verbes, une bouffée d'air frais
dans les maritimes pour eux
parce que nous, on ne mettait
pas cela possible. C'est très
serré. Restons calmes, mais
quand même.
- Elizabeth May s'était rendu
dans cette circonscription. Elle
y croyait. C'est finalement une
avance de 87 voit en ce moment
après le dépouillement de 15
bureaux de scrutin. Le libéral
Matt DeCourcey, qui était
secrétaire parlementaire, il est
troisième. On joue à la bascule
dans ce comté.
- C'est fort intéressant dans
Fredericton.
Voyez en Atlantique, -16 % pour
les libéraux par rapport à 2015.
Plus 11 %, une poussée des
conservateurs. -1 % pour le NPD
et plus 4 % pour le parti Vert
qui double. C'est énorme.
C'est très important
actuellement pour comprendre ce
qui est en train de se passer.
- Je vais revenir sur l'entrevue
avec le Brian Gallant et sur ce
que ferait tout Trudeau...
- pendant qu'on voit un gain
pour le parti conservateur.
- Ce que j'allais dire, c'est
que je suis convaincu que si
Monsieur Trudeau est à
l'intérieur de 10 sièges de
Monsieur Scheer, je suis pas mal
convaincu qu'ils vont rester,
ils vont tenter de gagner la
confiance de la chambre. Quand
on regarde...
Seto, on parle, on essaie de
meubler le temps.
- Mais un instant, vous dîtes
que même si le suffrage
populaire...
- selon moi, de toute façon, on
est parti pour être probablement
ou bien égal, c'est très tôt, ou
les libéraux en avance. Je parle
du nombre de sièges. Ce que je
vous dis, c'est que je pense
qu'à l'intérieur de 10 sièges,
on peut le faire jusqu'à un,
ce soir, il ne fait rien et
demain matin il nous annonce
qu'il va tenter de gagner la
confiance de la chambre.
- Il faut avoir la confiance de
la chambre.
Pour Julie Payette aussi, pour
demander aux conservateurs de
former un gouvernement, c'est
impossible mathématiquement, ça
ne ferait aucun sens. Ironie
dans tout cela, c'est que la
division du vote progressiste
entre quatre parties, les
libéraux, NPD, parti vers les
mêmes le Bloc québécois,
ce qui pourrait provoquer un
gouvernement libéral minoritaire
mais ça peut être la clé de sa
survie.
Il aurait des alliés naturels.
- Ce sont toutes des bonnes
analyses. On a eu un sursaut
quand même parce qu'une dizaine,
c'est beaucoup.
Philippe Vincent Foisy et avec
le chef de cabinet d'Andrew
Scheer. Comment on reçoit des
résultats qui pour l'instant en
tout cas son décevant pour les
conservateurs en Atlantique?
- J'ai Marc-André Leclerc avec
moi. Monsieur Leclerc, quand on
regarde les chiffres en ce
moment, est-ce que c'est
décevant par rapport à votre
objectif d'aller en chercher au
moins huit dans les provinces de
l'Atlantique?
Êtes-vous déçu en ce moment?
- Il reste des luttes encore
chaudes en ce moment, au
Nouveau-Brunswick et en
Nouvelle-Écosse. En 2015, après
les résultats en Atlantique, on
était moins de 32 %. On fait des
gains importants pour notre
parti. On est satisfait de
l'état de la situation. On sait
que les provinces de
l'Atlantique sont davantage pour
libéraux. C'est un peu normal ce
qu'on voit ce soit. On a fait
des gains qu'on n'a pas fait en
2015. C'est un bon signe pour le
reste de la soirée.
- Il y a encore de l'espoir
d'aller en chercher un peu plus?
- Il y a des courses très
importants, Fredericton - serré
et notre candidat en Nouvelle-
Écosse qui est très serrée.
On parle de même pas 200 votes
de différence. Il reste encore
beaucoup de boîtes dépouillées.
Également le votre participation
on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens convoités par anticipation
cette année et on sait que le
vote conservateur était vraiment
très fort lors du vote par
anticipation.
- Dans quel état d'esprit êtes-
vous alors que dans 45 minutes,
on va avoir le plus gros bloc de
bois qui va être dévoilé?
- C'est très excitant. C'est
pour cela qu'on fait de la
politique. On sait qu'on est
bien préparé, notre équipe sur
le terrain a travaillé fort.
Notre chef a travaillé fort. Les
candidats aussi. On est très
optimiste.
- Êtes-vous déjà en train de
planifier impossible
gouvernement minoritaire? Que
faites-vous si vous avez plus ou
moins de sièges?
- Présentement, on reste
concentré sur le 21 octobre qui
est aujourd'hui. On va avoir le
mandat. On espère avoir la
confiance d'Canada et ces gens
font confiance à Monsieur
Scheer, et qui va être prête
demain matin à aller de l'avant.
Merci.
- Voilà, c'était le chef de
cabinet de Andrew Scheer.
- Il ne va pas dire que tout va
mal et qu'il est découragé à la
télé nationale. Ce sont des gens
qui travaillent jour et nuit là-
dessus. Miramichi Grand Lake,
Peggy McLean qui creuse son
avance sur le libéral.
Voilà un exemple de gain
possible. Nova Ouest, Chris
d'Entremont qui est en avance
sur Jason Deveau, libéral.
- Ministre sur la scène
provinciale, un Acadien assez
connu.
- La situation en Atlantique
maintenant. 25 élus ou en tête
pour les libéraux, cinq pour les
conservateurs, s'est redescendu,
une circonscription pour le NPD
et une circonscription à
Fredericton pour le parti Vert.
C'est intéressant.
C'est certain que c'est décevant
pour les conservateurs.
- En Nouvelle-Écosse
particulièrement.
Ils ont encore des luttes. Mais
en Nouvelle-Écosse, ou nouveau
bandeau, ils ont bien fait. Mais
il faut voir si l'autre province
va changer un peu. Autrement,
c'est décevant.
- Mais tout n'est pas noir.
Les libéraux en ont quand même
perdu cette. Il faut regarder
les deux plans.
- Cependant, il faut dire dans
une perspective d'une division
du vote progressiste, le vote
conservateur aurait pu passer et
en faire plus.
C'est quand même décevant.
- On parle de nombreux comté
qu'on perdu les libéraux.
- On n'a jamais vu je le
rappelle les conservateurs au
gouvernement avec moins de neuf
sièges en Atlantique.
- Ça fait plusieurs fois que
vous le dîtes. Mais il n'y a
rien de magique là-dedans.
S'ils sont à sept, on peut quand
même continuer la soirée.
- Rien n'est terminé, nous avons
en fait pas.
- C'est pour ça que je suis de
ce côté-ci de la table.
- On va aller au Saguenay-Lac-
Saint-Jean parce que vraiment,
il y a trois luttes à suivre ce
soit. Jean-François Coulombe est
à Alma.
- Bonsoir Patrice.
Bien malin qui peut réduire
l'issue du scrutin ici au
Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean parce
que la région apportait à peu
près toutes les couleurs
politiques depuis les 15
dernières années. Bien sûr, ça a
été pendant longtemps un fief
bloquiste, mais ce n'est plus le
cas. Sous le gouvernement
Harper, la région avait été
conservatrice aux deux tiers
avec les députés et ministre
Jean-Pierre Blackburn et Denis
Lebel. En 2011, la vague orange
a permis aux parties
néodémocrate de faire élire des
députés dans deux des trois
circonscriptions de la région.
Et depuis 2015, Saguenay-Lac-
Saint-Jean et tricolore avec un
candidat sortant libéral, un
conservateur et une
néodémocrate. Ce qu'on surveille
ici ce soir, c'est est-ce que le
Bloc québécois va effectuer un
retour au Saguenay-Lac-Saint-
Jean dans une région où il est
absent depuis presque 10 ans?
Une région qui est considérée
comme souverainiste. Est-ce que
les candidats sortants vont
réussir à conserver leur siège?
Rien n'est moins sûr parce qu'on
prévoit des luttes série
particulièrement ici dans l'axe
Saint-Jean où on s'attend à une
lutte à trois entre le candidat
libéral Richard Hébert, candidat
conservateur et le candidat
bloquistes Alexis Brunelle-
Duceppe qui espère se faire un
prénom ce soit parce
qu'évidemment, il est bien connu
comme étant le fils de Gilles
Duceppe. Lancé chef du Bloc
québécois est venu à plusieurs
reprises lui prêter main-forte
au cours de cette campagne.
- Il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant.
- Gilles Duceppe, on n'y
reviendra, votre fils qui lutte
sur le terrain.
Mais déjà, les résultats
d'abord. La Gaspésie, les îles
de la Madeleine, Guy Pernety qui
a prie l'avance.
- Par 14 voix devant la ministre
sortante Diane Bouthiller. On
compte en ce moment les compter
aux îles de la Madeleine. C'est
pour ça qu'on a les premiers
résultats au Québec parce que
les et de la Madeleine sont
comptés plutôt que les autres et
on joue à la bascule parce que
tout à l'heure, c'était Diane
Bouthiller qui menait et
maintenant c'est Guy Pernety qui
a prie la place.
- Le maire de Saint Maxime du
Montlouis en Gaspésie. Enraciné
dans sa communauté. Une ministre
qui potentiellement pourrait
être en danger, une ministre
libéral. À suivre. Julie
Marceau, bonsoir à vous.
- Bonsoir Patrice.
- Vous êtes avec le chef du Bloc
québécois.
- On se trouve dans un hôtel du
centre-ville de Montréal ou
Monsieur Blanchet écoute la
soirée électorale en compagnie
de sa femme, de certains de ses
enfants. Il a donc accepté de
nous accorder une entrevue ce
soir. Bonsoir.
J'ai envie de vous demander, ça
a pris cinq mois pour vous
convaincre de vous lancer, de
devenir chef du Bloc québécois,
votre chef de cabinet, il a
travaillé très fort. Qu'est-ce
qui a été le point tournant?
- Il y a probablement plusieurs
point tournant. Au niveau de
l'émotion probablement aux
funérailles de Monsieur Landry
où on sentait beaucoup de
souverainiste parmi les plus
actifs était rassemblé et
partagé en comme un moment de
tristesse. L'élection du 1er
octobre a été un facteur
important parce qu'avant qu'on
ait vu l'orientation plus
qu'honorable du gouvernement
Legault et la défaite cuisante
pour le Parti québécois et donc
l'souverainiste, ces facteurs se
sont mis ensemble plus certaines
sollicitations et probablement
qui restait un peu de politique
dans le bonhomme.
Après des consultations
relativement courtes avec ma
douce, ça a complété la
réflexion.
- Sur le coup, il y avait des
réticences. Vous saviez que vous
embarquez dans une aventure
extrêmement risquée?
- Mais pour reprendre
l'expression américaine, je
voyais un chemin, je ne sais pas
où il va nous mener, on va le
savoir tous ensemble ce soir
mais je voyais un chemin entre
cette espèce de regain d'un fort
sentiment national québécois, un
sentiment que je considère
encore aujourd'hui comme modéré,
un sentiment qui est légitime, à
la limite souriant de l'apport
des Québécois. On sentait le
début de cela et ça ouvrait la
voie, la possibilité pour
ramener ce qui pour moi est un
outil fondamental à plusieurs
égards, le Bloc québécois et le
véhicule d'un projet futur pour
le Québec mais c'est se donné la
cohérence de ne pas faire à
Ottawa le contrat des décisions
qu'on a prises avec enthousiasme
au Québec.
- J'ai vu littéralement avec
vous dans la caravane, se
transformer l'ambiance avant et
après les débats. Qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus surpris durant
cette campagne?
- Le moment des débats était un
test que je vais traverser moi-
même. C'est un facteur important
mais je pense que le véritable
virage de la campagne donc on
mesurera ce soir l'envergure,
c'est qu'on a arrêté de tirer
les Québécois vers nous avec des
idées et des propositions. Il y
a un grand nombre, mais pas
tous, un grand nombre de
Québécois qui se sont mis à nous
pousser, qui ont adopté le parti
on le sentait sur le terrain
que les gens poussaient derrière
nous en grand nombrent.
- Le seuil de 20 sièges, est-ce
qu'il a changé?
- Il assure la pérennité du Bloc
québécois. On est conscient
qu'on peut espérer davantage.
- Merci Monsieur Blanchet et
bonne chance dans cette course.
Bonne fin de campagne.
Monsieur Blanchet qui avec sa
famille va se déplacer afin de
surprendre au théâtre national
où il va y avoir une bonne file
d'attente, beaucoup de gens qui
vont se rassembler. Ce sont des
places où il peut avoir 500
personnes. Il y a deux bars qui
ont été prévus si ça déborde. On
verra.
- Merci beaucoup. Merci pour
votre travail sur le terrain
tout au long de la campagne. On
apprécie. Dans Moncton Riverview
Dieppe, Ginette Taylor Petitpas,
ministre de la santé, c'est
réglé au Nouveau-Brunswick.
- Elle avait été élue par plus
de 19 000 voix en 2015, ne porte
avance. On s'attendait à ce
qu'elle soit élue ce soir.
- C'était une circonscription
qui n'était pas en danger pour
les libéraux.
Vous voyez le compte, toujours
le parti vert qui mène toujours
dans Fredericton, le 1 pour le
parti vert. Jack Harris qui est
revenu au NPD. Les libéraux en
ont 25 par les conservateurs en
ont six. Perte en pourcentage et
en circonscription pour les
libéraux. Mais si ça reste,
c'est le portrait restait comme
celui-là, Madeleine, ce sont des
pat libéraux escomptés?
- Ils espéraient limiter les
pertes à cinq ou six sièges ce
soir, c'est ce qu'on constate.
C'est quand même un début de
soirée qui se déroule assez
bien. On limite les dégâts mêmes
si on baisse en termes d'appui.
Ça ne se matérialise pas
toujours en termes de siège. Un
siège, c'est un siège, peu
importe combien de voix on l'a
emporté.
- Ils inséraient un Moncton au
Nouveau-Brunswick, le parti
vert, on n'en a parlé, il
pourrait faire un gain
Fredericton?
- On le savait tout le long de
cette campagne qu'il fallait
vérifier cette circonscription.
La candidate a été soutenue par
l'équipe provinciale, le chef a
été élu là-bas au provincial.
L'équipe a fait campagne avec
elle. Elle a fait une bonne
campagne. On a senti tout au
long qu'elle faisait des gains,
elle gagne en popularité.
C'était à surveiller.
Visiblement, selon les
résultats, elle devrait gagner
son siège. On n'est pas tout
surpris. Ce qui est surprenant,
c'est que le libéral sortant à
l'air d'être en troisième
position derrière la
conservatrice. Une perte
- Très bien avec désespoir à
Charlottetown à l'Île-du-Prince-
Édouard pour les verts.
Ça se matérialise pas pour
l'instant?
- Non pas du tout c'est le
candidat libéral Thierry lui
dans cette conception à
Charlottetown, mais oui en effet
on avait de grands espoirs pour
cette candidate une femme aussi
à Charlottetown, ça ne se
concrétise pas de ce côté.
Il n'y avait pas d'autres
espoirs ici en Atlantique pour
le Parti vert dans Avalon.
C'est un candidat très connu un
acteur connu dans cette
province.
- Merci beaucoup Elisa.
Il y a des gens qui veulent nous
parler, nous sommes ouverts et
merci beaucoup, à tout de suite
on va continuer de surveiller ce
qui se passe chez nous.
Jacaudrey Charbonneau est devant
un bureau de vote à Montréal.
Jacaudrey, en a parlé beaucoup
plutôt, la sortie de qui n'est
pas terminé, à neuf heures et
demie pour le Québec l'Ontario
et les autres Colombie-
Britannique, ça s'est plutôt
bien déroulé?
- Oui, ça continue de bien se
déroulait je parlais tout à
l'heure avec un porte-parole
d'élections Canada, on nous
disait qu'il y a des petits
problèmes ici et là, mais c'est
assez anecdotique pour le
moment. En voit tout de même que
les files sont de moins en moins
longues. On faisait remarquer
qu'un autre bureau de vote il y
avait encore des files d'attente
qui allait jusqu'à l'extérieur,
on m'a confirmé du côté
d'élections Canada que si vous
présentez un bureau de scrutin
avant 21 heures 30, avant
l'heure à laquelle les bureaux
vont fermer, vous allez pouvoir
voter même si vous êtes dans la
file d'attente, donc ça pourrait
prolonger un petit peu le
processus qu'on a beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui du fait que la
parole et aux électeurs
aujourd'hui, je ne sais pas si
on est en mesure d'en écouter
quelques-uns.
- La démocratie est importante
et il faut le signifier en
votant.
- Pour faire valoir ce qu'on
veut comme société.
- Étrangement cette année ça été
particulièrement difficile,
ça a changé.
- Je sais pas pour qui encore,
non je vais décider.
- Je repars presser mais je suis
pas sûr que je vais gagner.
- Je ne peux pas gagner.
- C'est important pour nous pour
voter.
- Pour remplir notre devoir.
- À 85 ans j'en ai déjà fait
des X.
- Donc le moins terminant
Patrice sur le vote par
installation on a beaucoup parlé
près de 5 millions de Canadiens
qui ont voté entre le 11 et le
14 octobre, une nette
augmentation particularité cette
année, on a commencé le
dépouillement une heure avant la
fermeture des votes qui
pourraient faciliter votre
travail, accélérer le processus
des résultats. Je vous le
rappelle 21 heures 30 la
fermeture des bureaux de vote au
Québec.
- Ce qui donne le ton à des gens
qui habitent près d'un bureau de
vote dit aller, il reste 28
minutes.
- Il n'y a personne à Laurier
Sainte Marie.
- C'est très bien merci
beaucoup. À plus tard.
C'est amusant de vous entendre
de parler du vote de
l'importance de votre salle de
moment sacré, c'est la parole
aux citoyens pendant qu'on voit
que Bernadette Jordan est réélue
Madeleine, une large majorité
dans South Shore St. Margarets.
- C'était la première femme
ministre dans l'histoire
Nouvelle-Écosse, ministre
fédéral, c'est important pour
elle cette toi parce qu'elle
n'était pas qui était une
circonscription
traditionnellement
conservatrice.
- Merci Madeleine!
Nova Centre Sean Fraser qui est
réélue pour les libéraux une
confortable avance.
Pour ce qui était plutôt George
Canyon.
- Il était en tournée.
- C'est un espoir conservateur,
Tasha?
- Oui c'est un parachute et des
gens dans le comté qui n'était
pas content.
Il peut retourner à Calgary.
Si je peux me permettre de
souligner une chose intéressante
dans un autre comté, la
différence entre libéral et
conservateur, ce n'est pas
décidé s'est représenté par le
parti populaire. Si ça tient,
ça voudrait dire que les
conservateurs, ce siège qu'il
voulait, peut-être qu'ils ont
perdu.
- On ne voit pas le vote de
Maxime Bernier parce qu'il est
plus loin derrière.
Mais vous dites que ça pourrait,
ce serait le cauchemar d'Andrew
Scheer, ça pourrait faire une
différence.
- Le candidat du parti de Maxime
Bernier est au-dessus de 400
voix, si ça se maintient, ça
pourrait vouloir dire que le
parti de Maxime Vanina
aucuneChance de l'emporter,
mais s'il gruge 400 voix au
conservateur...
- Avec la très mauvaise fin de
campagne de Andrew Scheer avec
les accusations de Maxime
Bernier, de campagne salissage
le Parti conservateur, ça
pourrait avoir aidé M. Bernier.
- On aura le temps de faire tous
ces bilans et ses analyses.
Pascale Lacombe est au
rassemblement des conservateur
et Québec, elle est avec Pierre
Paul-Hus.
- Exactement Patrice, vous
sollicitez un deuxième mandat
dans Charlesbourg, il y a des
militants qui sont déjà l'on est
à une demi-heure de la
fermeture.
- Je me sens très bien. Dans la
région de Québec de la matière
conception je pense que ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on a
fait une bataille électorale
très profonde aide de différents
débats d'idées mais il n'y a pas
eu d'attaque vicieuse, je
trouvais ça intéressant de
pouvoir faire campagne dans la
région de Québec, chacun avait
ses idées et maintenant on va
voir ce que la population a
décidé.
- Est-ce qu'il y a un peu de
nervosité avec le bloc qui tente
de percer dans la grande région
de Québec. Vous parliez aussi,
il n'y a pas eu d'attaque à
Québec entamé dernièrement fait
on en a parlé de votre chef de
ce qui est arrivé avec le parti
populaire, est-ce qu'il y a un
peu de nervosité qu'il y ait des
gains?
- Envoient comme tout le monde
le sondage mais il reste que la
réalité terrain peut être
différente. On a beaucoup, les
électeurs lorsqu'on parle aux
gens, on a des versions
différentes. Le vrai sondage va
être ce soir. On va voir. Pour
la région de Québec je crois que
les gens de la région de Québec
sont bien avec les conservateurs
en a une superbe équipe dans la
région. On a fait des projets à
l'époque. On a été présent pour
la région Québec avec l'ancien
gouvernement conservateur. Les
gens comprennent qu'avec des
membres du gouvernement, peut-
être futur gouvernement
conservateur, on va être bien
servi. Pour nous, bien entendu
de la population générale passe
le message : pourquoi on irait
avec le petit qu'on resterait
pas avec les conservateurs qui
nous servent très bien.
- On verra tout à l'heure les
bureaux ferme dans 30 minutes.
Dans la région de Québec je
tiens à vous rappeler qu'il y a
huit députés sortants
conservateurs dans nos
circonscriptions.
- Merci.
Fredericton on n'y revient à
cette avance pour le Parti vert,
Jenica Atwin. Fort intéressant
Madeleine pour les verts.
- Oui et les libéraux, les
députés sortants et troisièmes
dans cette circonscription.
Si on peut regarder ceux à quoi
ça ressemble sur la carte,
voyez c'était tout rouge en
2015, l'on a se siège vert ici à
Fredericton s'est entouré de
siège conservateur en ce moment
qui sont en avance. Donc c'est
ici que ça fait le plus mal pour
le Parti libéral, ses pertes en
ce moment sont surtout essuyées
dans cette région du Nouveau-
Brunswick.
- Très bien on va aller voir
Laurence Martin qui est au
rassemblement des verts, pendant
qu'on voit Élisabeth mais
arrivée à ce rassemblement.
Elle est en Colombie-
Britannique, une longue soirée
pour Mme May qui aux dires d'à
peu près tous les analystes a
quand même pas fait la campagne
qu'on imaginait. En tout cas pas
produit les gains qu'on verra ce
soir, qu'on imaginait.
Parce que rappelez-vous des
blondes et qu'elle allait
remplacer le NPD et qu'elle
allait devancer le NPD,
c'était la course pour la 3,
Place et ça ne s'est pas
matérialisé.
- J'ai pensé la même chose que
ce serait l'élection des verts
avec toutes les questions
environnementales soulevées par
l'hypocrisie de M. Trudeau sur
les pipelines aurait bénéficié
au vert. Mais je pense que
Jagmeet Singh a volé de son élan
et Mme May n'a pas fait de
bonnes performances dans les
débats.
- L'arrivée de dentelle n'a pas
aidé non plus. Elle fait du
dérapage politique pendant
quelques jours et André qu'elle
ne s'en est jamais remis, ni
dans les débats en français, en
anglais, c'était presque
pathétique à certains égards.
Très mauvaise campagne.
Pourtant, elle avait la cause
pour elle cette campagne.
- On va l'écouter.
Laurence, allez-y!
- On a réussi à l'attraper.
Mme May, vous êtes en avance
dans la circonscription de
Fredericton, ça doit vous faire
très plaisir.
- Oui j'ai hâte à une victoire
beaucoup d'énergie
d'enthousiasme, j'ai passé le
temps dans cette campagne.
Et je pense que... je suis pas
surprise mais nous sommes comme
ça et nous restons comme ça
pour tout le reste de cette
soirée extraordinaire.
- Qu'est-ce que ça peut changer
pour vous d'avoir maintenant
peut-être un député en
Atlantique, est-ce que vous
vouliez durant cette campagne
loups de la de la Colombie-
Britannique?
- Absolument et nous sommes
partout au Canada au niveau
provincial, Ile-du-Prince-
Édouard, aussi au Nouveau-
Brunswick, Ontario.
On doit aussi avoir les députés
au niveau fédéral partout au
Canada. Et j'espère pour une
victoire à Fredericton peut-être
aussi à l'Île-du-Prince-Édouard,
nous restons comme ça!
- Beaucoup de gens ont critiqué
votre campagne. Vous êtes
spontané pas toujours centré sur
votre message. Qu'est-ce que
vous en avez pensé de votre
campagne?
- Je pense que j'ai fait une
bonne campagne. Je pense que
c'est pas un problème de dire
les mémos à chaque fois.
Je pense que les citoyens, les
électeurs sont tellement plates
avec les leaders qui disent
toujours les mêmes messages.
Je réponds aux questions en
honnêtement, c'est important
pour moi de respecter les
acteurs du Canada.
- Quatrième campagne électorale
est-ce que c'est votre dernière
campagne?
- Pas du tout.
- Pas du tout?
- Non je vais rester député pour
plus longtemps que seulement que
2023. Je sais pas si je vais
faire l'autre campagne comme
leader mais je suis vraiment
contente et je suis engagée
pour le meilleure forme de
représentation pour les
électeurs partout au Canada.
- Merci Mme mais voilà en direct
de Victoria Patrice.
- Merci très intéressant. Elle
lui a demandé si c'est la
dernière fois. Oh! que non!
Gaspésie-Les Îles-de-la-
Madeleine. Regardez, Mme
Lebouthillier qui passe en
deuxième qui est candidat pour
le Bloc québécois.
On rappelle que les Îles de la
Madeleine c'est une demi-heure
avant. Je vous le souligna la
maison, Mesdames et Messieurs,
c'est dans 20 minutes,
on aura l'avalanche de
résultats, Québec Ontario et les
prairies jusqu'en Colombie-
Britannique. Et une demi-heure
plus tard la Colombie-
Britannique. Donc ça va aller
assez rapidement.
Alec?
- C'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les verts Fredericton mais une
mauvaise nouvelle pour les
conservateurs parce que les
libéraux pensaient perdre cette
circonscription. C'est aussi bon
pour les libéraux que les verts
l'emporte, c'est un gain pour
les conservateurs. Dès le comme
celle-là on va surveiller le
vote des verts ou le pot de
Maxime Bernier, mais ça veut pas
dire que c'est pas dans la
colonne des rouges que ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle. Je pense
qu'il y a des libéraux qui sont
contents de voir que les verts
sont bien.
- J'allais vous dire je partage
pas l'avis des analystes sur la
campagne d'Élisabeth May.
Je regarde son vote populaire
pour l'instant qui impressionne.
Elle n'était pas seule à
défendre l'environnement. Deux
il y avait d'autres personnes
qui s'emportaient à la défense,
et manifestement, voulait qu'on
adopte des mesures
environnementales beaucoup plus
agressives. Et troisièmement,
elle a aussi peut-être, c'est
tout, elle sera peut-être
victime d'un vote stratégique ùu
des gens se sont dits : belle
campagne, c'est intéressant si
je vote pour elle peut-être que
les consommateurs vont se
glisser entre les deux.
- Je pense pas qu'on peut dire
qu'elle a fait une belle
campagne. Si tu regardes le vote
populaire des verts depuis trois
élections, ça baisse. Dernière
élection 3,5 %. En Atlantique.
Mais au national...
- C'est quoi faire une belle
campagne en 2019? Tu n'as pas de
moyens et pas d'avion.
- C'est pas de contredire...
- Tout le monde a eu des
problèmes avec ses candidats,
Tasha.
- Élisabeth mais ce n'est pas sa
première campagne c'est la
doyenne des chefs et les gens
l'attendaient le momentum était
là avant la campagne, elle a
réussi à faire élire, le nouveau
député, on s'attendait. Ce
devait être son moment.
- Tu penses qu'elle allait
prendre le pouvoir?
- C'était le moment où les
changements climatiques allaient
être l'affaire.
- Très bien!
À la fois s'il vous plaît!
Gilles Duceppe, conclusion.
- Quand on regarde le cadre
budgétaire, ça n'a pas de sens.
D'avoir lancé sa campagne
Victoria, ils sont venus
dénoncer le déversement de 8
milliards de litres d'eau usée à
Montréal alors qu'Victoria,
il y a même pas d'usine
d'épuration, c'est à tous les
jours que les eaux usées sont
déversées, et c'est Stephen
Harper qui a forcé la
construction d'une usine
d'épuration à Victoria parce que
les Américains en avaient assez
de recevoir les eaux usées de
Victoria. C'est un peu comme si
Justin Trudeau avait annoncé sa
loi sur les armes dans un champ
de tir.
- Très bien alors des images en
direct de Mme Petitpas Taylor
qui a gagné facilement sa
circonscription, dans son cas.
Et qui est très heureuse, vous
le voyez. Évidemment tout ça,
c'est une question d'attente.
Au début de la campagne on et
malgré tout que les verts avait
une possibilité de doubler le
NPD c'est dans ce sens,
on verra le nombre de sièges. La
soirée est jeune. Elle n'a pas
réussi en tout cas à s'imposer à
ce niveau-là compte tenu de ses
attentes. Christian Noël vous
est au rassemblement NPD.
Comment on trouve le début de
soirée, Christian?
- On aurait aimé aller chercher
davantage de gain en Atlantique
on a gagné Saint-John East.
Il s'était balayé par l'vague
Roger maintenant qu'il reprend
son siège. On aurait aimé aller
chercher Halifax, l'ancien siège
et aller chercher d'autres
sièges comme Acadie-Bathurst.
L'ancien siège d'Yvon Godin.
C'est un début de campagne,
début de soirée lent pour eux
en Atlantique. Le NPD espère
faire des gains dans cette
région, et ensuite ça la
province où ils ont le plus de
sièges en Colombie-Britannique
avec 14 présentement, c'est là
qu'on espérait aller chercher
des gains, ici à Barnabé les
gens commencent à arriver et
commencent à espérer d'avoir une
remontée du NPD. On l'avait
rayé, on avait donné l'étiquette
de négliger à Jagmeet Singh au
début campagne. C'est une force
à surveiller. Ça commence
lentement en Atlantique.
- Très bien.
Il y a des courses serrées,
voyez le Parti conservateur est
passé à six, Miramichi Grand
Lake ou Peggy McLean April
avance sur Pat Finnigan.
Ça joue aussi et c'est très
serré, ça explique la modulation
du chiffre pour les
conservateurs. Sydney Victoria
autre exemple pour Eddie Orrell.
Il est en avance pour l'instant
sur le libéral.
- C'est très serré et j'aime
Baptiste avais dû s'excuser
pendant la campagne pour des
propos racistes.
- Françoise?
- C'était un solide libéral. Ça,
ce serait une surprise et une
grosse perte.
Zann qui est en avance mais de
plus sur les conservateurs.
Ça aussi ça pourrait changer.
Les conservateurs doivent prier.
Ginette Petitpas Taylor ministre
de la santé qui a été réélu.
Elle est en compagnie d'Elisa
Serret.
- Mme Petitpas Taylor
félicitations.
- Je me sens vraiment excité
c'est une belle journée je dois
féliciter tous nos bénévoles
c'est un travail d'équipe et
j'ai été choyé d'avoir une
équipe exceptionnelle
qui m'entoure. Non seulement
durant l'élection mais durant
les derniers quatre ans je suis
contente.
- Il y a une lutte plus chaudron
avec la candidate verte, Mme
Kelly a mené une bonne campagne
avez-vous eu chaud?
- On a tous menés une belle
campagne mais il fallait
travailler fort et dès ma
première élection, ça a toujours
été mon attitude ça va
continuer.
- On a perdu quelques sièges
libéraux en Atlantique
contrairement en 2015.
- Il faudra prendre du temps
pour récapituler pour voir ce
qui est passé mais encore une
fois aujourd'hui je tiens à
remercier tous les candidats
de tous les partis qui se sont
présentés. Ça prend du courage
pour mettre son nom sur un
bulletin et on doit remercier
tous les candidats ainsi que
tous les bénévoles qui ont
travaillé très dur pour
s'assurer qu'on puisse continuer
à avoir une belle démocratie au
Canada.
- Si votre parti est au pouvoir,
pensez-vous être ministre?
- On verra.
J'ai bien hâte de continuer à
travailler pour représenter ma
circonscription, la belle
circonscription.
- Merci beaucoup Mme Petitpas
Taylor. Voilà Patrice.
(applaudissements)
- C'est bien!
Alors oui les applaudissements.
De ce côté vous avait connu ça.
C'est des moments...
- C'est des gens qui sont là
parce qu'ils t'aiment et qu'ils
ont travaillé pendant 40 jours à
faire des téléphones aller
rencontrer des électeurs.
On verra la suite pour le Parti
libéral. C'est une ministre
réélu, les gens sont contents
donc il faut prendre la victoire
quand ça passe.
- Quand on voit ses résultats,
par exemple au Nouveau-Brunswick
s'il y a des Acadiens en telle
partie du comté,
ça fait influencer les résultats
qu'on a qui peuvent être plus en
faveur de voter pour un parti
que notre.
14 Gaspésie Les Îles de la
Madeleine, les votes...
ça change.
- Guy Bernatchez est en avance.
C'est plus significatif.
- Les anglophones votés pour les
libéraux. Ça va de soi.
- Madame Petitpas Taylor qui a
dit : on est quand même notre
visage sur le poteau. C'est un
engagement.
- C'est mieux que le poteau dans
le visage!
- Vous avez connu les deux,
Gilles!
- Je me sens un petit peu
coupable.
C'est pas évident. C'est des
émotions absolument incroyables.
Autant la victoire que la
défaite. J'ai connu les deux. Je
les ai vécus de près avec les
gens qui donnent. En fait, il y
en a que je connais qui prenais
leurs vacances à leurs frais
pour venir travailler pour toi.
Quand tu vois des choses comme
ça, j'ai un de mes amis qui
étaient partis du Yukon pour
venir travailler pour moi.
Cette force à demeurer humble.
Et en même temps, ces gens
souffrent avec toi ou sont
heureux de façon exponentielle
avec toi quand tu gagnes. Et tu
les vis toi aussi comme candidat
ses émotions. Ce n'est pas toi
que tu penses, tu as toute ta
gang.
- C'est important de rappeler
cela.
Quelle courtoisie!
- Il faut se rappeler. Il y aura
beaucoup de gagnants ce soir
mais il y a beaucoup de gens qui
perdront aussi ce soir. Il y a
des gens là-dedans qui ne sont
pas des prix Nobel consentants
mais il y en a beaucoup qui
aurait fait d'excellents
candidats et candidates. J'ai
affronté dans des débats des
gens avec des points de vue très
différents des miens mais des
gens qui étaient aussi engagés
et intéressés. Il s'était autant
donné que moi. C'est toujours
impressionnant de rencontrer des
gens qui sont aussi passionnés
de politique.
- On va y revenir. La soirée est
jeune encore. Dans une douzaine
de minutes maintenant nous
aurons... moins de huit minutes,
pardonnez-moi, on aura tous les
résultats qui vont entrer
rapidement du Québec, du reste
du Canada jusqu'à Colombie-
Britannique. À 10 heures, ce
sont les derniers résultats de
la soirée.
On aura un aperçu Madeleine avec
vous de ce qui a changé dans les
Maritimes et Atlantique.
- On peut faire un petit bilan
si vous voulez. Internatde et
Labrador en ce rappel de ses
gains Saint-Jean est pour le
parti NPD. Le Parti libéral a
sauvé les meubles. Il a conservé
six de ses sept
circonscriptions. Ce n'est pas
aussi rose pour le Parti libéral
dans d'autres provinces
Atlantique. Au Nouveau-
Brunswick, il y a jusqu'ici
quatre pertes aux mains du parti
conservateur est une perte en
voie d'être confirmé aux mains
du Parti vert. Ce serait
vraiment une entrée du Parti
vert sur la scène fédérale. Mais
ce siège sur la scène
provinciale est déjà détenu par
le Parti vert.
En Nouvelle-Écosse jusqu'à
maintenant on voit qu'il y a
deux endroits où le parti
conservateur mène. C'est dans
Nova-Ouest et dans Sydney
Victoria. Ce sont deux sièges
qui avaient été laissés vacants
parce que le député sortant ne
se représente pas. Dans trois
circonscriptions où les
conservateurs mettent en
Atlantique les autres
circonscriptions qui avaient été
vacantes parce que le député
sortant avait décidé de ne pas
tenter leur chance à nouveau
cette fois-ci.
- Il y a un tableau qui est très
parlant. Regardez. En Atlantique
au complet pour les libéraux,
c'est une perte de -8, c'est-à-
dire -1 circonscription interne
des Labrador au profit du NPD.
Île-du-Prince-Édouard, ça reste
inchangé pour les libéraux.
Nouvelle-Écosse, -2 - 5 au
Nouveau-Brunswick.
C'est là que Justin Trudeau a
connu les pertes de la soirée.
Et ça va à peu près rester comme
ça Madeleine, même s'il y a une
lutte à finir.
- Il y avait celle de Sydney
Victoria que l'on suivait tout à
l'heure parce que c'était très
serré. Ça a basculé plusieurs
fois pendant la soirée. En ce
moment il y a toujours 67 voix
d'avance pour le parti
conservateur. C'est très peu.
- Ça nous donne envie d'avoir
les résultats du reste du pays
parce qu'il y a une histoire qui
commence à se raconter. Baisse
du vote populaire pour les
libéraux, mais on maintient les
châteaux forts, on maintient les
acquis dans une mesure quand
même appréciable. C'est
intéressant.
- C'est un reflet finalement
assez fidèle de ce qui se
dessinait dans les derniers
jours, recule un peu du Parti
libéral, mais pas tant que ça.
Les Verts qui font quelques
percées, les conservateurs qui
en font néanmoins qu'il l'aurait
espéré.
Pour le moment, ça ressemble à
ce qu'on s'était raconté dans
les derniers jours. Ce que les
sondages disaient aussi.
- Le vote libéral et efficace
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas
trop de vote perdu. Tous les
votes sont importants mais par
exemple quand on va arriver dans
les prairies, ils ont des scores
comme 60 % en Alberta. Ça ne
leur donne pas plus de compter.
Le vote conservateur est plus
concentré. Le vote libéral est
plus efficace, donc donne plus
de compter. Ça risque d'être
l'histoire de la soirée.
- En 2015, ce balayage rouge de
l'Atlantique était quand même
exception à la règle.
- On ne s'attendait pas du côté
des libéraux à faire cet
exploit. C'était quelque chose
d'anormal. Trudeau père avait
fait ça au Québec.
- On a vu ce que ça a donné!
(rires)
- je crois qu'on va avoir la
vraie bataille beaucoup plus en
Ontario et en Colombie
Britannique. Ce sont des
populations plus homogènes.
Le vote au Québec est divisé.
Ils ont eu être à égalité 33 et
33, on regarde chez les
francophones, le bloque selon
les sondages, et à 40. Alors
qu'en Ontario et en Colombie-
Britannique ça va se jouer avec
une population plus homogène.
- On va aller à Sherbrooke.
Dans Compton Stanstead, notre
collègue Marie-Hélène et avec
une ministre, Marie-Claude
Bibeau.
- Exactement. Je suis accompagné
de Marie-Claude Bibeau. Ministre
de l'agriculture.
Vous avez un rassemblement de
militants ici.
(applaudissements)
- ça se passe bien. J'ai une
équipe extraordinaire.
C'est vraiment l'environnement
qui nous a allumé pendant ce
mois et demi.
- Une campagne assez difficile.
- C'est vraiment l'équipe qui me
portait et que je portais. La
dynamique a été extraordinaire
avec ces jeunes, je le répète
parce que c'était particulier.
On avait quelques personnes de
grande expérience. Mais comme
vous pouvez voir en ce moment
ils sont plein d'énergie!
(applaudissements)
- il y a quand même le Bloc
québécois qui a une percée.
- C'est une réalité mais
j'espère que les québécoises ont
rendu compte que c'est important
d'avoir une voix forte du côté
où les décisions se prennent.
C'est sûr que j'ai hâte de voir
les résultats un peu plus tard
ce soir.
- Les bureaux de vote qui ferme
dans quelques instants. On
reviendra certainement un peu
plus tard dans la soirée.
- Elle a comme tout le monde qui
nous écoute, d'avoir les
résultats d'un à peu près tout
le pays. 263 circonscriptions
qui vont être déployées dans
exactement une minute 15
secondes. Très rapidement parce
que le vote par anticipation a
quand même été important. Donc
ils avaient une heure avant pour
le compter. On nous a promis, on
verra si ça se concrétise,
d'obtenir parla plus de
résultats plus rapidement dans
les circonscriptions. À voir.
Dans un milieu donnera un
portrait précis de ou on s'en va
avec cette soirée électorale. En
tout cas je ne sais pas pour
vous mais moi j'ai très hâte.
On dirait que ça fait 40 jours
qu'on attend ça, 40 jours
comptaient presque sur place, en
tout cas au niveau des deux
grands partis. Il y a une
histoire du Bloc québécois qui
est venue mêler les cartes au
niveau québécois et qui broya
peut-être les cartes pour un
gouvernement majoritaire. On
verra.
Vivement les résultats.
- Pour reprendre l'expression de
Mélanie Joly : il y a de la
fébrilité dans l'air!
- C'est au Québec que ça va se
corser. En Atlantique c'est
assez fidèle au sondage. On
savait que les libéraux allaient
remporter la majorité. Mais au
Québec les batailles vont être
très serrées. En Ontario ici, le
nombre de sièges mais aussi la
division entre francophones,
anglophones et allophones. Au
Québec il y a parfois
d'microclimat politique.
Les bureaux de scrutin sont
fermés dans 263
circonscriptions. Au Québec, en
Ontario, au Manitoba,
Saskatchewan, Alberta,
Territoires du Nord-Ouest et le
Nunavut. Ils ne restent que la
Colombie-Britannique fermeront
leur bureau à 22 heures. Les
jeux sont faits essentiellement.
Vous avez décidé qui dirigera le
Canada d'ici quelques semaines,
qui sera le premier ministre. On
a bien hâte de connaître votre
décision.
Michel.
- Je sais que Michael Fortier et
Gilles Duceppe sont amateurs de
base-ball. C'est le temps de
dire : playball.
Ce qu'on va surveiller, et le
Bloc québécois au Québec. Ce que
l'on va surveiller aussi, c'est
la capacité des libéraux de
tenir l'Ontario. Ce qui sera la
clé ce soir.
- Vous avez des circonscriptions
chouchous. Je vais faire un tour
de table.
- J'ai beaucoup de
circonscriptions chouchous!
Je vais surveiller Sherbrooke
particulièrement parce que c'est
l'une des rares courses à trois
au Québec ou en aller libéraux,
le NPD et le Bloc québécois qui
sont compétitifs. Souvent il y a
des luttes entre le NPD ou le
bloque ou entre les libéraux et
le bloque. Mais où il y a une
vraie lutte à trois, ce sera à
Sherbrooke.
- Moi le 904, Whitby.
Une chance pour les
conservateurs. Mississauga
Lakeshore, un match de revanche
entre l'ancienne candidate et le
libéral qui est là maintenant.
Jane Philpott aussi pour voir
s'il va tenir son siège.
- Beloeil Chambly, Yves-François
Blanchet, chef du Bloc
québécois. Même s'il a de bonnes
chances d'être réélu, ça va
avoir une force de symbole pour
le Bloc québécois qu'avant
Monsieur Blanchet avait une chef
trans parlementaire.
Martine Ouellet qui a été élu à
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas
la chambre des communes. Je vais
surveiller aussi rapidement
Vancouver Granville parce que
c'est l'ancien ministre libéral
de la justice Jody Wilson-
Raybould, Jeanne d'Arc, si elle
est élue, ça risque de rester
quand même une épine dans la
côte des libéraux. Sinon ce sera
un grand soulagement pour Justin
Trudeau.
- Je pense qu'il rêve de
l'abattre effectivement.
- Je vais surveiller l'oreiller
Sainte-Marie.
Parce que Gilles Duceppe est là
mais parce que c'est une des
rares luttes à trois dans la
région de Montréal. Il y a
vraiment trois participants
avoir des chances. Je vais
surveiller les mosquées. Je
pense qu'il n'y aura pas une
grosse surprise mais que
Monsieur Caron...
- premiers résultats dans
Honoré-Mercier. Pablo Rodriguez
Akeem Haynes. Sans surprise.
Jacques Binette en deuxième
position. Un bureau de vote. On
va se faire plaisir. On va le
montrer!
Simon Chalifoux dans Pierre
Boucher Les Patriotes Verchères.
C'est étonnant.
Un bureau de vote, sur 227.
Une circonscription consommée.
François Philippe champagne qui
au début de la campagne, c'était
une marche dans le parc. Il est
en premier. 23 sur Nicole Morin.
Rimouski Neigette Témiscouata
Les Basques, Chantal Pilon qui
est en avance sur Maxime
Blanchette-Joncas. C'est la
circonscription des Guy Caron du
NPD. Mais encore une fois on se
fait plaisir. Longueuil Saint
Hubert, Réjean Hébert. Transfuge
du Parti québécois. Ancien
ministre qui est en avance sur
Denis Trudel.
Un bureau seulement.
Il faut briser la glace. C'est
pour briser la glace seulement.
- Ça prouve que les libéraux
sont encore bien bon dans le
vote avancé.
- Je vous pose la même question
rapidement. Les circonscriptions
que vous allez regarder.
- Beauport Limoilou parce que
c'est une vraie lutte à trois.
Le candidat libéral, un candidat
qui fait du porte-à-porte
pendant quatre ans, ça peut
faire une différence. C'est le
fils de l'ancien ministre
libéral Rémi Bugeaud. En Ontario
le comté de Miettinen. C'est
Lisa Rait.
Ancienne chef du parti.
- Région de Québec. Où le parti
conservateur assez assise depuis
plusieurs élections. Vont-ils
résister à l'assaut du Bloc
québécois? Le comté de Maxime
Bernier, pas par un désir de le
voir perdre. J'ai l'impression
qu'il va gagner. Et je pense
qu'on est pris avec lui pour
encore un petit bout.
Il va y avoir des entrevues et
des gens comme vous vont vouloir
l'interviewer et on verra ce que
ça donne. Et Jody Wilson-
Raybould et moi aussi également.
- Mon travail presque fait. Il y
en a un des deux que je
surveillais qui est déjà élu.
C'était Jack Harris dans l'Est.
Dans ma région de l'Outaouais,
j'avais vérifié Argenteuil La
Petite Nation qui est peut-être
la seule circonscription qui
pourrait basculer en dehors du
camp libéral.
Sinon l'oreiller comme beaucoup
d'autres. L'oreiller Sainte-
Marie. Une lutte à trois, mais
je que je n'arrête pas de me
dire depuis tantôt que c'est
vraiment une lutte à deux, que
le NPD n'est pas là mais ça va
m'indiquer si le parti a encore
du monde sur le terrain. Et s'il
ne l'a pas, je leur as raison.
Sinon je pense encore que
Madame... n'oubliez pas que
c'était Québec solidaire
provincial. Ça va travailler
main dans la main ces gens-là.
J'ai hâte de voir.
- C'est un peu par choix
sentimental. L'oreiller Sainte-
Marie. Je pense qu'on peut avoir
tous les deux raisons. Ça se
passe à deux, mais le total du
vol sera significatif pour le
NPD. Et mon autre comté c'est le
lac Saint-Jean avec mon fils qui
se présente.
- D'autres résultats encore très
parcellaires.
Jonquière, Mario Simard qui est
en avance sur Philippe Gagnon,
conservateur.
Et Karine Trudel et troisième,
la députée sortante du NPD.
Ce n'est qu'une boîte mais elle
est quand même troisième. Dans
Louis-Hébert, Joël Lightbound
conservera-t-il sa
circonscription?
Il est en avance en tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant.
Abitibi-Témiscamingue, il y a
deux circonscriptions qui
appartenaient au NPD. Sébastien
Lemire. L'autre n'a pas encore
de résultats. Sébastien Lemire
qui est en avance sur Mario
Provencher.
- Le NPD n'est même pas sur le
tableau alors que c'était une
circonscription néo démocrate.
- C'était Madame Moore qui était
là. C'était Roméo Saganash dans
l'autre circonscription en
Abitibi.
On est allé plutôt et avec
raison. Il creuse son avance Guy
Bernartchez dans Gaspésie Les
Îles de la Madeleine sur la
ministre Diane Lebouthillier.
429 d'avance. C'est très serré,
mais quand même.
Il se distance un peu. 55
bureaux. Le dépouillement est
plus avancé étant donné des
Îles-de-la-Madeleine.
Fait partie Mesdames et
Messieurs!
Louis Blouin, chez les libéraux.
- Je suis accompagné directeur
adjoint de la campagne
nationale. J'aimerais vous
entendre sur ce qui se passe
dans le comté de Mme
Lebouthillier. Le candidat
bloquistes qui est en avance.
Comment recevez-vous cela?
- C'est très préliminaire dans
les résultats.
Je suis très confiant pour Mme
Lebouthillier.
- Quel est votre objectif au
Québec? Est-ce que c'est de
préserver les sièges que vous
avez? Un certain moment il y a
des libéraux qui nous disaient :
on préfère plus 15 au Québec.
On sent qu'on est davantage en
train de sauver les meubles,
non?
- Non. M. Trudeau était au
Québec encore une fois la
semaine dernière.
On a fait une bonne campagne. On
fait une excellente campagne
terrain. On a des bénévoles
partout à travers le Québec qui
font sortir le vote.
C'est une chose avoir des
sondages mais il faut être
capable de faire sortir les gens
voter. Nous sommes confiants.
- Les attaques sont venues tard
contre Monsieur Blanchet. Très
intense au cours des deux
derniers jours. Est-ce que vous
avez sous-estimé le Bloc
québécois au départ de la
campagne?
- Comme je l'ai déjà dit plus
tôt, le choix est clair pour les
Québécois. C'est ce qu'on a fait
valoir. Les Québécois ont le
choix d'avoir un gouvernement
qui croit au changement
climatique, qui va lutter pour
les changements climatiques, qui
va en faire plus pour les
familles, et on a le choix de
retourner en arrière. On a
toujours dit que le Bloc
québécois, c'est un vote valide
mais on n'a pas besoin d'être
dans l'opposition. Les Québécois
doivent être au coeur de
l'action.
- Est-ce possible 40 sièges?
- C'est préliminaire.
On va voir comment ça se passe
ce soir.
- Merci. Libéraux qui ne
pleurent pas dans un coin. C'est
encore séries dans beaucoup de
circonscriptions. C'est ce
qu'ils ont la poussée des
Maritimes avec eux. En Beauce,
il est en avance de 16 voix.
- Vous parlez comme si j'étais
son agent officiel.
- Vous avez dit qu'on allait
être pris avec lui. Ce je crois
qu'il va gagner.
- On va surveiller très
attentivement. Les résultats
vont s'accélérer pendant qu'on
voit des luttes, il y a encore
des luttes qui étaient à finir
dans les maritimes. Nova Ouest,
Chris d'Entremont, c'est réglé.
C'est un conservateur. Ça a été
très chaud cette soirée. C'est
réglé pour les conservateurs
dans ce comté.
- C'est un ancien député et
ministre provincial qui fait son
entrée sur la scène fédérale.
- Voilà.
Le libéral, bien sûr, en
deuxième. Portrait général :
45 élus ou en-têtes pour les
libéraux. 20 pour les
conservateurs, cinq pour le Bloc
québécois, quatre pour le NPD,
en à Fredericton pour le parti
vert jusqu'ici et Maxime
Bernier, c'est le dernier, c'est
le mauve qui est en avance en
Beauce dans sa circonscription.
Ça va être fort intéressant de
voix. Le NPD, le pourcentage de
voix du NPD, déjà, il tombe au
Québec au profit du Bloc
québécois. On peut déjà vous
dire ça. Comment ça va se
matérialiser, ça reste à voir
mais en tout cas, une chute du
NPD, Françoise.
Ce n'est pas une surprise, on
est loin des belles années.
- C'est officiel. À la fin de la
soirée, je vais attendre la fin,
mais n'empêche que quand on
pense à toutes les années de
travail, j'ai une pensée
spéciale pour Jack Layton
présentement parce que depuis
2005 que cet homme avec son
équipe autour de lui travailler
à défricher le terrain, à ouvrir
le Québec, à aller chercher des
candidats, quand on pense à
Thomas Mulcair, même à moi-même
et tout le reste, pour créer la
vague orange, ça va être
recommencé pour cette formation.
Ce n'est pas évident.
- Il aura des lendemains.
- On n'est pas rendu là encore.
- On verra. Il y aura des
examens de conscience à faire
pour plusieurs personnes. On lui
parlait tout à l'heure, Monsieur
Plamondon, le doyen du
Parlement. Louis Plamondon qui
est en avance. Il ne devrait pas
avoir de difficultés à percer et
à remporter, ce n'est pas rien,
son 11e mandat. Il a été élu en
84 avec Brian Mulroney.
Il a fait parti de ce qu'elle
écrit le Bloc québécois.
Exactement. Beau parcours de
Beau parcours de c'est le comté
de Sylvie Boucher qui est
troisième. Les conservateurs
n'étaient pas très confiants
quand il parlait de Beauport.
C'est l'ancienne circonscription
de Madame Roy.
Dans Jonquière, Mario Simard qui
est en avance. Le NPD qui est
troisième. Ça va se reproduire
beaucoup ce soir, le NPD avait
gardé 16 circonscriptions la
dernière fois. Il en restait 14
au déclenchement, qui se sont
faits manger un peu partout.
Joliette : Gabriel Ste-Marie
qui est en avance, c'est tout à
fait normal.
Vous êtes avec quelqu'un qui a
connu les moments durs au Bloc
québécois, Daniel?
- Je suis en compagnie de Mario
Beaulieu, un bloquistes à La
Pointe de l'Île, et chef du
parti. Comment se sent ce soir?
- On se sent très heureux et
très enthousiaste.
On a senti sur le terrain, les
gens qui viennent à nous, qui
sont vraiment fiés du Bloc
québécois, fier de défendre ce
qui se passe en ce moment. Je
pense que le Québec est en train
d'avoir de plus en plus le goût
d'être debout et de vraiment
s'affirmer.
- Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au
juste durant cette campagne?
- Je pense que toute la
campagne, le Québec, c'est nous,
ça exprimait vraiment le seul
parti qui défend vraiment les
intérêts nationaux du Québec,
que ce soit pour l'économie de
l'environnement, la laïcité, la
langue, l'immigration, c'est le
Bloc québécois.
- Merci beaucoup Monsieur
Beaulieu.
- Les premiers résultats pour
Yves-François Blanchet dans
Beloeil-Chambly.
Même s'il n'y a qu'un bureau,
avec ces chiffres, il est en
très bonne posture.
Il fait son entrée à la chambre
des communes comme chef député,
chef du Bloc québécois. On voit
pour l'instant, sont vus résumer
l'histoire qui se déroule, on
voit que les libéraux ne
s'écroulent pas au Québec. Le
NPD s'écroule et le Bloc
québécois prend la place du NPD.
Mais libéraux ne s'écroulent pas
pour l'instant. Alors,
commentaires là-dessus, rapide,
Alec?
- C'est assez parcellaire. Ça
dépend des régions où ça sort en
premier. Les libéraux, dans les
belles années de Gilles Duceppe,
les libéraux faisaient élire des
députés au Québec.
C'est donc normal qu'ils gardent
des circonscriptions. Ceci dit,
on voit que la machine libérale
est assez efficace. Les premiers
bureaux de vote, c'est le vote
par anticipation. Ils ont fait
sortir le vote et ils ont été
capables de le faire. Est-ce que
ça va avoir tenu? Est-ce que le
mode aujourd'hui va être
différent? Il est encore tôt.
- Mais il y a des résultats
intéressants pendant
Brome-Missisquoi par exemple,
libéraux avaient mis une
vedette. Ça a été souvent
libéral. La bloquistes Monique
Allard est en tête sur la
cycliste Lyne Bessette. C'est le
début, mais c'est quand même
comme ça.
Richemont Arthabaska, Marc Patry
qui est en avance sur Alain
Reyes. C'est très étonnant.
On va attendre d'autres
dépouillements, pour commenter.
- Ma crainte, les libéraux
doivent être soulagés, parce que
la crainte aurait été de voir
comment 2011, le NPD était fort
au début de la soirée 2015, même
chose pour les libéraux. Les
Québécois, on l'a vu encore au
mois d'octobre, on a
l'impression qu'il donne des
coups à chaque fois. Tu regardes
le vote libéral, pour l'instant,
on n'est pas en train de dire
qui ne perdront pas des comtés,
on ne peut pas dire ça, sur le
bloc est à 40 % dans le vote
francophone, ils vont faire des
gains. Mais on n'est
présentement pas devant un
scénario où le vote libéral est
en train de s'effondrer
complètement. C'est clair que ce
n'est pas le cas.
- Un exemple à Québec. On
parlait de la région de Québec
tout à l'heure. Le libéral Jean-
Yves Duclos qui est en avance
pour l'instant. 10 bureaux sur
227.
Christiane Gagnon qui tentait de
faire un retour à la chambre des
communes. C'est intéressant.
Gilles Duceppe, as qu'à la fin,
il y a eu de l'emballement? On
nous disait : soyez prudent. On
n'est pas dans les 40
nécessairement.
- Les derniers sondages
donnaient Monsieur Duclos en
avance. Il faut voir d'où
viennent ces boîtes de scrutin.
Cette circonscription est
divisée entre l'eau et le bas.
C'est une importance majeure.
- Saint Maurice Champlain :
Francois-Philippe Champagne qui
est en avance. On le disait un
peu plus tôt qu'il avait dû
travailler fort parce que
c'était beaucoup plus séries
qu'il s'y attendait.
- C'est le cas de plusieurs
ministres du Québec. Envoyez
tout à l'heure Diane Bouthiller
en Gaspésie. Même chose pour
Francois-Philippe Champagne et
Monsieur Duclos. Les libéraux
espèrent conserver leur ministre
au Québec ce soir.
Justement, dans Gaspésie Les
Îles de la Madeleine, dit
Bernadette Schild qui creuse son
écart. On pouvait se demander
aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine comment
ils allaient voter alors que ce
sont de Gaspésia. La lutte est
très serrée.
Dans Berthier-Maskinongé, la
libérale, elle est en avance.
Ruth Ellen Brosseau, elle est
quatrième. Mais ce sont de
petits résultats.
- Les gens réagissent à la
table. C'est très bien.
C'est bien. C'était voulu!
L'équipe a mis cela pour vous
faire réagir.
C'est tellement jeune
qu'on va y revenir évidemment à
plusieurs reprises.
- Je ne gagerais pas.
- Mais en pourcentage,
néanmoins, le vote du NPD chute
de manière rapide au Québec. Et
l'Ontario, si vous voyez le
chiffre d'libéraux montés, c'est
qu'en Ontario, les libéraux sont
solides pour l'instant. On va
vous donner des résultats
détaillés, mais ils sont
solides.
- Un petit mot sur le vote
populaire au Québec. 34 pour le
bloc et 30 pour libéraux. Ça
devrait si on se fie aux
sondages être au moins égal ou
ne petit avance pour libéraux.
Actuellement, c'est le bloc est
en tête pour le vote populaire.
Ça veut dire que ça peut être
une bonne soirée.
- Il faut diviser 34 par 79 pour
avoir le vote chez les
francophones.
- Gilles Duceppe, on est en
train d'avoir notre
calculatrice. On n'est pas sûr
qu'on a suivi.
Avec tout le respect que je vous
dois, celle-là, on l'a manqué.
- Vous dîtes qu'il y avait 1 %
d'anglophones et allophones au
Québec, les libéraux font
habituellement 50 % dans cette
population. Ces 10 % du 20 %.
Quand ils font 30, ils sont à
20.
- C'est la distribution du vote.
- Très bien. Voyez le suffrage
de 40 pour les libéraux, 30 pour
le parti conservateur, 16 pour
le NPD, 11 pour le parti Vert et
voilà, ça se poursuit ensuite.
On verra en Ontario ou suis,
Madeleine, ça va être
intéressant de voir...
Monsieur Bernier qui traîne de
la panne, excusez-moi Madeleine,
Monsieur Bernier Ambrose qui
traîne la patte. C'est quand
même Richard Lehoux,
les conservateurs brillaient
tous les dieux, ils ont mis
beaucoup d'énergie avec Richard
Lehoux pour battre Maxime
Bernier.
- Il était président de la
fédération des municipalités du
Québec. C'est quelqu'un qui est
solide quand même. On peut être
d'accord ou pas avec ses idées
mais il est solide.
- 241/700. C'est quand même
important. Pour le Québec, ce
que ça donne pour l'instant, 18
en tête pour les libéraux, 12
entêtes pour le Bloc québécois,
trois entêtes pour les
conservateurs. On attend des
résultats de certaines
circonscriptions encore. En
suffrage, 34 % pour le Bloc
québécois, 31 pour libéraux, 24
pour les conservateurs et 5 %
pour le NPD. C'est une chute
abrupte qui fait mal.
Presque au même niveau que les
Verts.
- C'est très animé. J'espère que
ce sont dans des comtés pas
genre Rosemont La Petite Patrie.
Alors, c'est à suivre. Mais une
image vaut 1000 mots. Moi, ce
n'est pas une surprise n'en
déplaise à ceux... ce n'est pas
une question d'assassinat, c'est
une question de réalisme dès le
départ de la campagne. Malgré
la belle performance de Jagmeet
Singh, on n'a pas réussi à
compenser cet élan du Bloc
québécois. Les libéraux qui ont
une belle organisation sur le
terrain et qui sont capables
de limiter les dégâts. Je suis
presque surprise que les
libéraux ne soient pas plus
maganés encore.
Il y a encore bien des cours
savoir aller.
- Mais dans une bonne partie de
l'électorat francophone, c'est
comme si finalement le deuil
avait été fait du NPD pendant la
campagne.
Si la tendance se maintient,
c'est un peu ce à quoi on
assiste.
- Si la tendance se maintient,
comme dirait l'autre que l'on
salut, ça veut dire aussi un
gouvernement qui ne sera pas
majoritaire. Vous voyez ces
chiffres, on n'est pas en
territoire de majorité pour
l'instant. Je ne le dis pas
officiellement, mais je dis ce
qu'on voit et je constate comme
vous à la maison qu'il serait
extrêmement difficile pour les
libéraux d'arriver au chiffre
magique. On vous a parlé de 170
sièges. On continue, mais je
tenais quand même à vous le
mentionner. C'est important.
On disait que libéraux en
Ontario, ça va bien.
Pendant qu'on a des résultats
dans les Laurentides-Labelle,
Marie-Hélène Gaudreau qui est
devant le libéral sortant David
Graham, c'est très parcellaire.
- Cinq bureaux de scrutin. Le
bloc avait recommandé à Yves-
François Blanchet de se
présenter dans cette
circonscription parce que c'est
là où on voyait un gain avant
même qu'un vent souffle dans la
cour du Bloc.
- Châteauguay Lacolle :
- c'est Brenda Shanahan qui mène
par 196 voix devant la
bloquistes Claudia Valdivia.
Elle sollicite un deuxième
mandat.
- C'est un bon exemple, ça veut
dire que les libéraux vraiment
ont une bonne soirée. C'était
une des circonscriptions qui
étaient visées tant par le vote
francophone par le Bloc
québécois.
- On voit l'organisation du
Parti libéral et de la députée
aussi. Ce n'est pas une députée
connue du grand public mais elle
est très forte.
- En Abitibi, les premiers
résultats, Sylvie Bérubé qui est
en avance. Dans les deux
circonscriptions en Abitibi, le
bloc mène pour l'instant. Ce
sont de courte avance. Sébastien
Lemire, c'est une très bonne
avance dans son cas.
C'est confortable pour l'instant
avec les 15 bureaux sur 270.
Saint Hyacinthe Bagot, Simon
Pierre St-Amant Tremblay qui est
en avance. Brigitte Sansoucy, la
sortante, qui est quatrième.
C'est un autre exemple qui
montre la chute ce soir du NPD.
Premiers résultats pour Mélanie
Joly, voilà. Ça dit tout.
- Mais c'est seulement un bureau
de scrutin qui a été dépouillé.
C'est un début de dépouillement.
- Méta une CECA civile, je crois
que Monsieur Parizeau qui se
présentait pour le Bloc
québécois, qui a dû faire une
profession de foi pour le bloc a
été déjà chef du parti
communiste et je crois que ses
chances sont très bonnes. Même
le bloc n'y croyait absolument
pas. Vous voyez 85...
et toujours le parti Vert à
Fredericton qui est en avance
pour l'instant.
Libéraux qui cheminent
tranquillement et malgré tout
sûrement vers un deuxième
mandat.
- Oui, si on fait le total de
l'opposition, le gouvernement
serait minoritaire mais pas très
loin de la majorité
actuellement. Il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a des gens des
comtés qui rendent Saskatchewan
et de l'Alberta, des endroits
très favorables aux
conservateurs. Avoir 20 sièges
de différence, c'est à ce moment
si, ça veut dire sans doute un
gouvernement minoritaire. Mais
rouge.
- Aussi à Toronto, la couronne
de Toronto qui ne se dessinent
pas très bleus en ce moment.
C'est très tôt, mais quand même.
- Mais c'est quand même parlant.
Sur 63 circonscriptions, les
libéraux en Ontario sont en
difficulté dans uniquement trois
circonscriptions. Le vote
libéral ontarien ne s'est
absolument pas effondré. Il y a
peut-être des pertes ici et là à
la marge, mais Michael, vous
seriez dans le warroom des
conservateurs et vous trouveriez
ça dur.
- L'écart ne se rétrécit pas
depuis quelques minutes. Sinon
pas réussi à faire des percées
là-bas, on parle des Maritimes
tantôt, c'était correct, mais en
Ontario, si tu n'arrives pas à
faire des gains en Ontario,
tu te fais avoir des deux côtés.
- Les premiers résultats dans
Régina Capelle pour Andrew
Scheer, qui brigue son sixième
mandat. Il est arrivé très tôt à
la chambre des communes.
Mais il n'a absolument aucun
problème pour lui ce soit dans
sa circonscription. Il y a
d'énormes problèmes pour le
reste. Berthier-Maskinongé,
voilà!
- Ah!
- Ruth Ellen Brosseau!
- La famille de Monsieur Perron
n'est pas très contents de nous
entendre crier.
- Elle est en avance,
elle sera peut-être une ou deux,
on n'a pas de résultats sur
l'île de Montréal pour Rosemont,
dans son cas ça regarde mieux
que tout à l'heure.
- On peut voir sur la carte ici
si vous voulez envoie son siège
orange celui de Berthier-
Maskinongé. On dirait un village
gaulois entouré de bleu pâle et
de rouge mais lut Hélène
Brosseau tient bon mais on a vu
qu'il y a eu un revirement dans
son comté ce sera une lutte
serrée pour elle.
- Je ne le souhaite pas mais
est-ce que ce serait quelque
chose si Ruth Hélène Brosseau à
la fin de la soirée ne passe pas
parce qu'il y a quand même
Rosemont.
- , Fermeture des bureaux de
scrutin en Colombie-Britannique,
nous seront très bientôt les
résultats dans toutes les
circonscriptions du Canada.
Ça y est mais pendant que vous
voyez que les libéraux ont une
nette avance pour l'instant qui
serait, très, très difficile à
rattraper pour les
conservateurs, mathématiquement
je ne vois pas comment, Michael
vous le disiez.
- Le vote populaire à 30 %,
déjà dans les boîtes de scrutin
on commence à dépouiller des
boîtes très présentes de votre
conservateur dans les prairies,
il y a un petit problème.
- Il y a un petit problème comme
pour M. Sheer. Oui rapidement.
- Pour les conservateurs, ça ne
s'avère pas très bien même le
comté de... le candidat dont tu
parles, Yolande, était en
avance, c'est très tôt mais ça
ne s'avère pas aussi bien que
prévu.
- Il faut aussi se souvenir que
Justin Trudeau Paris très
audacieuse à cinq jours du vote.
Il a admit la possibilité d'un
gouvernement conservateur.
Bon évidemment c'était pas de
gaieté de coeur c'était pour
essayer justement de faire
prendre conscience un certain
nombre d'électeurs : écouter et
vous ne votez pas pour nous
voici ce qui nous attend.
- Il a martelé ça.
- Peut-être que Saül un impact.
- Il faut dire que la fin de
semaine Andrew Scheer,
ça été mauvais.
Pour les gens fins de semaine
qui doutait qui se disait : je
ne suis pas très impressionné
par le Parti libéral.
Est-ce que j'ai vraiment envie
de voter pour Andrew Scheer en
fin de semaine? Ils ont décidé
de rester avec le Parti libéral.
- Vous de voter NPD. C'est à ces
gens que je pense que Justin
Trudeau faisait son appel. Ne
prenez pas la chance.
- Si on regarde la balance du
pouvoir ce n'est pas le NPD
qu'il est, c'est le bloc qui
risque d'être là.
- Moins que certain envisagé
mais on n'a pas les résultats
dans toutes les
circonscriptions.
- C'est pour ça que ces données
vont changer beaucoup,
mais néanmoins la trame de fond,
histoire de fond est devant nous
et devant vous, Mesdames et
Messieurs. Lac Saint-Jean M.
Duceppe, je vous fais l'honneur
allez-y.
- C'est pas beaucoup encore mais
disons que je suis content.
Il a travaillé très fort.
C'est un passionné aussi, mais
ça commence.
- Il y a un air de famille.
- Ça commence bien.
- Possibilité de le prendre
comme ça.
- 52 de majorité.
- Comment on se sent quand on
est papa et qu'on voit ça.
- Plus stressé que quand c'était
pour moi. Tes enfants, ce sont
tes enfants.
- Est-ce que vous l'avez
dissuadé ou encouragé à faire
ça?
- C'était son choix. Moi je
trouve qu'il a ce qu'il faut
pour être en politique.
Il est respectueux des
adversaires. Il avait été
dénoncé par une adversaire qui
s'est excusée. Cet homme, je le
respecte parce qu'il était
capable de s'excuser. Et donc il
a été sur le fond des choses,
il s'est impliqué beaucoup dans
sa communauté. Ça commence tout
juste mais très heureux.
- On va suivre cette course M.
Duceppe. Vous soulignez que les
libéraux notariaux sont dans une
optique de gain et non de perte,
ce qui explique ce que vous
voyez en tête. 114 libéraux en
tête, 83 pour les conservateurs
et 18 pour le Bloc québécois et
neuf pour le NPD, deux pour le
Parti vert Madeleine.
- Oui Parti vert convoyer mener
en Ontario mais les résultats
sont très fragmentaires. La
carte du Québec, c'est assez
évocateur, ses tâches de bleue
poudre. Regardez ça quoi ça
ressemble en 2015.
On retourne aujourd'hui voyer le
bleue poudre qui est ajoutée
notamment Gaspésie, dans le bas
Saint-Laurent, on parlait du lac
Saint-Jean tout à l'heure
lorsqu'on parle de 18 sièges
élus ou en avance plutôt en
avance à ce temps-ci de la
soirée, ça veut dire...
- on a d'autres résultats dans
Beloeil Chambly, il creuse
l'écart, ça y est, c'est presque
fait même s'il n'a que 12
bureaux avec cette avance.
Ce serait très, très surprenant
qu'il y a un renversement.
- 706 voix d'avance, c'est tout
de même substantiel. Martin
Champoux qui mène par 115 voix
et François Choquette le député
sortant et quatrième.
Dans Jonquière Mario Simard qui
mène par 457 voix devant Karine
Trudel, elle espérait pouvoir le
conserver ce siège était un des
sièges que le NPD espérait
sauver.
-  va voir le portrait général
pour le Québec à cette heure-ci
avec 29 en-têtes pour les
libéraux. 18 pour le Bloc
québécois, 10 pour les
conservateurs qui se
maintiendraient, qui
n'accuserait pas de pertes et un
pour le NPD, c'est Ruth Hélène
Brosseau qui sauve la mise.
On n'a pas encore de résultats
dans Rosemont. On verra. En
suffrage, 33 pour le bloc
qui est nettement en première
place. 29 pour les libéraux, 26
pour les conservateurs, ça,
c'est quand même plus que ce que
les sondages laissaient
présager.
- Montréal n'est pas encore
sorti.
- Bonne remarque, Alec.
Et 3 % pour les verts.
Voilà pour les premiers
résultats, c'est tout il y a peu
de données et Geneviève Hinse,
à suivre. C'était simplement
pour vous dire prévoyait des
images chef du Bloc québécois
qui regarde la soirée qui
surveille les autres résultats
qui n'ont pas été reçus. Lui
étant en très bonne posture pour
gagner dans sa circonscription.
Alors voilà.
Ils sont à 18. Lui, pour mémoire
avait mis la barre à 20.
Il avait 10 mois, je vais
considérer que c'est un succès.
En bas demain ce sera mitigé. On
verra jusqu'où le Bloc québécois
ira ce soir.
- Pour le vote francophone
c'est...
- Très bien.
Voilà! Pendant que ça change
devant nos yeux, Madeleine,
couronne de Toronto je pense que
ça vaut la peine parce que c'est
important. Cette victoire
libérale si elle se confirme
et semble se confirmer.
Ça Sé joue beaucoup en Ontario.
- Il y a plus de sièges à
Toronto dans sa couronne que
dans les quatre provinces
atlantiques réunies, alors 57
régions au pays. Ça c'est en
2019. En 2015 regardez à quoi ça
ressemblait. Il nous manque
encore des comtés mais on voit
bien que jusqu'à maintenant les
libéraux tiennent bon. On peut
aller voir ce qui se passe ici
c'est le verre dont on parlait.
Une avance de 16. C'est sûrement
des résultats fragmentaires.
On voit une teinte verte
s'ajoutait à la carte.
- Gérard Deltell qui mène dans
Louis Saint Laurent.
En fait c'est l'plus sure, Louis
Saint Laurent, c'est son
endroit, sa place connaît tout
le monde, il va regagner assez
facilement. Richement
Arthabaska, Alain Rayes.
Quand on avait eu des résultats
fragmentaires mais il a repris.
La logique est là.
- Ils ont neuf compter les
conservateurs donc il ne perd
pas grand-chose au Québec
présentement.
- Mais il pensait gagner il
devait gagner.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À 22h08, Radio-Canada prévoit
que le prochain gouvernement
sera formé par le Parti libéral.
Justin Trudeau qui remporte
finalement son pari d'avoir
un deuxième gouvernement après
le gouvernement qu'il a eu à 47,
ans, M. Trudeau qui a eu une
grosse rose pendant sa campagne
électorale.
Les libéraux et qu'on est peut-
être en train de l'échapper mais
en finalement en Ontario ces
appels au vote stratégique,
au Québec également et dans les
maritimes, il n'a pas eu cette
déconfiture qu'il craignait.
Voyez au rassemblement libéral,
on doit être fort soulagé ce
soir d'apprendre qu'il y aura un
deuxième mandat. Serait-il
majoritaire ou minoritaire?
Tout indique actuellement qu'il
sera minoritaire, qu'ils
n'arriveront pas à dépasser le
seuil du 170 pour l'instant.
Mais être au pouvoir c'est quand
même énorme pour lui compte tenu
de cette campagne et des risques
qu'on avait identifiés. Voyez le
portrait général au pays,
124 élus des libéraux, 94 pour
les conservateurs avec 28
également pour le Bloc
québécois, 11 pour le NPD qui a
une très mauvaise soirée et un
pour le Parti vert, deux pour
les verts, mais un de confirmé.
31 c'est à peu près exactement
ce que les conservateurs avaient
eu également. Et le NPD à une
chute importante, ils étaient à
18 ou 19 la dernière fois.
Louis Blouin, on se
même une minorité je vous dis
avec ces chiffres, on va la
prendre avec un grand sourire.
- Les militants ici qui sont
peu nombreux mais très
enthousiastes. Qui viennent voir
l'annonce de gouvernement
libéral, ça été une inutilisable
impression qu'il devait sauver
les meubles et c'est cette
impression qu'ils ont peut-être
réussie. Vous avez raison de
parler de l'Ontario parce que
c'est là que ça pourrait faire
une différence, on l'a vu au
cours de la fin de semaine on
est en Ontario n'a passé
beaucoup de temps Patrice dans
le sud Ontario et on a senti
qu'il y avait un engouement dans
les rassemblement, on a parfois
dû agrandir la salle. Il y avait
cet engouement. On pouvait le
sentir. On savait qu'il y avait
cette menace au Québec du Bloc
québécois. On sentait qu'avec
l'Ontario du moyen de quelque
chose qui est en train de se
passer. Beaucoup de gens qui
doivent pousser un soupir de
soulagement ce soir. La grande
question c'est de voir quel
poids aura le Québec dans ce
gouvernement libéral
dépendamment des résultats
qu'auront les députés québécois.
Espace avec le Bloc québécois ce
soir. Est-ce que ce sont
gouvernements plus influencé par
l'Ontario dans sa
représentation. Ce sera
intéressant de le suivre.
- Tout à fait merci Louis.
On surveillera ensemble la
réaction de M. Trudeau plus tard
et si vous avez des candidats ou
des organisateurs, on ira vous
rejoindre. Je vais faire un tour
de table quand même, ça y est.
- Soulagé, content c'est pas si
le gouvernement sera majoritaire
ou minoritaire mais pour M.
Trudeau, il gagne. Il a gagné la
confiance de l'électorat pour
gouverner. Maintenant c'est à
lui quand même de prendre la...
la campagne pour M. Trudeau n'a
pas été facile. Il devra
gouverner un pays qui est quand
même divisé sur plusieurs
enjeux, que ce soit la loi 21,
le pétrole dans l'Ouest
canadien. Et maintenant voir
comment le Parti conservateur va
aussi se repositionner dans tout
ça, parce qu'il avait quand même
une belle opportunité pour les
parties qui n'ont pas réussi à
saisir avec Andrew Scheer.
- Il faut voir, est-ce que ce
sera une minorité importante.
Importante. Ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup, c'est qui va
contrôler? C'est une minorité
qui est modeste. Qui va
contrôler l'enjeu? Et qu'est-ce
qui va se passer avec Trans
Mountain. Première question,
question d'enjeu national pour
moi, donc première question.
Deuxième question : les sièges
qu'on les conservateurs pour
l'instant, évidemment il reste
encore siège déclaré, mais M.
Sheer devra se rapprocher de M.
Trudeau s'il veut avoir sa job.
L'écart est beaucoup trop grand
pour le moment. Si M. Sheer
quitte, on l'a vécu, On a eu du
temps pendant que les libéraux
organisaient leur course au
leadership. Ça nous a donné de
l'espace pour organiser notre
menu législatif.
- D'avoir maintenu un
gouvernement minoritaire. Est-ce
qu'il garde son travail?
- Leecan que je vois, absolument
pas de ce que je vois.
- Si on regarde la couronne de
Toronto dans les comptes de
Brampton, c'est le vote NPD
qui ne s'est pas levé sexy
beaucoup beaucoup pourquoi les
libéraux sont en avance parce
qu'ils ont pas scindé ce vote
progressif s'est ramassé chez
les libéraux. Le vote
conservateur n'a pas baissé mais
ils n'ont pas réussi...
- À 31 %, tu ne peux pas gagner.
- C'est-à-dire que le vote
néodémocrates vote
nécessairement pour espérer
passer l'route conservateur.
Un sondage est une question
d'opinion. Quand vient le temps
de mettre son bulletin dans la
boîte de scrutin c'est une
décision importante et ça arrive
assez régulièrement que les
néodémocrates en Ontario dans
ses banlieues, pas dans les
châteaux forts néodémocrates
mais dans les banlieues, à la
toute fin on était il y avait
Doug Ford en plus. Il y a bien
des gens qui se sont des sons
pas avoir de gouvernement
conservateur est en Ontario et
au fédéral? J'accueille...
un petit mot Philippe, vous avez
toute la campagne regarder les
sondages et examiner tout ça.
En pourcentage, c'est pas tout à
fait ce que les gens disaient
n'est-ce pas?
- Il faut toujours être parce
qu'il reste la Colombie-
Britannique une partie de
l'Alberta, mais on regarde oui
en effet les libéraux sont au-
dessus de la coche. On remarque
les conservateurs, si le vote
métier, ça va grimper un peu
avec la Colombie-Britannique
mais n'ont pas fait de gain,
ils ont simplement gardé leur
base. Et je regarde justement
achat mentionnais le 905, ces
rouges en entier.
- Tout ce qui peut sauver M.
Sheer, c'est qu'on n'est pas un
gouvernement minoritaire stable.
Regardez les chiffres des
libéraux et les chiffres du NPD
qui serait son allié naturel,
ça n'a pas l'air de faire une
majorité encore. Et à ce moment-
là dans un gouvernement
instable, on change pas de chef
on n'a pas le temps et non pas
la capacité de le faire.
C'est peut-être la seule chose
qui peut sauver M. Sheer.
- Il y a tellement à l'intérieur
du parti des Jean-Michel.
Il ne pouvait pas se
réveiller... il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui n'étaient pas
convaincus que M. Sheer était
nécessairement le meilleur
candidat.
- Personne ne voulait y aller.
C'était ça le problème.
- Vous avez raison en théorie
mais en pratique ce parti va
prendre acte de la défaite s'il
est aussi importante qu'on va le
voir ce soir je pense que M.
Sheer n'aura pas le choix que de
quitter.
- Je pense qu'il faut surveiller
beaucoup ce qui va se passer en
Colombie-Britannique. S'il se
passe la même chose qui est
passée en Ontario, en fait il
pourrait y avoir une majorité.
Ok, il pourrait y avoir une
majorité.
- Premier résultat, pardonnez-
moi pour Justin Trudeau dans
Papineau, ou bien sûr il n'y a
aucune histoire, aucun suspense.
M. Trudeau qui brille je vous le
souligne un quatrième mandat
dans Papineau, il avait été élu
lors d'u partielle.
- Non, général en 2008.
- Merci. J'aime que vous soyez
là, Gilles.
- J'ai bien des défauts mais
j'ai de la mémoire.
- C'est extraordinaire. Tasha,
l'avenir de M. Sheer?
- Ainsi que l'avenir de Jagmeet
Singh. M. Sheer va avoir un
sérieux problème. Si les
libéraux, on voit maintenant
s'ils vont plus proche je vous
dirai 2508 les conservateurs je
pense m'en pose beaucoup de
questions.
- Ça pourrait encore grimper mes
hydrates la Colombie-
Britannique, ça pourrait faire
mal. 44 sièges en 2015 pour le
NPD et on parle de la moitié du
total.
- Tous les sièges qu'ils ont si
bien Ontario sont tous libéraux
présentement.
- Le coup de massue pour M.
Sheer c'est l'Ontario.
Où il y avait des espoirs, pouf!
L'argument de vente de M. tout
en disant que vous allez vous
réveiller avec un gouvernement
de M. Sheer, de M. Ford, de
l'austérité, ça a porté.
- Ils ont fait une erreur je
pense les néodémocrates en
congédia M. Mulcair.
Il aurait mieux fait.
- Je suis pas convaincu
nécessairement, avec des si on
peut aller à Paris, on devait
être le prochain gouvernement en
2015 et on a terminé loin
derrière. On pourrait avoir de
bons arguments là-dessus.
Je suis pas aussi dur sur le NPD
parce que je regarde les chefs
s'ils vont chercher 25 ou 30
sièges après avoir fait toutes
les pertes qu'il devait faire au
Québec, je pense que la base
militante du NPD va pardonner à
Jack médecin qui a fait une
excellente campagne.
- Merci Françoise.
Le bloc est rendu à 32 en tête,
31 maintenant. Charlesbourg,
Pierre Paul-Hus qui mène.
C'est une course quand même
relativement serrée, quoiqu'il
devrait s'en sortir. Il brigue
son deuxième mandat. Dans
richement Arthabaska
Alain Re qui est confortable en
première place.
Le NPD plus sur notre tableau.
Ils sont rendus au cinquième.
Louis Saint Laurent, Gérard
Deltell je le disais tout à
l'heure, circonscription
acquise au conservateur.
- Qui avait mené par 19 000 voix
pratiquement en 2015 et qui
avait obtenu plus de 50 % des
votes.
C'est effectivement facile pour
lui.
- Très bien.
- Dans Trois Rivières.
- Yves Lévesque et troisième.
Devant l'libéral Valérie Renaud-
Martin chez qui les libéraux
misaient beaucoup, 710 voix.
680 voix pour Yves Lévesque.
- Et le député sortant.
C'est une course serrée contre
la cycliste Lyne Bessette,
c'est la fête pour le Parti
libéral.
Les conservateurs loin derrière.
Vous voyez il y a des course
serrée, 30, ce serait une très,
bonne soirée compte tenu des 10
de la dernière fois pour le Bloc
québécois.
- Mais il s'attendait à plus.
Ils étaient rendus à 40.
- À 22 heures 21 Radio-Canada
prévoit que le prochain
gouvernement libéral sera
finalement minoritaire. Justin
Trudeau à la tête d'un
gouvernement minoritaire. Il
recrée exactement ce que son
père avait fait.
En 68 une grosses majorités et
en 72 une minorités à Ottawa.
L'histoire qui se répète avec
son fils. La question qu'il faut
se poser, c'est : sera-t-il
confortablement minoritaire ou
vraiment minoritaire, passez-moi
l'expression, sur la fesse.
Avec de l'instabilité. Parce que
le NPD n'est pas assez élevé
pour se rendre à 170 pour
l'instant.
- Avec la Colombie-Britannique
oui, il pourrait.
- Mon Dieu que je vous aime!
- Ça commence à se
dessiner en orange. Il y a rangé
libéral. Il n'y a aucun
conservateur sur la carte. Si la
lutte se dessine comme ça les
deux parties pourraient bien
former un gouvernement
minoritaire.
- Ce serait l'idéal pour M.
Trudeau évidemment, et que ce ne
soit pas le bloc.
- Il manque 38 circonscriptions.
- Le bloc d'une part la fête
avec Paul Martin.
Je crois que le conservateur et
le NPD n'auront pas le goût de
relancer une élection
rapidement. On pourrait
maintenant adopter une règle qui
existe à Westminster. Avant
chaque vote, la chambre vote si
le vote qui suit sera un vote de
confiance ou pas.
Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
parties qui aimeraient une telle
chose actuellement, surtout le
NPD et le conservateur qui
dirait : ouf! Pas d'autre
élection rapidement.
- Ils ne sont pas loin. 45 + 21.
Alors ils ne seront pas loin.
- Bien des gens vont préférer
que les libéraux se joignent pas
nécessairement par une
coalition, mais une espèce
d'entente.
- Bingo!
150 et 20.
On l'a vécu en direct. Ça donne
170. Il y aurait un accord.
- Mais il y a des conséquences.
Ce n'est pas qu'elles sont
négatives. Mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec Trans Mountain? Un
problème d'unité nationale. Tous
les programmes qui avaient
proposé l'Jagmeet Singh au
niveau de l'assurance médicale,
l'assurance dentaire, les
projets de dépenses. J'ai lu son
programme de bout à l'autre et
il y avait d'truc là-dedans qui
est intéressant pour quelqu'un
qui veut dépenser.
- Dans Rosemont-La Petite-
Patrie, Alexandre Boulerice. Il
en restera vraisemblablement
deux au Québec. Il est en forte
avance sur Geneviève Hinse.
- Deux bureaux seulement dans
Laurier Sainte Marie. Scellant
le dépouillement.
Il y a des anges!
Que deux bureaux.
On va attendre. Dans
Montarville, Stéphane Bergeron
qui est en voie de revenir à la
chambre des communes. Il a été
aussi député du Parti québécois.
Il est en avance sur Michelle
Picard libéral. Pointe de Lille,
Mario Beaulieu qui était déjà
là, les députés sortants pour le
Bloc québécois. C'était logique
que pour lui de toi une soirée
plus facile. En forte avance sur
le libéral Plamondon. Péclet
essayer pour la deuxième fois
pour le NPD.
Jane Philpott est en troisième.
Justin Trudeau en sera sûrement
heureux.
- C'était l'ancienne ministre de
la santé aussi en Ontario.
- Joël Lightbound et qui est en
avance.
Il est en bonne voie d'être
réélu.
Il est en direct avec notre
camarade.
- Voilà. Plus de 400 voix de
majorité. Gouvernement
minoritaire libéral, est-ce que
c'est au-delà de vos espérances?
- Je pense que ça montre que
dans la région de Québec, il y a
beaucoup de progressistes. Ils
se sont fédérés derrière un
parti qui était résolument
moderne et progressiste. Les
analyses vont devoir venir dans
les prochains jours pour le
reste. Je suis très
reconnaissant envers les gens de
Louis-Hébert.
- Une certaine remontée du Bloc
québécois en cours de campagne :
comment avez-vous géré tout
cela?
- Sur le terrain je lis un peu -
36.
Ce que je percevais sur le
terrain, ce n'était pas un désir
de retourner dans l'histoire des
années 90, des chicanes entre
Québec et Ottawa. C'était plus
de voir comment on peut livrer
sur le transport en commun. Et
surtout pour moi réduire les
inégalités. Comment peut en
faire plus pour faire reculer la
pauvreté au Canada.
- Merci beaucoup!
- Merci beaucoup.
Pablo Rodriguez réélu. Ce n'est
pas une surprise non plus dans
Honoré-Mercier. Il a une
confortable avance sur Jacques
Binette, le bloquiste.
Pierre Paul Hus réélu lui aussi.
Ce n'est pas un endroit où les
conservateurs croyaient être en
danger et ça se confirme ce
soir. Gérard Deltell réélu dans
Louis Saint Laurent.
Ça ne faisait pas de cachette.
Mais il doit être extrêmement
déçu du résultat ce soir.
Il a travaillé d'arrache-pied
pour que les conservateurs
gagnent. Rayes réélu dans
Richmond-Arthabaska également.
- Ralph Goodale tient-t-il
fort?
- 1/10 élection pour lui, pas
consécutives. Mais il tient le
fort.
- Il est là, seul député de la
Saskatchewan depuis plus d'une
décennie.
Alors les cibles sont contre
lui. Les conservateurs
aimeraient donc avoir ce siège.
Il mène pour le moment par 25
voix.
Ce n'est pas beaucoup. Mais il
tient bon.
Évidemment que la lutte va être
dérisoire parce que les
conservateurs ont mis toute la
gomme dans ce comté.
- Il aurait voulu ne plus être
seul et comme cela par contre.
- Et les avait espoirs dans le
nord de la Saskatchewan.
- Mais c'est chaud on nous dit
dans le deuxième comté.
- L'Alberta est complètement
bleue?
- Allons à Calgary. C'est
intéressant parce qu'il y avait
là quelques sièges libéraux.
Edmonton jusqu'à maintenant tout
est bleu en Alberta. On a beau
chercher les sièges libéraux, on
n'en voit pas.
Ce sera une déception pour le
Parti libéral parce qu'ils
espéraient avoir au moins un
siège dans chaque province.
C'est plus facile de gouverner
quand on a une représentation
régionale un peu partout au
pays.
- Un gain pour Yves-François
Blanchet que réélu.
Il avait mit la barre à 20.
Il est à 33.
Une délégation de 33 bloquistes.
Vous voyez des images en direct
du théâtre national à Montréal
où on est fou de joie. Et on
peut le comprendre parce que le
Bloc québécois, sans exagérer,
on peut dire qu'il a frôlé peut-
être pas la mort mais l'apathie
totale. C'est une poussée
importante du Bloc québécois au
Québec. Ce qui cause très
certainement en tout cas la
minorité de M. Trudeau avec
moins de députés du Bloc.
L'histoire que Gilles Duceppe
connaît bien à deux reprises.
Une telle poussée du Bloc
québécois empêche
mathématiquement un des parties
à devenir majoritaire au pays.
Il faudra voir quel genre de
pays avant de donner demain.
Vous avez parlé des
conservateurs qui avaient tout
raflé en Alberta, qui était en
voie de tout rafler. C'est un
pays divisé, désigné. Il y aura
des lendemains difficiles pour
les chefs nationaux au Canada.
Daniel, vous êtes au Bloc
québécois. On est content.
- Oui. Il y avait un petit doute
en début de soirée parce qu'au
cours des derniers jours il y
avait pas mal de gens qui
commençaient à parler de 37,38,
40 sièges. On sentait depuis
deux jours que les gens
tentaient d'être plus prudents
et de dire : on visait 20 sièges
au début. Si on n'en a 30, on
sera heureux. Il y a beaucoup de
satisfaction ce soir. Le chiffre
que l'on voit présentement à 34,
ça fait plaisir à tout le monde.
On a l'impression qu'on a
dépassé les attentes et qu'on a
réussi à atteindre l'objectif
que plusieurs observateurs à
déplacer sur le Bloc québécois
au début de la campagne.
Maintenant il y a beaucoup de
gens ici. Ils sont arrivés très
tôt. Ils sont très motivés. Vous
les entendez derrière moi. Ils
se sont faits entendre depuis le
début de la soirée. Chaque fois
que vous mentionnez un gain ou
un candidat en avance ils sont
très brillants. Beaucoup de
plaisir ici. Plus que ce que
j'ai vu dans d'autres
rassemblements du Bloc québécois
dans le passé.
- Attention à vos oreilles parce
que ce n'est pas fini. On va
donner quelques gains du Bloc
québécois. Ça risque d'applaudir
fort. Dans Saint-Jean. C'est un
gain également pour le Bloc
québécois. Christine Normandin
est élu contre le libéral Jean
Rioux. C'est un gain au profit
du Parti libéral.
Salaberry Suroît, Claude
DeBellefeuille qui revient la
chambre des communes pour le
Bloc québécois. Autres gains du
Bloc québécois au Québec.
- Elle avait été députée de 2006
à 2011.
- Abitibi-Témiscamingue,
Sébastien Lemire un autre gain
au profit du NPD qui est
quatrième. Un gain solide du
Bloc québécois. L'ancienne
circonscription de Madame Moore.
Rivière du Nord, deuxième
mandat pour Monsieur Rhéal
Fortin. Il n'est pas encore élu.
Mais c'est pas mal proche. Mais
vous avez raison que
techniquement. Mais avec 1018 de
majorité, disons qu'il a plus de
majorité que la 2e place.
OUf!
- Il n'a pas encore gagné.
Je vais vous raconter une
histoire. En 93 c'est moi qui
dirigeais le rassemblement
Montréal. Lucien Bouchard était
allemand. Les journalistes
étaient tous dans mon bureau. Il
disait : venez vous en. Et je
disais : non, je ne veux pas me
rendre tant qu'on ne m'a pas
annoncé comme gagnant. Je suis
très heureux de ce que je vois!
- Avec 2421, il est en bonne
voie d'être député.
- Ça regarde bien!
Quand ça va être fait.
- On va y revenir.
- Je suis très optimiste!
Quand je vais le voir.
- 143 pour les libéraux, 21 pour
le NPD.
On rabaisse en dessous du seuil
de 170. Alors la question qui
demeure c'est : est-ce que ce
sera une majorité confortable ou
une majorité confortable?
On aura la réponse avec le
dépouillement Colombie-
Britannique.
- Il y a environ huit comtés que
les conservateurs ont ciblés en
Colombie-Britannique. Reste à
savoir s'ils vont réussir à les
arracher. Ça pourrait changer
les choses. Mais si les libéraux
le conservent, ils auraient 150.
- Si vous aviez dit hier aux
conservateurs que ça leur
donnerait juste 113 comtés, les
conservateurs auraient été très
surpris.
Je pense qu'ils avaient des
attentes plus élevées à 33 %.
- Ils ont aussi arrangé les
sièges. Lisa Raitt est en train
de perdre un mail terne.
Le carré de 400 voix.
- Merci Rob Ford!
- Ça va se Browse dans
l'intérieur du parti
conservateur Ontario est fédéral
parce que certainement il va y
avoir des gens qui vont dire...
=- on avait péché par un excès
de prudence M. Duceppe. Voici
votre moment!
Ces faits!
- Je vais vous dire, quelque
chose que je n'ai pas dit à
Alexis. J'ai vu maman quelques
heures avant qu'elle décède. Ce
serait sa fête demain. Et
j'avais dit à maman : Alexis va
se présenter. Quand il sera
assermenté, tu viendras avec
moi. Mais je ne l'avais jamais
dit Alexis. Je lui dis
présentement. Il doit m'entendre
là-bas.
- Ne pleure pas!
- Mais la filiation, de voir
votre fils qui arrive à la
chambre des communes, c'est
quand même quelque chose.
Souhaitiez tout à fait. Je lui
ai parlé tous les jours, quatre
ou cinq fois par jour. Je suis à
Challans sur le téléphone. Il
partait troisième.
- Ce n'était pas gagné d'avance
il y a deux mois et demi cette
histoire.
- Il a travaillé très fort. Il a
mis une machine sur pied. Il a
tout réorganisé.
Il a sorti 15 000 personnes.
C'est beaucoup.
Yolande est là avec lui. Elle a
fait campagne là-bas.
- Bravo à lui!
- Votre mère, on lui envoie de
belles pensées en haut.
- Il va bien faire ça.
- Dans Montarville, Stéphane
Bergeron qui revient également.
Il est en avance de 300 cette
voie devant Michelle Picard.
- Une course quand même assez
serrée encore Patrice.
- Montarville c'était vraiment
ce que l'on .tg le Bloc
québécois comme genre de
circonscription.
Longueuil Charles LeMoyne, c'est
serré.
- Court avance de 51 voix devant
Sherry Romanado, la libérale.
Une course très serrée qu'on va
surveiller ce soir. 20 bureaux
de scrutin ont été déployés.
- Le Bloc québécois 35.
Maintenant en tête. Ça
correspond beaucoup plus à ce
qu'eux-mêmes nous disaient vers
la fin. Il pointait vers les 35
plutôt que le 40.
Les 40 est venu dans
l'emballement.
- Dans Saint-Hyacinthe Bagot,
Simon Pierre Favart Tremblay qui
mène par 2444 voix.
La députée sortante Brigitte
Sansoucy et troisième.
On va parler de cette course
serrée. 39 voix qui séparent Guy
Bernatchez de Lebouthillier, la
ministre sortante du revenu
national. C'est extrêmement
serré dans ce comté.
- Gaspésie Les Îles de la
Madeleine, je sens que l'on va
recompter cela demain.
- Dans l'acte Saint-Jean, on a
parlé.
- N'essayez pas d'appeler votre
fils Monsieur Duceppe. Il est
avec notre journaliste!
On va le retrouver.
- Je suis en compagnie d'Alexis
qui vient tout juste d'être
déclaré vainqueur dans l'acte
Saint-Jean. Vous été fébrile en
début de soirée. Vous vous
attendiez à une lutte serrée.
Finalement c'est un gain assez
convaincant. À quoi attribuez-
vous votre victoire?
- On a une équipe incroyable
dans l'acte Saint-Jean. Je veux
remercier les gens de me faire
confiance. Je vais travailler
corps et âme pour leur prouver
qu'ils ont eu raison.
- Vous êtes dans la région
depuis deux ans et demi
seulement.
Sur quoi ça s'est joué selon
vous?
- On a fait une campagne propre
et noble. Je veux féliciter mes
adversaires. Je pense que ça
s'attribue entre autres aussi à
la performance du chef du parti
bien entendu mais aussi à
l'équipe régionale qu'on a mise
en place. On a mis une plate-
forme régionale. On a été le
seul à le faire. Ça touche
directement les enjeux des gens.
Les deux combinés ont fait en
sorte qu'on a une belle victoire
ce soir. Je salue mon père ce
soir.
- Je disais plutôt aujourd'hui
Félicitations. Je vais vous
passer votre père qui veut vous
parler.
- Bravo. Il vient d'être que tu
étais le fils de Gilles Duceppe.
Moi, j'étais le fils de Jean
Ducey. Maintenant, on va
m'appeler le père d'Alexis.
Bravo.
- Merci papa.
Je t'aime.
- Embrasse ta maire très fort.
- Moi aussi, je t'aime beaucoup.
- Il faut que tu finissais la
soirée.
Je t'aime.
- C'est pour cela qu'on fait ce
fait ce métier.
Ce sont des vrais moments, c'est
de l'émotion, ce sont des
histoires humaines. Vous avez un
exemple mais tous les candidats
ont des mamans et des papas qui
sont dans tous leurs états et
qui leur disent : pauvre toi, ce
sera une prochaine fois où oui,
on a gagné.
C'est votre petite fille!
- Simone, elle a la double
nationalité.
Elle est née à Portland.
Elle est née prématurée.
C'est Simone qu'il a présentée
lors des assemblées. Ça fait
trois ans qu'elle est présidente
de sa classe.
- En prépare déjà la relève.
- Des nouvelles du chef
conservateur, Andrew Scheer
réélu dans Regina Qu'Appelle.
Sixième mandat pour Monsieur
Scheer qui devra se poser la
question quand on est un chef
qui n'arrive pas à remporter le
pouvoir, même avec un
gouvernement minoritaire de.
Doit-il rester ou non?
Michael Fortier disait que dans
les rangs conservateurs, il y
aura beaucoup de pression.
Alors, ce que ça donne, à ce
moment-ci : 144 élus ou en-têtes
pour les libéraux, 119 pour les
conservateurs, 36 pour le Bloc
québécois, 21 pour le NPD et
pour le parti vert uniquement.
Il faudra voir en Colombie-
Britannique, Madeleine, si on a
déjà dépouillé la
circonscription de Madame
Elizabeth May.
Sinon, ce ne serait pas normal.
- Anva surveiller Madame May et
de Jody Wilson-Raybould.
- 15 pour le NPD, lui pour le
Bloc québécois. C'est pour
l'ensemble du Canada. 7 pour le
parti vert. Au Québec, ce que ça
donne : le Bloc québécois à 35
sièges, 32 pour libéraux, les
conservateurs sont à égalité
avec 2015 et un seuls sièges
pour le NPD. Est-ce à dire que
dans Rosemont, on a eu un
renversement?
- C'est dans Berthier-
Maskinongé.
- C'est Ruth Ellen Brosseau qui
ne passe pas.
- J'avais prévu 35 32 9 1 et 1.
Ce n'est pas fini.
- Le suffrage que vous voyez
pour le Québec.
Philippe Vincent, je parlais de
l'avenir du chef conservateur
tout à l'heure. Mais d'abord,
revenons au début de l'histoire,
il y a une grosse déception dans
les rangs conservateurs avec un
pourcentage qui est un peu plus
élevé que la dernière fois. On
voit les libéraux arriver avec
une minorité.
- Oui, donc c'est sûr qu'au
début de l'élection, on pense
être capable de remporter au
moins une minorité. Même ce
matin, on disait encore que
c'était possible et que la
majorité était envisageable.
Alors c'est sûr que c'est une
déception. Grosse déception
aussi au Québec. J'ai parlé avec
plusieurs conservateurs qui me
disaient qu'il y a même de la
frustration parce qu'il y a une
campagne qui a été mise en place
pendant deux ans, beaucoup de
travail de terrain. Aujourd'hui,
en ce moment, il y a certaines
pertes qui vont être compensées
par des gains mais ça ne va pas
bien pour les conservateurs quoi
que si on regarde les chiffres,
ce qui va et intéressant à
surveiller, c'est le pourcentage
de vote et le nombre de votes
absolus. Est-ce que les
conservateurs vont gagner le
même nombre de votants 2015? Ce
soir, ils vont avoir profité de
la division du vote des
néodémocrate et des libéraux
pour gagner des sièges. Ça va
amener la future question : que
fera Andrew Scheer?
Si on regardait chef du
gouvernement minoritaire, est-ce
que les libéraux et les
néodémocrate peuvent gouverner
assez longtemps pour épouser
peut-être les conservateurs et
permettre à certains
conservateurs qui ont des
ambitions de se faire sentir?
Vous l'entendez quand même ici,
il y a de la joie dernière moi
surtout quand on regarde la
circonscription de Ralph Goodale
en ce moment, on voit qu'il
traîne de la pâte.
Ce sont des résultats qui sont
encourageants pour les militants
qui sont ici après une soirée
qui est un peu décevant avec le
résultat global du gouvernement
minoritaire libéral.
- Merci. On se réjouit dans le
gouvernement conservateur
partira Good elle est passée
deuxième.
On voit le Canada qui est cassé
en deux.
- Il n'y a pas de siège libéral
au Manitoba. C'est un gros
problème pour le gouvernement.
Il a perdu sa majorité au
Québec. Il va falloir que
Monsieur Trudeau dise : j'ai des
ponts à rétablir avec le Québec.
Juste l'idée de ne pas avoir
eu... son père en avait un.
Chaque fois qu'il y avait une
demande venant du Québec même de
la part de Monsieur Couillard,
c'était ignoré. Il y a des ponts
à rétablir.
- On le voit, Ralph Goodale qui
est deuxième.
- Le gouvernement fédéral qui
est en cours contre une loi
de l'Assemblée nationale,
c'est un peu gros.
- Je ne crois pas que c'est un
enjeu.
- Ce n'est pas ce que je voulais
démontrer. Ça démontre
l'attitude qu'il a envers le
Québec. C'est ce que sa demande.
- Il va gouverner je vous pose
la question, il va gouverner
avec le NPD même si c'est formel
ou pas.
Il va creuser encore plus
l'écart avec l'ouest du pays
parce qu'il aura des décisions
plus difficiles à prendre.
- CGT les néodémocrate, je ne
ferai pas un gouvernement de
coalition. Je les vois ce que
les Britanniques ont vécu.
Les néodémocrate ont été
assimilé dans le gouvernement de
coalition de 50 David Cameron.
C'était merveilleux.
Tout le monde était heureux. À
la fin, quand l'élection s'est
tenue...
- Maxime Bernier qui est défait
en Beauce.
- Vous m'interrompez pour cela!
- C'est une claque énorme pour
Maxime Bernier.
On se dit qu'il allait au moins
conserver...
son père a fait campagne avec
lui. Il a tout fait. Il restait
beaucoup dans les 10 derniers
jours dans sa circonscription.
Richard Lehoux, les
conservateurs ont mis toute la
gomme et les producteurs
laitiers.
- Ne vous battez pas contre
l'UPA.
- La marge est haute.
- C'est énorme.
- Il va peut-être se présenter à
la chefferie des conservateurs.
- C'est une blague.
- On parlait du lien,
tu n'as pas besoin d'aller en
Grande-Bretagne. Tu n'as qu'à
aller en Colombie-Britannique.
Le parti vert est associé au
néodémocrate qui gère la
province, la Colombie-
Britannique. Ils sont en train
de devenir totalement
inexistant. Alors quelque part,
c'est un danger. Mais qu'ils
aient une entente comme on avait
eu en fin de mandat en 2004
jusqu'en 2006 sous Paul Martin
avec le NPD, avec un plan de
peut-être un an et demi ou
quelque chose, c'est possible,
mais pas avec une coalition,
c'est mortel.
- Le NPD va avoir plus de
pouvoir s'il reste à appuyer les
budgets et les projets de loi au
vote.
Ils veulent plein de choses...
- c'est une formalité, mais
Justin Trudeau qui est réélu
dans son comté de Papineau.
Michel soulignait que son refus
de nommer un lieutenant au
Québec avait crée une distance
peut-être et que
stratégiquement, ce n'était pas
sa meilleure décision
depuis quatre ans.
Louis Blouin, c'était certain
que Monsieur Trudeau allait
remporter sa circonscription.
Regarder chez on se dit qu'avec
le NPD, on arrive au chiffre
magique de 170.
- Absolument. Monsieur Trudeau
qui va devoir commencer à faire
des appels dans le camp
néodémocrate pour voir comment
on va planifie les prochaines
semaines. Les gens qui viennent
de réagir à la victoire de
Monsieur Trudeau. Qu'est-ce vous
havé pensé de la campagne?
- Il a fait une bonne campagne
et on a fait du mieux qu'on a
pu.
- Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
résultat de manière générale?
- On est soulagé.
C'est vrai qu'on aurait aimé
avoir un gouvernement
majoritaire, mais un
gouvernement minoritaire, on est
soulagé. Vaut mieux que cela
qu'un gouvernement conservateur.
- Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
la campagne menée par Monsieur
Trudeau? Est-ce que vous êtes
déçu de voir qu'il se retrouve
avec un gouvernement
minoritaire? Un peu déçu mais
c'est mieux que de perdre face
aux conservateurs. Je suis très
soulagé. Je trouve que ça s'est
bien passé. Parce que j'étais
inquiet au début.
On pensait que c'était serré,
mais à la fin, on a gagné.
- Oui, on vous a perdu mais on
n'y reviendra.
Monsieur Trudeau, Monsieur
Scheer a un immense défi :
reste-t-il comme chef?
Avant d'aller à un tour de table
sur l'avenir, des résultats dans
Laurier Sainte Marie. C'est très
lent, je ne sais pas ce qu'il
arrive. On dépose lentement.
- Une petite avance. Une toute
petite avance.
La néodémocrate est troisième.
C'est un peu à l'image de la
soirée, à quel point les
néodémocrate ont obtenu une
déconfiture au Québec. Je peux
vous montrer ceux à quoi ça
ressemble sur la carte, on a vu
du bleu pute immergés un peu
partout au Québec jusqu'à
maintenant. 25 gains qui ont été
faits d'abord au détriment du
parti néodémocrate. Son regarde
ceux à quoi ça ressemblait en
2015, voyez à quel point c'était
une couleur, ne courtepointe
vraiment différente. On assiste
aujourd'hui au bleu pute qui a
pris vraiment les devants. Je
vous manque la Gaspésie. C'est
redevenu rouge ici. Alors Diane
Bouthiller, 490 voix d'avance.
On peut se diriger dans Montréal
parce qu'il y a un siège
néodémocrate qui tient bon.
C'est celui évidemment
d'Alexandre Boulerice dans
Montréal, c'est le seul rescapé
de la vague orange au Québec.
C'est social d'Alexandre
Boulerice.
- Il disait qu'il ne voulait pas
être le dernier.
- Quel avenir pour lui!
On voit les circonscriptions du
NPD. Voyez ce qui s'est passé ce
soir.
Les bloquistes en ont pris la
majorité. Libéraux sont en
avance mais c'est loin d'être
fait dans Laurier Sainte Marie.
- Hochelaga aussi.
- On va aller voir Hochelaga.
Sherbrooke, les libéraux qui
mènent aussi. On va rassembler
ses résultats. Hochelaga, voilà.
- Combien de bureau?
- 35.
- Sherbrooke, Élisabeth Brière
qui est en avance aussi. Quand
même une bonne avance.
- Pier-Luc qui fait une belle
bataille.
- Il est deuxième. Le bloquistes
Claude Forgues qui est en
troisième. Les libéraux, ça va
réjouir d'avoir Sherbrooke.
Fredericton,a y est!
Ça a quand même été serré avec
la candidate conservatrice.
Il en a trois élus ou en avance
pour le parti vert. En Colombie-
Britannique, bien sûr, Madame
May qui est en avance. Au tout
début du dépouillement mais il
ne devrait pas y avoir de
problème. Son mari, pour la
petite histoire, il est
troisième pour l'instant.
C'est tout à fait embryonnaire
comme résultat. Voilà le
deuxième, le troisième dans da
Nanaimo Ladysmith.
Voilà pour le parti vert
qui va peut-être finir la soirée
avec trois.
- Ce n'était pas la soirée que
l'on souhaitait. On souhaitait
avoir un statut de parti
officiel. Vous imaginez, ça veut
dire 12 compter. On n'avait pas
vu nécessairement venir celui de
Fredericton à part Michel qui en
a parlé au début de la soirée.
Mais sinon, on croyait à une
meilleure performance sur l'île
de Vancouver notamment. Mais
jusqu'à maintenant, on conserve
les deux sièges qu'on avait.
Celui de la chef et du député
qui s'était fait élire dans une
élection partielle maintenant.
- Premiers résultats dans
Vancouver Granville, Jody
Wilson-Raybould et en deuxième
position. C'est le début.
Le candidat libéral qui est en
avance. C'est ça se maintenait,
c'est vraiment, c'était un des
objectifs de Monsieur Trudeau ce
soir de battre son ancienne
procureur qui lui a donné tant
de fil à retordre. Et Madame
Philpott qui est troisième en
Ontario.
- Lacourt c'est un peu moins
serré en Ontario cannelé pour le
moment dans Vancouver Granville.
- C'est une soirée un peu douce-
amère pour Jagmeet Singh.
Il a clairement la balance du
pouvoir actuellement. Il va être
un jour important dans le
prochain Parlement. C'est un
gouvernement minoritaire, mais
fort.
Ce que ça veut dire aussi, pour
le NPD, il y aura des choix
déchirants. On parlait de Trans
Mountain de, dans l'Ouest
canadien, on a vu les résultats
en Alberta, cible, en
Saskatchewan aussi. Là-bas,
c'est identitaire. C'est un
symbole comme la loi 21 peut
l'être ici. Il faut faire
attention comment on manipule ce
dossier. On pourrait s'appuyer
sur les conservateurs sur un
dossier comme ça. Ça va être
fort intéressant ce Parlement à
suivre.
- Une valse et parfois avec le
bloc. C'est arrivé à l'époque.
- On a fait inscrire le
déséquilibre fiscal dans le
discours du 30. C'est réglé.
- Celui qui va être extrêmement
seul, au Québec, c'est cet
homme. Alexandre Boulerice qui
est réélu dans Rosemont La
Petite Patrie avec une très
bonne marge. C'est un bon
exemple, c'est le député qui
fait une différence et non pas
le parti. Monsieur Boulerice qui
est enraciné dans Rosemont La
Petite Patrie. Il doit être très
déçu quoique Alec, c'était juste
que vous venez de dire, le NPD a
un rôle important dans ce
prochain Parlement à Ottawa.
Rivière du Nord, réélu, Rhéal
Fortin. Sylvie Fréchette qui
était une candidate vedette pour
les conservateurs dans Rivière
du Nord, elle est avec notre
collègue Valérie Mikhailava
- Madame Fréchette, vous avez
terminé troisième. Vous êtes
habitué à la compétition et aux
médailles, comment vous vivez
cette défaite?
- Je ne la vois pas comme une
défaite du tout. C'est la
première fois que je me lance en
politique. Je n'avais aucune
expérience en politique mais
beaucoup de passion et
d'énergie. Pour moi, je vois
cette expérience comme un
apprentissage incroyable, une
opportunité d'aller vers les
gens et d'apprendre à connaître
davantage ma circonscription. Ma
puce est à côté de moi et elle
m'a dit qu'elle était fière de
moi.
On ne gagne pas tout le temps.
Je me dis que l'apprentissage
humain, même au niveau de ma
famille, ça va être très riche.
Encore une fois, les gens que
j'ai rencontrés, les mains que
j'ai séries, les organismes qui
m'ont laissé entrer dans leur
réalité, qui se sont ouverts que
moi, les entreprises, on a des
entreprises à Rivière du Nord
qui sont tellement bonnes,
excellente, mais qu'on ne
connaît pas. J'étais déjà
impliqué avant, j'ai été
impliqué pendant 40 jours et je
vais continuer d'être impliqué.
- On va peut-être vous revoir à
la prochaine élection?
- Je vais commencer par dormir
demain on verra ce qui va se
passer par la suite.
- Merci beaucoup Madame
Fréchette. Elle s'est présentée
dans Rivière du Nord. Une
circonscription qui est à l'eau
bloquistes Rhéal Fortin qui est
réélue pour un deuxième mandat.
- Merci Valérie.
Elle était bonne joueuse. Merci
à Madame Fréchette. Regardez ces
chiffres, Mesdames et Messieurs.
33,9 % pour les libéraux, 33,8 %
pour les conservateurs. Quand on
dit que les conservateurs
gaspillent du vote, dans les
prairies et en Alberta, voici un
bon exemple. Ils ont beaucoup de
vote mais ça ne donne pas autant
de circonscriptions.
- Absolument pas.
C'est vraiment choquant, ils
sont à égalité, on voit la
différence entre efficacité du
vote libéral et la concentration
du vote des conservateurs. C'est
un parlement est un pays très
divisé que l'on voit et je pense
que ça va faire...
si on pensait que le dernier
gouvernement était houleux,
celui-ci ma lettre.
- Il y a une division au
couteau. Les libéraux qui sont
éliminés de deux provinces
totalement. Il y a des
lendemains qui seront
difficiles.
- J'ose espérer que ça peut même
peut-être forcer les compromis.
Les chefs de parti vont devoir
prendre acte du résultat aussi.
On est devant un parlement ou le
NPD, devoir le NPD et non le
Bloc québécois qu'à la balance
du pouvoir, ça pourrait
faciliter peut-être d'une
certaine façon une coalition,
mais des ententes sur le certain
nombre de dossiers.
Mais c'est sûr que Monsieur
Trudeau, le défi, c'est-à-dire
qu'il va devoir changer de ton
et replacer les cartes pour
justement favoriser un
rapprochement parce que c'est
clair qu'on le voit par le
- Patrice rappelle le résultat
de Pierre-Elliott Trudeau. Ce
qu'il protège les libéraux dans
l'ouest de la loi sur les
espèces menacées, il y avait pas
de députés à l'ouest de tendeur
pendant plusieurs années.
Avec le programme national de
l'énergie toute sortes de choses
a été une vraie situation
explosive dans le Canada.
- Un gouvernement minoritaire
après avec Trudeau père.
- Tout ça risque de se produire
une autre fois.
Et ce qui est plus grave pour M.
Toulouse qu'il a perdu sa base
de Québec pour le même prix.
Demain matin, il y a plus de
député bloc risque de députés
libéraux Québec.
Il perd sur deux tableaux.
- Les conservateurs viennent de
devancer des libéraux dans le
vote populaire.
C'est 1/10 et 33, neufs et 33,
ce qui montre que quand ils font
70 % de suffrages dans une
province, ils accumulent. Il
n'accumule pas de
circonscription.
- La différence avec les années
70 avec Pierre-Elliott Trudeau
et il y avait déjà... c'est
Jason Kenney maintenant qui elle
a été très différent.
Il parlait de faire un
référendum sur la péréquation,
c'est un conservateur social
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
très différent de l'époque qui
avait la stature d'un homme
d'État..
- C'était un centrisme surtout.
- Jason Kenney vu que Trans
Mountain se fasse. C'est son
premier objectif. La
péréquation, peut-être Gilles.
Je pense qu'il va réussir à
s'entendre avec le premier
ministre Trudeau s'il peut voir
s'il y a un chemin ou un
sentier.
- Les conservateurs vont
l'appuyer. Ça va passer.
- C'est beaucoup pour lui.
- Ça ne pas trouvé Trudeau aussi
intelligent. Il va y avoir des
disputes mais je pense que Jason
Kenney, son premier objectif
c'est pas de couper la gorge
quelqu'un c'est d'obtenir le
pipeline Trans Mountain.
- Mais Patrice en même temps, je
pense que comme M. Trudeau l'a
échappé belle, on peut dire ça
comme ça, il y a quand même une
deuxième chance, une chance de
coaliser ce qu'il a appelé lui-
même le vote progressiste.
Il va falloir qu'il le fasse
parce que si elle ne le fait
pas, justement Jason Kenney, je
suis pas persuadé qu'il va
rester en Alberta si longtemps
que ça. Est-ce qu'il va lorgner
le leadership du parti
conservateur fédéral aussi?
On ne sait pas. Alors il y a une
menace à court et moyen terme
qui est vraiment là à la droite,
il faut pas sous-estimer la
droite non plus au Canada.
Pour ça il faut qu'il coalisait,
M. Trudeau.
- Va parler avec un conservateur
qui est avec notre journaliste,
Alain Rayes.
On est à vous, M. Rayes.
- Oui on est avec Alain Rayes,
le lieutenant politique du
Québec. D'abord félicitations
pour cette réélection.
J'imagine que ce ne sont pas les
résultats attendus pour votre
parti. Votre première réaction?
- Premièrement très heureux
d'avoir gagné la confiance des
citoyens pour une deuxième
élection d'enrichissement
Arthabaska. Déçu de ne pas être
au gouvernement parce que tout
le monde travaille pour gagner
pour gouverner et mettre à
l'avant-plan de mesure qu'on a
présentée à la population.
À titre personnel avec le
travail qu'on a fait sur le
terrain au Québec naturellement
c'est pas l'auteur.
Ce soir mes pensées sont
beaucoup plus pour les 67 autres
candidats et candidates au
Québec qui ont décidé de faire
la bataille avec nous sur le
terrain des hommes et des femmes
de grande qualité. Je pense que
tout le monde reconnaissait
qu'on avait une magnifique
Équipe Québec, et les résultats
sont pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on aurait espéré travailler
doublement plus fort dans la
prochaine année, les prochaines
années qui en viennent mais au
moins on a une base solide
Québec pour penser à construire.
- Il y a un message visiblement
tu n'as pas passé auprès des
électeurs québécois.
Qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
pour le Parti conservateur ici
dans la province?
- Je pense qu'on va faire un
post-mortem va se rasseoir tout
le monde ensemble pour évaluer
les résultats. On avait des
hommes et des femmes
extraordinaires sur le terrain
pour faire la campagne.
On avait une plate-forme qui
provenait de notre tournée à
l'écoute des Québécois pour les
gens à combler le rapport
d'impôts et plus d'argent dans
nos poches et plus de pouvoir en
immigration et en culture au
Québec. Et d'arriver dans la
campagne avec la loi 21...
on pensait avoir les outils pour
faire la bataille respecter les
juridictions provinciales avec
le gouvernement conservateur des
centralisateurs. Il faut croire
que le message ne s'est pas
rendu à la population.
On a un post-mortem à faire et à
s'asseoir et regarder ce qui
doit être fait mieux la
prochaine fois.
Ce que je constate qu'au moins
qu'on a une base, une
organisation dans les 78
circonscriptions dans lesquelles
on va voir reconstruire.
- Déception évidemment au niveau
national pour son parti.
- Merci Alain Rayes qui est un
bon joueur. François-Philippe
Champagne finalement qui a été
réélu dans Saint Maurice
Champlain, voilà une bonne
avance! On le mettait dans la
colonne de peut-être des gains
possibles pour le bloc. Marc
Garneau dans Notre Dame de Grâce
Westmount, c'est pas une
surprise. Ça doit être une des
plus fortes majorités avec Mont-
Royal au Québec pour les
libéraux. Lasalle aussi,
l'ancienne circonscription de
Paul Martin. David Lametti qui
aura une décision important
d'apprendre pour SNC-Lavalin.
Ils sont devant la cour.
Des ministres en Ontario dont
Bill Morneau, le ministre des
Finances réélu avec une
gigantesque majorité également.
- Il avait été gigantesque en
2015.
- Catherine McKenna réélue,
elle aussi avec une bonne
majorité l'ministre de
l'Environnement.
Ottawa-Centre. Dans rose del
Chrystia Freeland, réélu
également.
- Ministre des affaires
étrangères très populaires et
bien vu dans le cabinet.
- Les anges non justes perdus
deux en Ontario, les libéraux.
- Effectivement et cette
histoire de la soirée, Patrice,
de perte alors qu'il y en a eue
plus ailleurs. L'Ontario a tenu
bon. S'ils avaient pu gagner le
Québec, peut-être qu'ils
auraient réussi à avoir un
gouvernement majoritaire.
- On va vous montrer un tableau
dans quelques secondes avec les
plus et les moins dans les
provinces, c'est très parlant.
En Ontario, ça a été solide pour
les libéraux. Ce qui leur a
permis d'arriver avec quoi?
160 malgré tout au Canada.
Avec une poussée du bloc malgré
tout, avec 34.
Imaginez un affaiblissement en
Ontario s'était terminé.
- Oui ça aurait été terminé.
- On les a, excusez-moi.
Moins deux, en Ontario ça n'a
pas bougé. Plus trois pour les
conservateurs, c'était pas
suffisant. Et les néodémocrate
qui en perdent une.
Au Québec regarder, -7 pour les
libéraux. Plus 24 pour le Bloc
québécois. -3 pour les
conservateurs. Le visage de
Alain Rayes qui ne mentait pas.
-14, il en reste un enrôlement
pour les néodémocrate.
Comme l'a dit Françoise tout à
l'heure. Est-ce qu'il attendra
un autre bon moment où il
décidera un jour que son avenir
est ailleurs? On verra.
- Il va trouver le temps long.
Les réunions de caucus, pauvre
Alexandre va être assez plate.
Mais il va être au moins
d'accord avec...
- C'est comme celui qui avait
fini par quitter le parti à
l'époque.
- Il était dans Beloeil.
- Oui.
- C'est le dernier gaulois qui
est encore léger confiance qu'il
va être capable de rebâtir,
mais il faudra qu'il fasse un
virage, le parti au complet au
Québec, c'est certain.
-  Laurier Sainte Marie l'écart
se creuse pour Steven Guilbault.
Il y a vraiment des
circonscriptions Québec où les
libéraux vont sabrer le
champagne. Ils avaient peur de
le perdre, ce n'est pas terminé,
ce n'est pas terminé mais tout
de même!
Parce que deux parties dans
cette circonscription.
- C'est une bataille de
circonscription.
- Hoche là, ça vous surprend
Gilles?
- Il y a une partie au nord de
Sherbrooke, c'est pas le
Hochelaga du temps de l'époque.
- Regarder Lyne Bessette qui est
capable de pédaler vite, elle a
devancé Monique Allard.
Je vous ai fait rire!
Elle est en avance. Ça va être
surveillé parce que c'est très,
très serré quand même.
Sherbrooke également serré mais
la tendance se maintient. Quand
l'avance se maintient deux fois
en fois, c'est un signe pour
Élisabeth Brière qui est pour
les libéraux.
- Et Pierre-Luc Dusseault est
deuxième. Il a quand même 212
voix qui séparent Mme Brière de
M. Dusseault.
Les néodémocrate espéraient
échapper cette circonscription.
- Est-ce que l'université de
Sherbrooke est rentrée...
- Regardez Trois Rivières,
messieurs dames, c'est très
serré mais ce que je retiens,
moi... c'est comme si la
politique est injuste, et
cruelle. Déjà quand ça va mal,
circonscription qu'il voulait au
Québec avec Yves Lévesque,
les conservateurs ne l'ont pas.
-  c'est une course à trois
parce qu'il y a 103 voix.
M. Lévesque n'est pas si loin
troisième.
- Mais il est quand même
Lui se voyait que premier.
Stéphane Bergeron, gain pour
Montarville pour le bloc.
Il retourna la Chambre des
communes et ancien député du
Parti québécois également.
J'aimerais savoir, est-ce que
c'est le dernier?
Abitibi, baie James.
Ça, c'est réglé une ancienne
circonscription de Roméo
Saganash du NPD.
La candidate du NPD est loin,
loin derrière.
On va aller écouter si vous le
voulez bien M. Bernier qui a
commencé à parler.
On l'écoute.
(en anglais)
Donc une alternative importante
qui contrastait avec...
mais ce qu'ils ont fait,
ce n'était pas en vain.
Ce que nous avons réussi en à
peine une seule année est
spectaculaire.
(applaudissements)
Nous avions plus de 315
candidats et candidates du parti
populaire à travers le pays.
Ils ont fait preuve d'un courage
et d'une passion extraordinaire
et remarquable en défendant nos
principes et nos valeurs.
Ils l'ont fait malgré des
attaques honteuses de la part de
nos opposants. Ils ont fait
d'immenses sacrifices personnels
pour offrir aux électeurs
canadiens une option fondée sur
des principes différents de
toutes les autres options des
partis politiques.
Et laissez-moi vous le dire
qu'ils n'ont pas fait ça pour
rien. Ils ont construit la
fondation d'un mouvement qui ne
fait que commencer.
(applaudissements)
Des centaines de milliers de
Canadiens ont donné leur appui
au parti populaire aujourd'hui.
Nous sommes le parti qui grandit
le plus vite dans l'histoire
canadienne.
Et nous allons continuer de
grandir au cours des prochains
mois et années.
(en anglais)
Il et question de bâtir les
fondations. Des centaines de
milliers de Canadiens ont appui
notre parti aujourd'hui.
Nous sommes le parti qui a la
croissance l'plus rapide de
l'histoire du Canada et nous
allons continuer de croître dans
les mois et les années à venir.
Les enjeux que nous avons
soulevés pendant cette campagne
électorale ne vont pas
disparaître.
L'immigration non durable, les
déficits sans fin et la
péréquation inévitable,
la politique de grande
envergure, les impôts élevés...
tous ces problèmes vont rester
là et nous serons là afin de
critiquer le gouvernement
y offrir de meilleures
solutions.
Ce que nous avons suite à la
campagne va pas disparaître une
immigration non contrôlée, les
déficits sans fin, la
péréquation injuste, achat de
vote de la politique de gros
gouvernement international, les
taxes élevées... tous ces
problèmes ne vont pas
disparaître. Et nous serons là,
nous serons là pour critiquer le
prochain gouvernement et offrir
de meilleures solutions.
Nous allons continuer de nous
battre pour la liberté, la
responsabilité, l'équité et le
respect. Nous serons plus fort
la prochaine fois.
Ce n'est qu'un début pour le
parti populaire.
(en anglais)
Il n'y a pas d'autres options
pour notre pays. Nous serons
plus fort la prochaine fois.
Nous allons continuer de nous
battre pour la liberté, la
responsabilité de l'équité le
respect, ce n'est qu'un début
pour le parti populaire.
(applaudissements)
♪ ♪ ♪
Merci!
(applaudissements)
- Alors voilà, dure soirée pour
Maxime Bernier qui se retrouve
orphelin, il n'a plus de
circonscription. Il n'est plus
député de Beauce.
Il a un parti mais qu'est-ce
qu'il adviendra de son parti? On
verra, il avait réussi il faut
le souligner à présenter des
candidats dans à peu près toutes
les circonscriptions du pays.
Lui était le seul qui avait une
réelle chance de le remporter.
Il faut croire que les gens de
la Beauce, il y avait la gestion
de la faisait problème avec les
producteurs, c'est une évidence
mais les gens de beaux sourcils
qui ont été choqués certainement
par certaines prises de position
plus externe Maxime Bernier.
Vous avez travaillé avec lui
dans le même cabinet, le même
conseil des ministres. Est-ce
que ça vous a étonné?
- Non parce que c'est quelqu'un
de très déterminé. Il faut quand
même reconnaître qu'il a bâti
quelque chose. Je suis
totalement en désaccord avec 70
% de ce qu'il avance, mais je
lui donne quand même crédit
d'avoir eu cette ténacité.
Maxime, bienvenue à la vraie
vie, les parties sont pas ici
pour s'envoyer des fleurs.
Il parlait comme quelqu'un qui
pense que le parti allait
sauver. Clairement...
voyons. Peut-être mais qui
d'autre est identifiable dans ce
parti à part l'ancienne épouse
de Rob Ford, il y a personne.
C'est un parti qui va
s'effondrer probablement.
Et Maxime je ne sais pas ce
qu'il va devenir mais il parle
comme quelqu'un qu'elle peut
être resté autour. J'en doute je
pense que sa carrière politique
déterminée.
- C'est clair!
Un petit mot parce qu'il avait
été on se souvient, nous on s'en
souvient en organiser le débat,
on pensait que peut-être allait
sauver sa conception ce n'a pas
été le cas.
- Maxime Bernier a réussi à se
démarquer à la course au parti
conservateur avec la gestion de
l'offre notamment. Il a fait la
même chose avec la campagne
électorale en prenant des propos
très tranchés sur
l'environnement. Pour être
capable de faire un peu de
bruit. Je pense qu'il a choisi
le mauvais cheval de bataille
pour cette campagne électorale
où l'environnement était dans la
tête des gens. Ça a discrédité
tout le reste de son programme.
Le Maxime Bernier du débat des
chapitres sur le même plateau
que nous quand il parlait de
gestion des finances publiques,
de baisse des impôts il y a des
gens qui écoutent ce message qui
trouve ça intéressant. C'est
quand il parle de changement
climatique il se discrédite. En
immigration il a des positions
extrêmes. S'il avait un peu plus
en retrait je pense qu'il aurait
eu un peu plus de chances de
remporter.
- Très bon point.
Convoqué le chef des vert est
réélu dans sa circonscription.
Il y en a quatre en tête pour
l'instant élu est en tête.
Deux élus et deux en-têtes.
Mme avait d'autres ambitions
pour son parti.
- Elle voulait obtenir le statut
de parti officiel c'est-à-dire
12 sièges, et elle espérait
sinon obtenir la balance du
pouvoir donc évidemment c'est
pas elle qui contrôle ça la
balance du pouvoir et ça dépend
du des résultats d'autres
parties mais clairement en ce
moment, elle n'a réussi ni ni
l'autre.
- Très bien alors on reviendra
en Colombie-Britannique qu'est-
ce qu'on en dit.
Avec nous Alexandre Boulerice.
Pendant qu'on voit des résultats
des verts qui mènent en
Colombie-Britannique.
- Un modelé qui mène par 301
voix. Il avait été élu dans une
partielle. Winnipeg Centre,
il y a une autre verte qui mène.
Andrea...
- c'est une erreur.
- Oubliez ça!
On ne l'a pas vue.
Alexandre Boulerice Rosemont-La
Petite-Patrie réélu est avec
nous.
M. Boulerice, d'abord
félicitations pour votre
bataille dans Rosemont.
Bravo!
- Merci, merci beaucoup!
Êtes-vous assommé des résultats
du NPD?
- Je pense qu'on savait dès le
départ que ça pouvait être une
campagne difficile. On a montré
beaucoup de caractère. Je pense
que Jagmeet Singh s'est révélé
parmi cette campagne avec une
commande très positive, axée sur
l'environnement, la lutte aux
inégalités sociales. Il aurait
peut-être fallu qu'on est un peu
plus de temps. Malgré des
résultats qui peuvent apparaître
décevant, on a ouvert des portes
et des routes pour l'avenir.
C'est la première partie, la
première période de nouveau
match de hockey pour nous.
- Vous aurez un rôle important à
jouer dans la suite des choses
pour M. Trudeau. Quel rôle vous
imaginait jouer et comment vous
voyez la suite des choses au
Parlement?
- Ça va être extrêmement
intéressant parce qu'on a un
gouvernement libéral en position
minoritaire qui va avoir besoin
d'appuyer pour survivre. Donc il
va devoir négocier. On va
pouvoir aller s'asseoir à la
table et avoir des discussions
et essayer d'obtenir des gains
pour les Québécois et
Québécoises pour les programmes
sociaux, la santé, logement.
C'est vraiment tout un nouveau
chapitre de l'histoire politique
qui s'ouvre à partir de ce soir.
On a un contingent pour des
députés ni aux démocrates,
malgré les pertes ici au Québec.
Je pense qu'on va être capable
de jouer un rôle positif dans ce
projet Parlement. J'ai bien hâte
de voir ça. Pour le Québec je
rappelle que Ruth Ellen Brosseau
est encore dans une bataille
très serrée et elle pourrait
remporter sa circonscription.
- On vient de voir Sherbrooke à
l'écran. C'est très serré. Et
Berthier-Maskinongé. Un petit
peu moins serré mais disons
qu'il y a une possibilité. Dans
Sherbrooke et ses 65 voies.
Pierre-Luc Dusseault est passé
premier.
Est-ce qu'il y a des sujets sur
lesquels vous ne ferez pas de
compromis avec les libéraux? Par
exemple l'agrandissement de
Trans Mountain. Est-ce que ce
serait de nature à faire tomber
le gouvernement libéral?
- Vous savez je pense qu'on a
fait campagne contre l'expansion
de Trans Mountain pour un virage
vers des énergies renouvelables.
C'est sûr que pour nous est un
point majeur était quelque chose
d'extrêmement sensible. Ce soir
à chaud, je ne vais pas
commencer à fixer des
conditions. Mais je pense que
c'est OK pour nous ce serait une
priorité. Jagmeet Singh l'a déjà
dit. Mais attendons de voir qui
les libéraux vont vouloir tendre
la main dans le projet
Parlement.
- Monsieur Dussollier de
repasser deuxième dans
Sherbrooke par 53 votes. Avant
de vous faire mourir en direct
on va vous laisser aller écouter
les résultats.
On le voit dans votre
circonscription, les gens
apprécient les députés qui font
une différence, qui sont
enracinés.
Félicitations pour votre
campagne.
- Merci beaucoup Monsieur Roy.
Bonne soirée électorale à tout
le monde!
- C'est incroyable dans
Sherbrooke. Sa passer de l'un à
l'autre!
Gaspésie Les Îles de la
Madeleine aussi, ce n'est pas
terminé.
Ils y a vraiment des cours à
suivre qui ne sont pas terminés.
- Une circonscription Hossa
jouait à la bascule une partie
de la soirée. C'est la ministre
du revenu qui mène par 348 voix.
Il y a 189 bureaux de scrutins
qui ont été dépouillés. Ça
comment achever cette course.
Dans Compton Stanstead une
ministre qui se porte un peu
mieux. Une avance de 1865 voies.
Devant le bloquistes David
Benoît.
Québec là aussi, on surveillait
cette course. Une avance de 769
voix pour Jean-Yves Duclos
devant Christiane Gagnon qui
voudrait faire un retour à la
chambre des communes pour le
Bloc québécois.
- Ah!
Steven Guilbeault est élu dans
Laurier Sainte-Marie.
Un gain pour les libéraux. Il
aura réussi son pari qui était
risqué.
Ses anciens amis se sont mis à
écrire des lettres incendiaires
à son endroit dans les derniers
jours. Il a gardé le cap. Il a
dit : je veux par le pari que
dans un gouvernement, je peux
faire une différence. Comme
Nicolas Hulot. On verra combien
de temps ça durera.
- Le vote du NPD ne s'est pas
effondré. C'est beaucoup Projet
Montréal et Québec solidaire.
- Est-ce qu'il va se satisfaire
d'être adjoint parlementaire de
quelqu'un d'autre?
- Je pense que c'est assez clair
que...
- ça, c'est l'autre affaire!
- Ce n'est pas pour rien que M.
Trudeau l'a nommé président de
son comité de l'environnement
avant. J'imagine qu'il va lui
réserver une place au sein de
son cabinet.
- Dans la mesure où la question
d'une urgence climatique va
vraiment devenir prioritaire,
c'est sûr que le recrutement de
Steven Guilbeault par Justin
Trudeau était absolument
fondamental.
Et sa victoire aussi est
absolument fondamentale. Je
pense que Steven Guilbeault,
c'est quelqu'un qui va monter
dans le parti libéral du Canada.
C'est quelqu'un qui va prendre
vraiment du galon. C'est
quelqu'un qui a attendu très
longtemps. Ça fait des années
que la rumeur circule. On se
demande toujours quand est-ce
qu'il va se présenter. Alors je
pense qu'il a décidé parce qu'il
veut changer les choses de
l'intérieur, on espère qu'il ne
sera pas déçu comme Monsieur
Hulot l'a été en France, mais
c'est un gros morceau.
- C'est une grosse victoire pour
lui.
- Il faut aussi souligner de
voir l'élection de Jean-Yves
Duclos ou de Mme Guilbault. Et
on verra bien aux Îles-de-la-
Madeleine. Je comprends que le
Bloc québécois a 32 députés, que
Monsieur Trudeau a réussi à
garder des députés québécois à
l'extérieur de l'de Montréal
aussi. Ça va être important pour
lui.
- Il n'a perdu aucun ministre au
Québec. Il a fait élire tous ces
candidats vedettes saufs pour
Réjean Hébert. Si Lyne Bessette
gagne et que tous ces ministres
sont en place, il a perdu des
sièges mais sa députation
québécoise dans son gouvernement
minoritaire, il sera très
heureux de l'avoir.
- Martin Champoux, c'est un gain
Don Drummond pour le Bloc
québécois. Monsieur Choquette
qui était le député sortant est
quatrième. Dans la prairie un
autre gain pour le Bloc
québécois. Alain Therrien.
- Ancien péquiste.
- Au Bloc québécois on doit être
content.
- Il reste Christiane Gagnon à
Québec.
- Il y a des gens d'expériences
qui s'en vont au Bloc québécois.
Ils vont être sur le front avant
du Bloc québécois. Ils seront
capables de brasser la cage un
peu. Ce sont des gens qui ont du
tempérament.
- Maxime Blanchette-Joncas qui
remporte la circonscription sur
Guy Caron. C'était quelqu'un
d'important dans la députation.
- Je suis quand même surprise
parce qu'il y a eu un temps
durant la soirée au Guy Caron et
est quatrième. On voit la force
de son organisation sur le
terrain. Je pense que pour le
NPD ça n'a rien à voir avec la
qualité des candidats, des
députés qui étaient en place. Je
les salue tous. Je sais
exactement comme ils se sentent
au moment où je vous parle.
C'est les circonstances, c'est
la loi 21, c'est plein de choses
qu'ils vont devoir décortiquer.
Mais il a quand même fait une
belle campagne. Une grosse perte
pour le NPD. C'est un candidat à
la chefferie. Ça fait mal.
- Un chef intérimaire aussi.
- Daniel Thibault et de
rassemblement du Bloc québécois.
32 députés pour l'instant.
Daniel vous est avec un militant
de la première heure.
- Voilà. On est descendu sur le
plancher où il y a beaucoup de
monde. Il y a René Pichet qui
est ici. Vous en avez traversé
des soirées comme ça.
- Beaucoup. J'ai toujours été
bloc CDPQ. À chaque fois qu'il y
avait des rencontres je venais
toujours au rassemblement. Ça
fait parti de notre vie au
Québec. On veut continuer là-
dedans.
- Qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence dans cette campagne
selon vous?
- Les trois autres parties se
sont aperçues que le Québec, il
n'y avait pas de danger. Ils ont
sous-estimé notre pouvoir. On se
rend compte des résultats. On
est rendu à 32.
C'est quand même bien. On est
heureux d'avoir ces résultats.
- En début de campagne pensiez-
vous faire ce genre de résultat?
- Non. Je m'attendais à moins.
On voit le contraire qui se
produit aujourd'hui. On est tous
heureux.
On va quand même défendre notre
loi sur la laïcité avec un bloc
qui va défendre le pourcentage
des Québécois.
- Merci beaucoup!
C'est un militant. Il y en a des
centaines d'autres derrière qui
sont très bruyants et qui
réagissent à chaque fois que
vous parlez de candidats en
avance ou élu. Ils ont une bonne
soirée ici.
- Merci Daniel!
On est content. On le serait à
moins.
Avec 32, on est trois fois plus
nombreuses à la chambre des
communes.
Yves Perron dans Berthier-
Maskinongé qui creuse son avance
sur Ruth Ellen Brosseau. Il y a
eu un éclat de sympathie autour
de la table.
Dans Beauport Limoilou.
- Ça me surprend. Une avance de
1078.
Les conservateurs sont
troisièmes ici.
- Rivière-des-Mille-Iles, Luc
Desilets. Une avance de plus de
1000 voix sur la sortante Linda
Lapointe.
- Linda Lapointe qui a mené une
campagne du matin au soir. Elle
voulait conserver son siège. On
disait qu'elle travaillait de
façon acharnée. Jusqu'à
maintenant c'est une lutte qui
est serrée. Dans Shefford
Andréanne Larouche qui mène par
950 voix devant le député
sortant libéral Pierre Breton.
- Sommaire Québec. Vous le
voyez, le Bloc québécois de 10 à
30 : c'est 22 gains pour le Bloc
québécois. À Montréal, un.
La Pointe de l'Île. Couronne de
Montréal, on était assaisonnée
maintenant à 15 :
région de Québec, on était à
zéro on est maintenant à deux.
Ça explique les 22 des
différences pour le Bloc
québécois. Une bonne soirée pour
les bloquistes.
Notre collègue et avec le
ministre réélu Philippe
champagne.
François Philippe champagne.
- Il a été réélu pour une
deuxième fois ce soir.
Vous savez, François Philippe
champagne s'est fait attendre ce
soir.
Vous vous êtes laissé attendre
ce soir ça été long avant que
vous arriviez. La soirée était
plus longue en 2015 alors que
vous aviez été un des premiers
élus confirmés.
- D'abord j'ai fait le tour de
tous les pôles. La Mauricie
c'est un grand comté.
Je voulais arriver ici pour être
avec les bénévoles et les
militants. Les gens sont là. Le
message pendant cette campagne,
on a beaucoup parlé, les
Canadiens se sont faits
entendre. L'important c'est
qu'on soit au gouvernement avec
Monsieur Trudeau. On a démontré
que l'équipe libérale pourrait
faire une différence à l'échelle
nationale. On va continuer à
être là pour les familles. Notre
façon de voir l'avenir a
toujours été d'investir. On sera
là pour les gens. On a depuis le
début que nous notre façon de
gouverner, c'était investir dans
les gens.
- C'est quand même gouvernement
minoritaire. Ça change un peu la
donne.
Comment vous voyez la suite des
choses?
- On va travailler. L'importance
soirée de prendre constat du
message des Canadiens. Ils nous
ont demandé de continuer de
gouverner dans la direction
qu'on a prise, d'investir. Je
l'ai fait dans les
infrastructures. Cette formule
va rester. C'est clair que les
gens nous ont élu. Je suis
content de voir aussi qu'on a
besoin de voix forte pour les
régions du Québec. Le Québec
s'est donné les moyens de
réussir. J'ai toujours dit que
les Québécois et Québécoises
aimaient décider par eux-mêmes.
En ayant une députation libérale
forte ça va nous permettre de
défendre ses intérêts à partir
de la table des décisions. Quand
on est à la table des décisions,
cela comptait une vraie
différence. On va continuer
d'être à l'écoute parce que
clairement les gens nous ont
demandé de travailler pour eux.
- Dès demain vous commencerez à
travailler. Il n'y aura pas de
journée de congé finalement.
- On va continuer à être dans
l'action et asservir les gens.
- Merci Monsieur champagne.
François Philippe champagne et
réélu. La dernière fois la
soirée avait été beaucoup plus
courte. Il avait été un des
premiers élus confirmés en 2015.
Cette fois-ci ça a été un peu
plus long. En 2015 environ 40 %
des voix.
Mais quand même les gens sont
ici. Toute son équipe est ici ce
soir avec lui.
- Merci. S'il y avait un
concours international de celui
qui serrait le plus de même,
François Philippe champagne
gagnerait haut la main. Louis,
vous êtes avec Steven Guilbeault
et Mélanie Joly.
- Félicitations Monsieur
Guilbault. Premier sentiment?
- Très heureux vraiment. Je
remercie du fond du coeur les
électeurs et électrices de
Laurier Sainte Marie de m'avoir
confié ce privilège de les
représenter à la chambre des
communes.
- C'est extraordinaire parce
qu'on va avoir une voix forte au
niveau de l'environnement. On
sait que les Québécois nous
envoient un message ce soir. On
n'en prend acte. On sait que la
question environnementale
résonne au Québec. Avec Steven
Guilbeault, avec l'équipe de
Québécois qui ont été élus on
sera une voix forte au niveau du
Québec et aussi sur la question
environnementale.
- Il faudra peut-être négocier
avec le NPD au cours des
prochains mois. Comment vous
entrevoyez cela?
Il pourrait y avoir des points
de contentieux, notamment
l'extension de Trans Mountain.
- Lorsqu'on regarde la plate-
forme de NPD, des verres et des
libéraux, il y a énormément de
points de convergence. Plus de
technologie verte,
électrification des transports.
Moi j'avais proposé de choisir
de travailler sur ce qui nous
rassemble plutôt que sur ce qui
nous divise pour que ces
questions puissamment au Canada.
Je pense que c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde de
faire cela.
- Votre réaction au résultat
plus général ce soir. Vous
n'avez pas pu aller chercher la
croissance que vous désiriez.
Qu'est-ce que vous lisez là-
dedans?
- On a pas toujours en tête que
la politique a également un
visage humain. Je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de mère et de père de
familles qui ont travaillé
extrêmement fort au sein du
caucus du Québec au cours des
quatre dernières années.
Malheureusement ils ne seront
pas à nouveau à la chambre des
communes. Mon coeur et mes
pensées sont avec eux.
Je tiens à les remercier pour
leur travail parce que je sais
qu'ils ont donné une voix forte
Québécois. Maintenant on prend
acte de ce qui s'est passé au
Québec et au pays. Ensemble, les
députés élus on sera là pour
défendre les intérêts des
Québécoises et des Québécois
parce que c'est important que le
Québec est une voix forte dans
ce gouvernement.
- Le message est lancé et
félicitations à vous deux pour
votre réélection.
- Un petit tour dans Hochelaga.
C'est un gain pour cette
libérale. M. Duceppe tout à
l'heure disait que c'était
étonnant. Ça montre ce que vous
disiez à l'ex- un peu plus tôt.
Les libéraux ne se sont pas
effondrés au Québec.
- Pas du tout. Ils ont dégagé.
Hochelaga, c'est un gain net.
Monsieur Guilbault dans Laurier
Sainte Marie également. Le Bloc
québécois a privé le
gouvernement libéral de sa
majorité.
- Oh!
Vancouver Granville, Jody
Wilson-Raybould Akeem Haynes par
17 voix!
50 boîtes ont été ouvertes.
- C'est une course à trois.
- Elizabeth May de l'encens. Ils
avaient allumé des lampions.
- Si on revient à Hochelaga..
- c'est très excitant aussi.
- Tout à fait.
C'est la performance du NPD dans
Hochelaga. Encore une fois on
voit l'alliance Projet Montréal
Québec solidaire et NPD qui
donne 5000 votes. Si ces votes
ne vont pas ou NPD, à ce moment-
là les libéraux ne gagnent pas.
- Sherbrooke, je vous donne des
nouvelles. Ça continue à changer
d'enchères broke. Pierre-Luc
Dusseault qui a repris l'avance
pour la troisième fois. C'est
vraiment une course croisée avec
la libérale.
On va suivre cela pour une
partie de la fin de la soirée.
Berthier-Maskinongé, à suivre
aussi. Ruth Ellen Brosseau qui
est deuxième.
Ce n'est pas tant que ça.
Denis Trudel, comédien. Ce ne
sera pas un rôle pour lui. Il
sera député de Longueuil. Il
fera son entrée à la chambre des
communes. Jean-Sébastien vous
est avec le nouveau député de
Longueuil.
- Le gagnant de cette
circonscription qui en était à
sa deuxième tentative.
Monsieur Trudel, cinquième, vous
en allez à Ottawa. Votre
réaction?
- Merci. Ça alla qu'ils me
laisseront pas parler. Je suis
très content.
C'est ma deuxième campagne.
C'est surtout aussi, je pense
que les Québécois envoient un
message clair. Je pense qu'on va
être une trentaine, on va
s'occuper des Québécois dans les
prochaines années à Ottawa.
- Comment voyez-vous ce nouveau
rôle?
- On verra demain comment on va
planifier cela. Le chef pas
seulement en parler. Mais pour
le moment, on est content. C'est
la fête des militants.
Toute mon équipe, on a travaillé
super fort.
Ce soir, on célèbre et demain,
on va à Ottawa.
- Quelle a été le point
tournant? On s'était parlé en
début de campagne, n'était pas
nécessairement le favori. Quelle
a été le point tournant dans
longue?
- Dans Longueuil, c'est
difficile à dire. Je continue à
penser que le point tournant de
la campagne, c'est la réaction
de Yves-François Blanchet au
blackface de Justin Trudeau.
Il aurait pu en profiter pour
faire du capital politique. Il a
été au diapason des Québécois.
Il a dit : il n'est pas raciste.
Les Québécois se sont reconnus
dans cette réaction. À ce
moment, les Québécois ont
recommencé à écouter le Bloc
québécois.
- Félicitations. Au revoir.
- Merci Jean-Sébastien.
- Trois Rivières.
- Monsieur Blanchet avait une
réaction.
Louise Charbonneau, c'est réglé.
Le rêve de Yves Lévesque vient
de s'effondrer. Il est
troisième.
- C'était vraiment une grande
déception pour le parti
conservateur. C'était un des
indicateurs du succès du parti
conservateur ce soir. C'était
délire Yves Lévesque dans Trois
Rivières et c'est raté.
- C'est important pour le Bloc
québécois. Le Parti québécois ne
fait pas de bons résultats dans
cette région. D'aller chercher
Trois Rivières, c'est un gain
important pour le bloc. C'est un
endroit qu'on espérait mais au
début, ce n'était pas dans les
cartons. Yves Lévesque est un
monument là-bas.
- Oui.
- C'était une course à trois.
- Regardez le sommaire au
Québec. Moins cet débuté pour
les libéraux. Plus 22 pour le
bloc, moins deux pour le parti
conservateur est -13 pour le
NPD. On verra celui du Canada.
Madeleine?
- Vous voyez à quoi ça
ressemble. Du bleu poudre
partout au Québec.
Regardez la carte en 2015, il y
avait beaucoup plus d'oranges.
C'est la couleur qui a
pratiquement disparu de la carte
du Québec. On peut surveiller ce
qui se passe ici dans ce comté,
si on est capable de se rendre,
c'est celui de Sherbrooke.
Peut-être que Pierre-Luc
Dusseault sera un rescapé de
cette soirée mais peut-être pas.
66 voix qui mènent en ce moment,
c'est une très courte avance. On
a vu toute la soirée, ça a été
des revirements sans cesse.
Cette lutte n'est pas terminée.
Ailleurs, il y a quand même eu
des pertes pour le Parti
libéral, surtout dans la
couronne de Montréal.
On voit à quel point ça a changé
de couleur. C'était en 2019,
seront retourne en 2015, il y
avait des sièges libéraux
supplémentaires. Revenons à
2019. Le Bloc québécois a fait
des gains un peu partout dans la
couronne mais ailleurs en région
aussi.
- La Pointe de l'Île qui est
resté bleu pâle, pas d'autres
gains. On espérait Hochelaga et
Laurier Sainte Marie.
Jagmeet Singh, il aurait un
parcours plus difficile que
prévu Madeleine?
- Dans Burnaby Sud, rappelez-
vous à quel point il avait mené
une lutte sans merci pour gagner
son siège dans une élection
partielle. Il avait passé
beaucoup de temps dans sa
circonscription. Il a dû diviser
son temps dans l'ensemble du
pays. Ce n'est pas facile pour
lui ce soir. Une avance de 710
voix devant les conservateurs.
- Ce n'est pas facile du tout.
C'est comme si la réalité le
rattrapait.
On le savait, ça...
- une avance de 5000, c'est
majeur.
- C'est la bonne nouvelle pour
le parti conservateur.
- Bien oui.
Il est avec nous. Merci Bernier,
bonsoir. Monsieur Bernier, dure
soirée.
Vous avez dit que c'est à cause
des autres parties mais il
n'allait pas vous faire de
cadeaux non plus.
- Non, ça a été une dure soirée,
vous avez raison de le dire mais
je suis quand même fier de la
campagne qu'on a faite en Beauce
et partout au Canada.
Le parti populaire et un jeune
parti comme vous le savez. Il
s'agit de contre le parti sur de
bonnes fondations je pense qu'on
a les bonnes fondations.
Pour les Canadiens qui croient
un gouvernement limité, on va
continuer à se. C'est une soirée
difficile pour moi.
- Vous avez l'intention de
rester à la tête de ce parti et
de tenter de continuer à le
faire vivre?
C'est ce que vous dîtes ce soir?
- De continuer à le faire vivre
et de me représenter à une
prochaine élection ici, c'est
mon choix premier, de toujours
représenter les citoyens. On va
avoir du temps pour continuer à
bâtir ce parti à travers le
pays. On va continuer, on ne
lâche pas la serviette.
C'est un renouveau pour le parti
mais comme j'ai dit dans mon
discours, je suis vraiment
un peu abasourdi.
- On le voit.
- On va se relever.
On va voir ce qui va arriver. Je
pense que pour le parti, il y a
un bout dans les prochaines
années.
- Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas matière
à réflexion? Je ne veux pas vous
accabler, ce n'est pas le
moment, mais est-ce que vous ne
voyez pas par ses résultats que
les Québécois et les Canadiens
n'aiment pas trop les extrêmes
et que vous avez dans certains
dossiers, vous êtes aller fort?
Il y a des choses sur lesquelles
les gens étaient d'accord avec
vous, mais il ne faut pas
exagérer. Ce n'est pas le
message?
- Le message par rapport à
l'immigration, c'est un nouveau
débat que l'on fait au Canada.
On a eu ce débat au Québec et on
a toujours ce débat. On va
continuer. C'est une politique
importante de notre parti. Ça
prend plus de temps peut-être à
communiquer cette politique, on
va travailler plus fort sur le
terrain. On verra dans les
prochains mois.
Mais la plateforme de notre
parti, les principes fondateurs
de notre parti vont demeurer.
- Monsieur Bernier, merci de
nous avoir parlé.
- C'est moi qui vous remercie.
Au revoir.
- La définition d'un homme
effectivement sous le choc, on
vient de l'avoir.
- Quand tu peux garder ta
circonscription, tu as une
plateformes, soit un salaire, ça
ne nuit pas à personne. Tu peux
voyager. Soit des. D'Air Canada.
Là, tu n'as pas ça. Tu n'as pas
de salaire, tu n'as pas les
passes d'Air Canada, qu'est-ce
que tu fais? Il faut faire du
financement. Ce n'est pas la
même plateformes.
- Il donnait l'impression, on ne
passera pas Milan là-dessus,
mais donner l'impression qu'il
était sûr de gagner la Beauce.
- Je suis convaincu qu'il était.
Ça fait des décennies
que de père en fils, on se dit
qu'on contrôle.
Je pense que c'est un choc.
- Clairement.
Pardonnez-moi, Ralph Goodale
qui est défait.
Et pas à peu près.
- Avec un recul de 3596 voix,
c'est énorme.
Il sollicitait 1/10 mandat. Il
faisait parti des meubles en
Saskatchewan.
Il était une cible deux fois
de choix pour le parti
conservateur.
- C'est un des solides de ce
gouvernement.
- Marie-Claude Bibeau, réélue.
C'était serré. Maintenant, c'est
réglé dans Compton Stanstead.
Vous le dit, Ralph Goodale, les
gens l'aimaient.
- Dans le cabinet Trudeau,
il y avait beaucoup de
nouveautés en 2015. Il y a
encore des gens un peu faibles
dans son cabinet. Le perdre, à
mon point de vue, c'est une
grosse perte.
- C'est symbolique. C'est un
balayage conservateur dans
l'Ouest. Ces diviser sur les
questions de l'énergie et
l'environnement. Trudeau va
avoir à gérer cela.
Cette impression du NPD, ça va
être un chantage incroyable lors
de ce prochain budget.
Ça va être la grande question,
ça va déchirer le pays.
- Il y a détention et non pas
l'histoire du pétrole, Alec,
vous avez bien fait de le
souligner tout à l'heure, quand
vous avez fait comprendre...
c'est un peu comme la laïcité.
Ils vont me monter au créneau
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose qui
ça passe rapidement.
- Ils vont le faire parce qu'ils
ont un premier ministre qui
prend énormément de place, Jason
Kenny. Mais si Andrew Scheer
démissionne, et non pas avantage
à faire tomber le gouvernement
si on a un budget où Trans
Mountain est encore en vie.
- On voit Yves Lévesque, son
discours de défaite à Trois-
Rivières.
Gérard Deltell, il a gagné haut
la main dans Louis Saint
Laurent. On va lui parler tout
de suite en direct. Monsieur
deltel, félicitations pour votre
victoire.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Ce n'est pas l'heure des
grandes analyses pour vous, je
comprends, vous êtes dans le feu
de l'action. Néanmoins, il y a
quelque chose qui n'a pas
marché. Commençons au Québec, il
y a quelque chose qui n'a pas
marché au Québec pour les
conservateurs.
- Oui, c'est sûr. Comme vous
l'avez dit, il est encore trop
tôt pour faire des analyses. Il
reste encore quelque minutes de
jeu dans la période.
La réalité, c'est que c'est vrai
qu'au Québec, on avait des
grandes attentes au Québec.
Notre exceptionnel lieutenant
avait rassemblé une équipe de
rêves.
La population s'est prononcée.
Oui, il y a des choses qui n'ont
pas été comment le souhaiter. On
aurait aimé gagner,
mais il est trop tôt pour porter
analyse là-dessus. Il faut
mettre cela dans un ensemble et
regarder globalement.
- Est-ce que vous craignez la
suite des choses? On le souligne
depuis plusieurs minutes, le
fait que le Canada est vraiment
déchiré, désuni, d'un côté, on
vote en masse pour les
conservateurs, en Ontario, les
libéraux se sont maintenus, au
Québec, les libéraux et le
blocs, gouvernement minoritaire.
Ou est-ce qu'on ça va?
- On n'est pas mort au Québec.
On a fait élire une dizaine de
personnes et je vois que dans la
Saint-Jean, mon ami Richard est
en train de gruger. Il est trop
tôt pour faire des analyses.
Lorsqu'un gouvernement, les
Canadiens envoient à Ottawa
gouvernement minoritaire, ça
veut dire que les Canadiens sont
divisés. Ça veut dire aussi que
les Canadiens nous disent :
les policiers, travailler
ensemble. C'est ça qu'on doit
prendre comme réflexion. La
personne qui a été capable de
fédérer le soutien majoritaire
des Canadiens. Ça veut donc dire
que ils y en a qui ont des
pensées conservatrices et
d'autre qui ont ne pas lancé de
gauches campés par le NPD. Il
faut prendre acte de cela. Un
gouvernement minoritaire, ce
n'est pas la fin du monde. Ils y
en a qui ont duré seulement neuf
mois, comme celui de Monsieur
Clarke en 79.
Ça arrive d'gouvernement qui ne
dure pas longtemps. Mais ça
arrive aussi d'gouvernement qui
dure longtemps. Stephen Harper a
dirigé de gouvernement
minoritaire qui ont duré cinq
ans et demi. Il y a personne qui
est mort au Canada. C'est un
appel que nous lancer Canadiens,
c'est un avertissement.
Ils veulent nous dire de
travailler ensemble pour que ça
avance.
Soyez assuré convaincant pays
notre rôle fermement et
fermement opposition à la
chambre des communes.
- Très bien. J'ai apprécié.
Bonne fin de soirée à vous. Vous
avez gagné, c'est clair. Salut.
Au revoir. Vous voyez des images
en direct de l'autobus du chef
du Bloc québécois qui vient
d'arriver devant le théâtre
national où il y a un
rassemblement du Bloc québécois.
Monsieur Blanchet va faire son
entrée dans la salle
et on va avoir son discours
qu'on va vous donner en direct.
Monsieur Blanchet qui doit se
dire avec 32 : mission
accomplieú.
- Tout à fait. Il faut
comprendre que Monsieur
Blanchet, il est devenu chef du
bloc il y a seulement neuf mois.
C'est quand même... c'est le
temps d'un accouchement grosso
modo!
- On parlait de renaissance pour
le bloc. On est dans le même
thème.
- Vous me voyez venir. On l'a
dit plusieurs fois pendant la
campagne, il a eu l'instinct
stratégique de s'accrocher plus
après l'attaque de François
Legault que le Parti québécois
qui est plus faible. N'empêche
que c'est lui qui a mené cette
campagne aussi, c'est lui qui
l'a mené sans faille. Bien sûr,
François Legault, cette semaine,
je l'ai baptisé, c'est le
panoramix du Bloc. Mais c'est
quand même Yves-François
Blanchet et ses troupes qui ont
mené le combat et de passer de
10 à 32, tripler sa députation,
non seulement, il transcende le
12 pour avoir des ressources,
mais n'aura plus à répondre à la
sempiternelle question de la
pertinence du Bloc québécois à
Ottawa.
- Il ne faut pas oublier,
c'est encore plus moribonde que
de ne pas avoir le statut de
parti reconnu. Il faudra voir
quel est le Bloc québécois qui
va être là. Je ne dis pas ça
parce que Gilles Duceppe est là.
Est-ce que c'est le Bloc
québécois de Duceppe où les
députés étaient assidus, il
faisait parti du processus
législatif, ils étaient des
députés qui allaient dans tous
les comités, qui scrutait les
projets de loi ou dans les huit
dernières années, soyons clairs,
le Bloc québécois, il a surtout
été imparti qui essayait de
pousser le Parti québécois plus
radical. Martine Ouellet est le
meilleur exemple de cela.
C'est à Monsieur Blanchet de
faire en sorte que les gens qui
étaient très fiés du travail du
Bloc dans le temps s'y
retrouvent encore une fois et
que ce ne sera pas un endroit
pour se chicaner avec le Parti
québécois.
- C'est Monsieur Blanchet le
grand gagnant de la soirée parce
que c'est lui qui a augmenté ses
sièges, sans pourcentage de
vote. Le NPD abaissé à 15 %,
il a perdu dessèche. Mais ils
vont avoir plus de poids parce
que les libéraux ne vont pas
vouloir, Monsieur Trudeau, dans
ces derniers jours, il a dit que
la souveraineté, c'est cela, le
bloc. Monsieur Trudeau ne veut
pas avoir l'air qu'il danse avec
le bloc dans le reste du Canada.
C'était Jagmeet Singh qui va
avoir plus de pouvoir lors de
budget que Monsieur Blanchet.
- Intéressant.
- C'est vrai qui François
Blanchet a fait une très bonne
campagne. Il s'est fixé des
objectifs. Bravo, victoire. En
même temps, je regardais tout à
l'heure, j'ai eu l'impression
qu'ils sont un peu déçus. Ils
auraient voulu plus.
Il se croyait capable de dire
que nous sommes la voie du
Québec. Ils ne peuvent pas le
dire. Partir du moment où le
parti libéral du Canada a quand
même... ce n'est pas vrais qui
sont la voie du Québec. Ils vont
devoir tempérer le discours.
- L'histoire s'accélère.
- Je vais vous dire que j'avais
prévu 35 et le blocs me disais
avant que j'arrive ici, les gens
du Bloc me disaient 31.
Il s'attendait à cela.
Mais je parle des gens qui
étaient là, je ne parle pas des
commentateurs. J'y parle de
cela. Pour l'avoir vécu pendant
sept ans avec un gouvernement
minoritaire, je vous dirais que
Monsieur Trudeau va devoir
composer avec les uns et les
autres.
- Avec Harper, on a passé de
budget dans un gouvernement
minoritaire de 2006 et 2008 et
on ne l'a pas fait qu'avec des
fédéraliste. Arrêtons focussés
sur le NPD comme étant des
alliés naturels. Il a un menu
d'options selon le sujet où il
va pouvoir puiser de l'appui.
- Ça ne fait pas parti de l'ADN
libéral.
- Mais tu veux rester au
pouvoir.
- La réalité fait loi.
Pablo Rodriguez qui est réélu
qui est avec nous. Bonsoir à
vous.
- Bonsoir.
- Félicitations pour votre
victoire. Qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des résultats. 157, vous
allez devoir danser avec le bloc
et le NPD.
- Tout d'abord, je souhaite
remercier les électeurs de ma
circonscription tout comme
l'ensemble des Canadiens qui
nous ont donné un mandat de
gouverner. Il est minoritaire
mais c'est un mandat de
gouverner. La meilleure
nouvelle, c'est au niveau des
changements climatiques. On va
poser des gestes concrets et
pour une société plus juste
aussi.
- Est-ce que ça veut dire mettre
de côté Trans Mountain?
- On verra. C'est ma cinquième
victoire électorale et c'est mon
quatrième Parlement minoritaire.
Un seul gouvernement
majoritaire, c'est le dernier.
C'est souvent négocié à la
pièce. C'est à nous de proposer
des politiques qui collent aux
réalités d'québécois et canadien
Edalli négocient avec des
membres des autres parties.
- Très bien.
Vos ministres ont tenu le coup
au Québec?
- Oui j'ai une pensée pour tous
les collègues et amis qui n'ont
pas gagné qui ont été la et qui
ont travaillé aussi fort qui ne
seront pas avec nous à Ottawa
et je les remercie du fond du
coeur.
- Comment vous traduisez la
montée du Bloc québécois.
Quels messages des Québécois ont
voulu envoyer d'après vous?
- Écoutait, on a 35e travail
avec ça. Ce qui est important
c'est de trouver des terrains
d'entente avec le bloc ou le NPD
et faire avancer le Québec et le
Canada dans un Canada plus
progressiste et plus vers.
- Pablo Rodriguez merci de nous
avoir parlé. Ensuite merci à
vous.
- Lyne Bessette éludant Brome
Missisquoi c'était l'une des
vedettes choisies par le Parti
libéral.
C'est un exemple pour les
libéraux justement, vous le
disiez, ils se sont pas du tout
effondré.
- C'est un gain.
- C'était un siège libéral.
- Oui.
- C'était M. Paradis.
- Jane Philpott n'ira pas au
Parlement comme indépendante et
la défaite. Elle est troisième.
Il y avait moins d'espoir pour
elle. Justement comme c'est
serré.
- C'est une course à trois
essais vraiment peut-être une
des mauvaises nouvelles de la
soirée si ça se confirme, cette
avance de Jody Wilson-Raybould
pour le Parti libéral. Les raids
ont aimé ne pas l'avoir dans la
banquette arrière dans la
chambre commune parce que
c'était l'une des histoires du
Parti libéral, une des
difficultés de l'année incarnée
par Mme Wilson-Raybould. Affaire
SNC-Lavalin.
- Pour les verres il y aura de
l'analyse affaire, Madeleine.
Il n'y a pas eu de poussée.
De deux à trois peut-être.
- On est à trois. On avait vu...
on avait vu à Fredericton un
gain, sinon sur l'île de
Vancouver c'est exactement les
mêmes sièges qu'on avait à la
dissolution.
Le siège de Colemannous Leek
s'était fait élire dans une
partielle et le siège de l'chef
Elizabeth May, c'est loin des
espoirs qu'ils auraient pu avoir
un début de campagne. Souvenez-
vous on se demandait entre le
NPD et les verres qui allaient
obtenir la 3e place?
- C'est un de plus
qu'actuellement.
- Il n'y a pas de quoi célébrer.
- Non il n'y a pas de quoi
célébrer. Des nouvelles de
Burnaby Sud.
Jagmeet Singh qui accroît son
avance quand même.
- Légèrement. 727 voix devant le
conservateur et l'libérale qui
n'est pas loin derrière donc une
course à 3 m Jagmeet Singh à une
certaine avance.
- Dans Sherbrooke, Pierre-Luc
Dusseault est redevenu deuxième.
Mais c'est très, très près pour
Élisabeth Brière qui voudrait
faire un gain pour les libéraux.
Voilà l'arrivée du chef du Bloc
québécois, M. Blanchet, qui aux
dires de tous les analystes a
fait de bons débats. C'est
important, c'est vu par beaucoup
de monde. Fait une bonne
campagne sans faute.
Il avait le vent dans le dos
de ce courant nationaliste de M.
Legault. Donc il s'est accroché,
oui à la locomotive, mais il
fallait qu'il fasse le travail
quand même, c'était pas évident.
Il a pas beaucoup parlé de
souveraineté. L'indice n'est pas
maintenant que ça se règle.
J'invite tout le monde à voter
pour le bloc.
(applaudissements et
acclamations)
C'est quelque chose que vous
avez connu ça.
(acclamations
Oui, il était poussé dans le
dos.
- Il y a toujours des raisons de
gagner des raisons de pertes. Il
faut jouer la carte
correctement.
- Il a bien joué ses cartes.
- Mais aussi pour les
souverainistes à la dernière
campagne au Québec qui ont été
difficile donc cette victoire
pour le bloc en soi, je pense
que pour les souverainistes
quelque chose.
- C'est un baume.
- Tout à fait.
- On va continuer à suivre ce
qui se passe là-bas.
M. Blanchet il a 54 ans.
C'est son premier mandat
évidemment sur la scène
fédérale. Il a été ministre sous
le gouvernement Marois,
ministre de l'Environnement
entre autres...
- Mes amis...
(applaudissements)
Je nous trouve très fringant.
Je nous trouve très vivant!
(applaudissements)
Et ma foi je vous regarde, je
vous regarde et trouve très
jeune.
Nous revenons de loin mais nous
irons encore plus loin.
Permettez-moi d'adresser d'abord
quelques remerciements.
Dans quelques heures il y aura
21 ans que mon père nous a
quittés.
J'ai une pensée pour son doigt
vindicatif et son admiration
pour René-Lévesque.
(applaudissements)
Permettez-moi de remercier Nancy
et les enfants pour leur
patience et beaucoup mieux,
pour leurs encouragements
et le regard qui brille au
meilleur moment.
(applaudissements)
Je veux remercier les militantes
et les militants de Beloeil
Chambly, les électeurs de
Beloeil Chambly, vous m'avez
accueilli avec une chaleur, ma
foi, bien au-delà de mes
espérances.
(rires)
Je veux...
- (scandant): C'est nous!
- Je veux saluer toutes les
militantes et militants du Bloc
québécois. Je veux aussi
remercier mon conseiller et ami
et inspiration, M. Gilles
Duceppe.
(applaudissements)
M. Gilles Duceppe vient
d'ailleurs de confier au Bloc
québécois son fils largement
éludant lac Saint-Jean.
(applaudissements)
- Duceppe! Duceppe!
- Pour la trace indélébile qu'il
aurait laissée dans l'histoire
du Québec, je veux aussi
remercier Lucien Bouchard.
(applaudissements)
- J'ai une pensée toute amicale,
mais surtout reconnaissante pour
une équipe. Une petite équipe,
mais une équipe qui a réalisé
une campagne possible.
En ressources, entend, en
argent, nous avons fait plus que
beaucoup avec moins que tous.
(applaudissements)
Et ma foi, à bien des égards, ce
fut une campagne victorieuse.
Je gardais pour la fin mes amis
candidates et candidats,
quel courage. Je sais
aujourd'hui avec le recul, de
loin on peut se dire que c'est
un choix qui aurait pu avoir
l'air un peu facile, mais
réalisé, il y a quatre mois, il
y a six mois qu'attendaient
encore des fous. Il y a des fous
qui ont dit oui et qui s'en
viennent à la chambre commune.
(applaudissements)
(foule en délire)
Merci!
Merci beaucoup, merci!
Ces gens la vie professionnelle
de côté et ils ont gagné une
obligation solennelle à
l'endroit des Québécois, mais
plusieurs dont certains que j'ai
vu ce soir n'ont pas été choisi.
Vous en tirez une reconnaissance
vibrante de beaucoup de
Québécois et vous avez, non
seulement ma reconnaissance,
mais vous avez mon amitié
durable.
(applaudissements)
Les Québécois et les Canadiens
se donnent ce soir un parlement
minoritaire.
Aucun parti parmi ceux qui
aspiraient a obtenu une majorité
de chaises. Aucuns ce soir ne
prend le contrôle de la chambre
commune. Au Québec, le Bloc
québécois ne veut pas former un
gouvernement, ni même participer
un gouvernement.
En revanche, le Bloc québécois
peut au mérite collaboré avec
n'importe quel gouvernement.
Si ce qui est proposé est bon
pour le Québec, vous pourrez
compter sur nous.
(applaudissements)
Si ce qui est mis de l'avant est
nuisible pour le Québec, le Bloc
se dressera sur le chemin.
(applaudissements)
Si le gouvernement et par la
table, il est dans le
tempérament même des Québécois
d'être parlable, alors le Bloc
québécois sera parlable sauf
s'il s'agit de passer davantage
de pétrole à travers le Québec.
(applaudissements)
Sauf s'il s'agit de renoncer
ou compromettre des valeurs,
notre langue, ou l'engagement du
Québec envers la laïcité des
institutions publiques.
Je ne crois pas que les
québécois et les Canadiens aient
élu un gouvernement minoritaire
dans le but de retourner aux
urnes rapidement. Je crois que
les Canadien et les québécois ne
demande tous parties ou toutes
régions confondues, malgré les
divisions profondes qui marquent
la carte politique du Canada
aujourd'hui. Il nous demande de
travailler ensemble.
Il nous demande de faire marcher
un É bien imparfait, le pays qui
fait peu de cas depuis 37 ans de
laisser de côté près du corps de
sa population dans une
constitution à laquelle ils
n'ont jamais adhéré.
(applaudissements)
Mais c'est un parlement que nous
devrons faire fonctionner.
Le Bloc québécois prend toute la
mesure du mandat qui lui est
confié dans ce contexte.
Nous avons proposé d'être la
voix d'une nation québécoise qui
est retrouvée... qui s'est
retrouvé dans son seul parlement
national, l'Assemblée nationale
du Québec.
(applaudissements)
Nous sommes la voie des
consensus, de l'Assemblée
nationale du Québec.
Nous nous sommes solennellement
engagés à porter ce mandat,
l'entièreté de ce mandat
en toute conscience est sans
équivoque.
Nous saisissons toute la portée
du mandat, mais aussi ses
limites.
Les membres, les militants et
les électeurs du Bloc québécois,
tous savent que nous croyons
qu'un jour, le plus vite
possible, mais à ce moment et à
sa manière, le Québec pourrait
choisir de se doter de tous les
attributs de la souveraineté.
(applaudissements)
Mais j'ai...
- (scandant): On veut un pays!
- Merci!
Moi aussi!
Mais j'ai une admiration sans
bornes, un respect, une
reconnaissance responsable
envers nos militants, nos gens
d'une nature parfois plus
patiente, mais pour tous ces
gens, mes amis, tous ces gens
qui acceptent que le Québec
avait besoin, que pour cette
fois, que pour cette fois,
la réalisation de la
souveraineté ne soit pas notre
mandat.
En effet, le Bloc québécois est
un parti souverainiste et le
désir d'un pays anime chaque
battement de mon coeur depuis qe
mon père le chantait à sa propre
façon. Le Bloc québécois comme
parti, le Bloc québécois va
réapprendre réécouter et à
réentendre les québécois dans
cette perspective. S'il est une
chose que cette campagne nous a
appris c'est que si nous portons
la voix de Québécois à leur
façon, à leur vitesse, si nous
respectons leur valeur, ils
peuvent nous accorder une
extraordinaire confiance.
(applaudissements)
Nous devons conserver et chérir
cette humilité qui nous a ramené
nous sommes ce soir.
L'aile parlementaire du Bloc
québécois prendra dans les
prochains jours le chemin
d'Ottawa.
Notre travail n'est pas d'y
faire fonctionner le fédéralisme
canadien.
(applaudissements)
Notre mandat, notre mandat tel
que dictée par les électeurs
n'est pas non plus de l'en
empêcher. La différence profonde
entre la nation canadienne
et la nation québécoise est-elle
qu'elle n'a pas besoin d'être
exacerbée.
Soyons toutefois de bons amis
les parlementaires, peut-être en
arriverons-nous un jour au
constat que telle est la voie de
l'avenir, partenaires mais égaux
et libres.
(applaudissements)
Notre mandat est toutefois dans
l'intervalle de tirer le
meilleur parti pour les
québécois et les québécois du
temps qui nous est offert.
En attendant que ces québécois
si tel est leur désir à leur
heure et la manière choisisse
l'autre chemin. C'est au prix de
cette patiente, au prix de cette
humilité seulement à ce prix que
nous pouvons ce soir dire :
Le Québec, c'est nous!
(applaudissements)
J'ai aussi ce soir le grand et
sincère plaisir de m'adresser
mes collègues chef de parti.
J'ai cherché avec obstination
au détriment de tempérament tout
québécois à mener une campagne
positive, une campagne propre,
une campagne d'idées, une
campagne de coeur.
(applaudissements)
Le Québec vient de nous en
récompenser.
J'espère, sans pour autant faire
la leçon à quiconque, j'espère
que nous serons tous au
Parlement saisir le message qui
vient avec ce choix.
Dans l'intervalle, j'adresse mes
sincères pulsations M. Justin
Trudeau, à M. Jagmeet Singh, Mme
Elizabeth May, à M. Andrew
Scheer et à M. Maxime Bernier.
(applaudissements)
Je me rendre disponible pour
mettre en place, pour jeter les
bases d'une culture
parlementaire qui adoptera une
autre valeur chère aux Québécois
: le respect.
(applaudissements)
Le respect, oui, mais aussi le
respect entre nous les
parlementaire, le respect et
l'humilité de nous mettre au
service des gens.
(applaudissements)
Dans cet esprit, sans compromis
sur qui nous sommes, dans le
respect de notre mandat et de
ses limites, notre désir de
collaboration est assuré.
Jonathan autant des autres
parties. En revanche, n'attendez
pas de compromis sur l'esprit,
claire et sans équivoque, des
positions, des demandes de la
volonté de la langue et des
valeurs de québécois.
(applaudissements)
Dans cet esprit aussi, je crois
approprier d'adresser nos
salutations aux élus de
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec
et à sa convenance de rencontre
bientôt le premier ministre du
Québec M. François Legault.
(applaudissements)
Mes amis, n'oublions jamais
cette campagne qui prend des
allures de serment.
Le seul serment qui soit le
nôtre s'adresse à la nation
québécoise.
(applaudissements)
Que lui avons-nous dit à la
nation québécoise?
Nous lui avons dit, le français,
c'est nous. La laïcité, c'est
nous. Les régions, c'est nous.
La gestion de l'offre, c'est
nous. Les aînés, c'est nous.
La sortie du pétrole, c'est
nous. L'énergie propre, c'est
nous. L'innovation, c'est nous.
Le Québec, c'est nous.
(applaudissements)
Avant de nous qui nous quelques
mots pour des gens qui nous sont
chers.
Je veux tendre la main avec
toute la sincérité de mon amour
Premières Nations et aux Inuits
du Québec.
(applaudissements)
Nous d'égal à égale donation à
nation une confiance mutuelle à
construire sur cette terre que
le destin nous invite à
partager. Je serais à vos
côtés..
(applaudissements)
Je vais aussi rappeler à nos
frères et nos soeurs que porter
notre belle langue française au
Canada. À nos soeurs et frère
franco-canadien et ontarien...
(applaudissements)
que le Bloc québécois est un
allié.
Je demande en toute amitié à la
précieuse communauté anglaise du
Québec, si riche de culture et
cyprès en amitié, de soutenir
notre voeu que les franco-
canadiens et les Acadiens
jouissent au Canada des mêmes
droits et privilèges dont les
Anglos québécois disposent au
Québec.
(applaudissements)
enfin, je demande au nouveau
premier ministre de façon
formelle et solennelle sur mon
honneur et le sien, de demander
la libération des prisonniers
politiques catalan.
(applaudissements)
Et d'exiger...
(slogans)
- Liberté, liberté!
- L'exiger, mes amis, la fin des
violences contre les civils
d'une nation parmi les plus
pacifiques du monde.
(applaudissements)
Si le droit à
l'autodétermination et juste
pour le Canada, il lève pour la
Catalogne.
(applaudissements)
mes amis, futurs collègues à la
chambre des communes, les
lecteurs et lectrices du Québec,
ce soir ce que je vous offre
c'est l'engagement absolu,
durable, sincère et fier, d'être
à la hauteur de notre confiance.
(applaudissements)
quelles que TT votre choix
aujourd'hui, vous êtes le
Québec. Le Québec c'est vous!
Merci beaucoup!
(applaudissements)
- Blanchet, Blanchet!
- Alors voilà, Yves-François
Blanchet qui dans un assez long
discours a dit en deux mots : le
bloc est parlable. Les Québécois
et les Canadiens ne veulent pas
retourner...
- et il salue les élus qu'il va
faire monter sur la scène.
J'invite les élus et les
candidats à me rejoindre ici!
(applaudissements)
- M. Duceppe, il a tenu à vous
rendre Avec Lucien Bouchard
également. Il a bien dit aussi :
notre mandat cette fois-ci c'est
d'aller défendre les intérêts du
Québec. Mais ce n'était pas un
mandat pour la souveraineté. Il
a été clair avec ça. Parce qu'on
n'en a pas parlé de la campagne.
- On n'a pas plus parlé du
fédéralisme dans la campagne. Ce
n'était pas le débat. Pour moi
c'est tout à fait normal. La
souveraineté, ce n'est pas sans
saveur. Explique dans toutes les
dimensions de la vie collective.
Tu vas des propositions qui sont
différentes.
- Sur l'idée qu'il est parlable,
que le bloc ne veut pas
replonger le pays en élections,
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs.
- J'ai fait 7 ans comme ça.
Je l'ai fait avec des libéraux.
Avec Stephen Harper, on ne
pensait pas la même chose mais
on était capable de se
rencontrer. Il faut avoir un
cadre budgétaire pour être
capable de négocier avec un
gouvernement minoritaire.
Sa être rigoureux je pense. On
peut être d'accord ou pas avec
le blog, mais ces députés ont
toujours été reconnus comme des
gens rigoureux qui travaillaient
bien. Même les autres
parlementaires à Ottawa nous
élisaient dans plusieurs
domaines.
- C'est le message qu'il voulait
envoyer, on est parlable.
- Si je suis Canadiens anglais
et que j'ai écouté ça avec une
traduction, je suis agréablement
surpris. J'ai l'impression que
c'est quelqu'un avec qui peut-
être pourrait s'entendre sur
certains sujets. Il n'est pas le
bonhomme sept heures que
certains avaient dépeint. Un
discours n'était pas une
carrière, mais j'ai trouvé qu'il
avait le bon temps. Il parle
comme quelqu'un qui va vouloir
collaborer.
- Même après le débat en anglais
au Canada anglais, les gens ont
apprécié la présence. Le défi
pour lui sera un défi de
positionnement pour le Bloc
québécois au Parlement étend
donné que tu as quand même le
NPD et les Verts, et peut-être
Mme Wilson-Raybould aussi comme
balance du pouvoir. Ça va être
intéressant de voir sur quel
enjeu il va vouloir se
positionner rapidement.
- Il y a aussi une période
d'adaptation. Quiconque est
arrivé la première fois au
parlement, tu ne deviens pas un
grand parlementaire comme Gilles
Duceppe après X nombre d'années.
Il aura un apprentissage à
faire.
- Et ils vont devoir aussi,
parce que les députés du bloc
actuellement, les 10 qui étaient
là n'ont jamais été membres de
parti reconnu. Ils n'ont jamais
été dans un comité
parlementaire. Ils n'ont jamais
eu à travailler dans un comité.
C'est tout un apprentissage à
refaire. Il y a peut-être quatre
ou cinq députés qui ont soient
siégés à l'Assemblée nationale
ou aux communes et qui ont cette
expérience. Ce n'est pas simple,
souder un tel groupe.
- Une petite seconde. Je vais
faire le tour de table.
Et la suite des choses.
- Dans un premier temps celui
qui va être très heureux de ce
discours, c'est François
Legault. Parce que ça confirme
en effet que le Bloc québécois
va se concentrer vraiment sur la
défense des intérêts du Québec,
traduction des consensus de
l'Assemblée nationale.
- Pendant qu'on voit Elizabeth
May qui fait son entrée et qui
va être la prochaine à livrer
son discours d'ici quelques
minutes.
Vous pouvez terminer.
- Et non pas de la souveraineté.
Monsieur Blanchet a parlé des
catalan, c'est plus pour ses
troupes.
Pour François Legault, je trouve
que c'est une victoire politique
assez majeure. Il va avoir son
tank en pleine chambre.
- À part la Catalogne dont le
reste de du pays ne se soucie
pas, il paraîtrait raisonné,
faisant un appel aussi au Franck
ontarien, aux Anglos québécois.
Pour un anglophone qui coûterait
cela, c'est quelque chose de
très franc et honnête. Sauf que
les demandes du bloc et comme la
déclaration de revenus uniques,
on a déjà dit qu'on ne voulait
pas de ça.
Je pense que le Bloc québécois
aurait été beaucoup plus content
si c'était un gouvernement
minoritaire conservateur. C'est
leur seule déception de la
soirée.
- Il y a des éléments du
programme qu'il n'y a pas chez
les libéraux évidemment.
- Je pense que les québécois ont
obtenu exactement ce qu'il
voulait ce soir. Un contingent
assez important de bloquistes
dans un gouvernement minoritaire
libéral. Yves-François Blanchet
avait raison de dire qu'il
n'allait pas tenter de défaire
ce gouvernement. Un parti ne met
jamais en vitrine tous ces
députés. Ça prend cinq ou une
dizaines d'députés qui vont être
capables d'aller devant les
caméras. Il en a ce soir.
Stéphane Bergeron, Claude
DeBellefeuille, Yves-François
Blanchet. Il n'avait pas besoin
que les 32 soient
particulièrement avec un
excellent. Il avait besoin
d'avoir quelques lieutenants
avec lui comme Gilles Duceppe en
avait avec lui. Les autres vont
apprendre. Ils vont apprendre
sur leur temps et ils vont faire
leur devoir. Et on verra qui va
se révéler. On a pas mal ce que
beaucoup de québécois souhaité
ce soir d'après les sondages.
- Moi je pense que ça prend un
bon encadrement. En 93 on avait
plein de nouveaux qui n'avaient
pas beaucoup d'expérience.
Un an et demi après, les
journaux anglophones disaient :
peut-être voilà la meilleure
position officielle depuis
longtemps.
- Le Bloc québécois était
l'opposition officielle à
l'époque. C'était un coup de
tonnerre.
- Mais on était pas parti
reconnu en 93. Il a fallu
encadrer ces gens-là et leur
montrer à travailler et être
très rigoureux. Je pense que
Yves-François Blanchet va faire
la même chose.
- Monsieur Bouchard qui était
très fier, et vous après vous
haver gardé la même habitude :
- Je pense qu'il faut être
rigoureux dans la vie. On est là
pour travailler et respecter
l'adversaire. On peut penser
différemment mais on est capable
de se respecter.
- Très bien.
On verra à quel moment
exactement. Il a dit : on parle
d'ici quelques jours à Ottawa et
ce sera une nouvelle à
devanture.
Aventure.
- On a beaucoup parlé de ce qui
s'est passé au Québec avec cette
montée du Bloc québécois mais
dans l'Ouest, les libéraux ont
essuyé des pertes. Et quand même
pas mal de pertes. Si on se
dirige dans la couronne de
Vancouver, c'est la carte
aujourd'hui. En 2015, il y avait
davantage de rouge. À Colombie-
Britannique ils ont essuyé 7
pertes. Ils avaient connu un de
leurs meilleurs résultats en
2015 en Colombie-Britannique.
Si on continue notre tournée de
l'ouest du pays, en Alberta ils
ont été carrément rayés de la
carte les libéraux. Ils n'ont
plus un siège. Le seul siège
d'une autre couleur de la mer
bleue que l'on voit, c'est un
siège néo démocrate dans
d'Edmonton. C'est le même siège
que les néo démocrate bétonné,
mais une nouvelle députée qui
fait son entrée à la chambre des
communes.
Si on se dirige en
Saskatchewan. Là aussi, c'est
bleu foncé. Il n'y a plus un
libéral là. C'est une seule
perte pour le Parti libéral mais
c'est une perte qui fait mal
parce que c'est Ralph Goodale
qui perd son pari d'avoir obtenu
un deuxième mandat ce soir.
Donc c'est complètement bleu.
Les libéraux ont été rayés de la
carte.
Si on se dirige au Manitoba. Là
aussi les libéraux ont issus des
pertes. Ils avaient davantage de
sièges, entre autres dans
Winnipeg. Ils avaient un siège
supplémentaire. Là aussi il y a
un GÉNIeau démocrate.
Je m'y arrête parce que c'est la
conjointe de Roméo Saganash qui
fait son entrée.
C'est un succès pour elle. En
Ontario, si le gouvernement est
libéral ce soir, c'est parce que
l'Ontario a tenu le coup. Ils
ont réussi à maintenir leurs
acquis en Ontario. Ils ont
essuyé de pertes seulement dans
un total de 121 sièges au total
en Ontario. Si on se rend dans
la couronne de Toronto, en
voulant montrer tout à l'heure à
quel point il a beaucoup changé
de couleur. C'est encore très
rouge dans cette région qui est
riche de siège. Les libéraux ont
maintenu leurs acquis. Ils n'ont
perdu que deux sièges en
Ontario.
- Jody Wilson-Raybould a
finalement remporté Vancouver
Granville. Elle sera de nouveau
parlement.
Elle sera un caillou dans le
soulier de M. Trudeau parce
qu'elle ne lâchera pas.
- Un mot sur l'Ontario. C'est
quand même remarquable. Il y a
deux fois plus de députés
ontariens qu'il y aura de
députés québécois dans le caucus
du Parti libéral. Plus de la
moitié des députés du caucus
ministériel vont venir de
l'Ontario.
C'est un déséquilibre auquel
Monsieur Trudeau va devoir faire
très attention parce qu'à un
moment donné...
et on sait combien ses partisans
en Ontario, combien la campagne
a été sur le dos de M. Ford.
De ne pas essayer de devenir un
chef de position à Queens
parquet. Il y a bien des députés
libéraux qui auront cette
tentation.
Ça risque d'être un problème de
déséquilibre dans le caucus
libéral auquel il faudra que
Monsieur Trudeau passe très
attention surtout qu'il a décidé
: du côté du Québec, je n'ai pas
besoin d'un lieutenant
québécois. Il devra faire très
attention.
- C'est plus aussi je dirais une
réalité à Toronto.
L'Ontario ce n'est pas juste
Toronto. Il y a d'autres
ontariens qui grondent beaucoup
que Toronto a trop de pouvoir.
Maintenant au sein du caucus
libéral, Toronto et la couronne
ont beaucoup de pouvoir.
- Tu as beaucoup parlé de
l'Ontario. Ford a quand même été
absent. Je me demandais qui
gérais l'Ontario. Mais malgré
ça, la grogne était très forte
en Ontario. Malgré le fait qu'il
ait réussi à le cacher...
- pendant tout ce temps, il y a
eu la menace de grève scolaire
en Ontario. Il y a eu plein de
choses, même si la législature
ne siégeait pas. Grandement
aussi sur le programme pour les
enfants autistes. Il y avait
beaucoup de problèmes
qu'percuté. Monsieur Ford était
absent. Il ne pouvait pas se
défendre. C'était peut-être la
mauvaise décision.
- Envoie un gazouillis de
félicitations, non pas de Barack
Obama, mais de Donald Trump qui
félicite Justin Trudeau.
"Le Canada est bien servi."
- Ça doit être Rudy Giuliani
qu'il a écrit. D'abord, il n'y a
pas de faute. Ça ne doit pas
être lui qui l'a écrit.
- Barack Obama a dû lui écrire
en privé.
- Je pense que ça l'a aidé,
c'est gazouillis. Je pense que
oui.
- Tu veux croire ça.
Il est minuit 36, on va te
laisser croire ça.
- J'ai entendu ça de la part
d'universitaires, que le
gazouillis de Barack Obama les
avait fait voter pour Justin
Trudeau.
- On disait que les élections se
gagneraient en Ontario et que la
majorité des Hydro-Québec.
C'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé.
La couleur se décède en Ontario
et la majorité ou la minorité se
décide Québec.
- Et les libéraux ce soir vont
se mordre les doigts d'avoir
ignoré le Bloc québécois en
début de campagne. C'était une
façon de ne pas leur accorder
d'importance. Ils auraient peut-
être dû penser autrement parce
qu'effectivement cette majorité
libérale a été bloquée, si je
peux me prêter l'expression, par
le Bloc québécois au Québec.
- On a un tableau intéressant si
vous demandez combien de femmes
ont été élues ce soir pour
chacun des parties.
52 femmes sur 156 pour les
libéraux.
- Précisément le cas pour ce qui
est du Parti libéral. Chez les
conservateurs on est à 17 %
environ en ayant 21 femmes sur
121 députés.
Pour ce qui est du Bloc
québécois on approche de la zone
paritaire avec 38 % avec 12
femmes.
Le NPD c'est précisément la zone
paritaire avec 40 %.
Et les Verts, ils ont la
majorité.
- Jean Charest disait quand ils
étaient deux que la moitié de
son caucus était féminin.
- Un conseil des ministres
Barilà, j'imagine qu'il ne
reviendra pas là-dessus.
- Ce serait une erreur. C'était
une marque de commerce libéral.
Il avait fait grand bruit avec
cela. Il peut faire des reculs,
mais peut-être pas là-dessus.
- Dans Berthier-Maskinongé, Ruth
Ellen Brosseau qui est toujours
deuxième. Yves Perron n'arrive
pas à se dégager assez pour être
déclaré élu.
Ça commence à y ressembler.
- Mesdames et Messieurs, la
carte routière à partir de
maintenant. Et on ne se rend pas
au petit déjeuner, mais presque.
Elizabeth May va parler. Jagmeet
Singh va parler. Andrew Scheer
va parler. Et Monsieur Trudeau
va parler. Alors ça nous donne
quelques minutes encore à passer
ensemble.
Daniel Thibault, vous avez un
invité.
- Je suis accompagné de Luc
Thériault, député de Montcalm
qui a été réélu. Félicitations!
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit comprendre
du discours de votre chef ce
soir?
- Moi je pense que ça a été très
clair qu'on va honorer le mandat
que les Québécoises et Québécois
nous ont donné.
On va négocier à la pièce et on
Il est clair et précis que ce
n'est pas mandat pour faire
fonctionner du fédéralisme mais
pour faire avancer les
revendications du gouvernement
du Québec.
- Est-ce que ça fonctionne ou ça
bloque d'après vous?
- Il est clair que Monsieur
Trudeau est au gouvernement, il
est minoritaire. Il est clair
que par rapport au projet de loi
21, on lui a fait dire avec très
peu de questions en chambre à la
fin de la session à savoir ce
qu'il allait contester ou pas,
il était très clair qu'il
s'enligne pour contester la loi
21. Pour nous, ça ne passe pas.
- Est-ce que c'est ce qu'il a
joué beaucoup dans cette
campagne?
- Je pense qu'on a un chef
extraordinaire qui a été à la
hauteur des aspirations des
Québécois et des Québécoises et
en 2015, j'étais déchiré.
J'étais élu pour un premier
mandat mais je n'avais pas de
chez. Je salue M. Duceppe parce
qu'il nous a permis dans cette
campagne merveilleuse en 2015 de
pouvoir continuer à faire du
travail pendant quatre ans. Là,
on a un chef à Ottawa et savoir
faire toute la différence. C'est
un chef extraordinaire.
- Félicitations. Voilà Patrice.
- Merci Daniel.
Voilà, je vous indique qu'on a
une meilleure idée de quand le
chef du NPD va s'adresser à ses
partisans. Ça devrait être dans
quelques minutes. Il va peut-
être passer devant Elizabeth
May. Mais chaque chef, des fois,
un chef peut décider d'y aller
de l'avant.
Voilà, vous êtes informé.
Madeleine, on a des luttes à
finir par exemple à Sherbrooke.
Ce n'est pas terminé. Élisabeth
Brière a 200 voix davantage sur
Pierre-Luc Dusseault.
- Toutes les voies vont compter.
Dans Gaspésie-Les Îles-de-la-
Madeleine, ces 92 voix pour
Diane Bouthiller en ce moment.
Donc voyez-vous à quel point
c'est une lutte qui a été serrée
du début à la fin de la soirée
et ce n'est pas terminé. Guy
Bernette, du Bloc québécois, il
est deuxième. Il y a 207 bureaux
de scrutins qui ont été
délibérés.
- C'est très drôle. On a
commencé la soirée avec cela. On
va peut-être la finir...
- Il faut regarder chacun des
comptés. Il y a une communauté
anglophone qui est là-bas.
C'est ça qui se joue.
- C'est aussi serré chez les
francophones.
- On s'entend.
- Déformé par mes propos.
C'est à peu près unanime à l'île
d'entrée, ça va de soi.
C'est bien ce que c'est serré
chez les francophones.
- C'est un grand comté.
Voyez-vous, ce ce n'est peut-
être pas tant anglophone et
francophone les différentes
communautés.
- Jean-Yves Duclos, il est à 400
quelques d'avance sur Christiane
Gagnon qui voulait faire un
retour.
- Ce n'est pas terminé.
- Ce n'est pas terminé mais
quand même,
ça achève. On voit qu'il y a des
ministres qui ont eu chaud ce
soit. C'en est un exemple.
Madame le Bouthiller, n'est
probablement pas couché.
- Il y a personne de coucher. On
le souhaite.
Mesdames et Messieurs, vous
restez avec nous jusqu'à la fin.
- Ici, une avance de 963.
- C'est beaucoup. C'est comme
ça.
Berthier-Maskinongé, Yves Perron
qui est élu officiellement.
C'est un gain du Bloc québécois.
Ruth Ellen Brosseau caserner sa
carrière de députée.
- C'est triste.
- Vous aviez parlé d'elle au
début entre autres. Ça a été
serré mais voilà.
- Jusqu'à la dernière minute. Je
pense quand même que c'est une
perte non seulement pour le NPD,
et pour les femmes.
Je pense qu'elle a été vraiment
exemplaire dans sa
détermination, son courage.
C'est une perte.
- Tous partis confondus.
- Ce n'est pas dit qu'elle
reviendra pas.
- Voilà, Jagmeet Singh qui fait
son entrée dans son
rassemblement.
Il y va d'une danse.
- Il fait ses sautillements.
- Il a la balance du pouvoir.
Même s'il a moins de députés qui
ne l'espéraient, c'est évident,
il a quand même un pouvoir
important.
- Et bien mieux que ce qu'on
passe au début de la campagne.
On disait que ça n'allait pas
être un parti reconnu.
- Il faut se rappeler de ce
qu'on a dit quand même.
Il a pu se maintenir. Il a fait
aussi une bonne campagne,
sympathique, plus positive.
Beaucoup de gens disaient qu'on
l'aime justement, les deux chefs
des principaux partis étaient
trop négatifs. Il amenait un
côté courtois, un côté de rêve
avec un programme peut-être
irréaliste, c'est à chacun de
juger, mais au moins des
propositions positives pour
essayer d'améliorer la vie des
Canadiens qui en arrachent
aussi, de s'intéresser qui ont
moins les moyens, un programme
social agressive. Alors est-ce
que tout cela peut père collé et
peut arriver chez les libéraux
avec un gouvernement qui devra
négocier? C'est fort possible.
Christian Noël, vous étiez avec
lui une bonne partie de la
campagne. Qu'est-ce qu'on croit?
Est-ce qu'il peut vraiment se
dire que malgré tout, avec la
balance pouvoir, ça y est?
- C'est ce qu'il va essayer de
dire ce soir. Le vote
stratégique a fonctionné
et on se dit qu'avec moins de
députés, on aura quand même plus
de pouvoir à Ottawa avec la
balance du pouvoir.
L'd'attirer davantage les
projecteurs.
Jack Layton avait obtenu 19
députés. À la suite d'un
gouvernement minoritaire, il
avait réussi à attirer les
projecteurs vers lui.
Jagmeet Singh espère la même
chose. On l'écoute.
(applaudissements)
- Jagmeet!
- Merci beaucoup, mes amis,
merci.
L'amour est palpable.
Merci.
Merci infiniment pour votre
présence, votre implication,
c'est vraiment un honneur d'être
ici parmi vous. Merci pour tout
ce que vous avez fait. Merci.
(applaudissements)
Mes amis, j'aimerais reconnaître
le territoire traditionnel sur
lequel nous nous trouvons en ce
moment.
Le territoire non cédé...
qui sont toutes des Premières
Nations de ce territoire.
Mes amis, ça a été une soirée
incroyable, une campagne
formidable, tout un périple que
l'on a vécu ensemble et c'est un
tel honneur d'être ici de retour
à la maison en Colombie-
Britannique.
J'aimerais également prendre
moment afin de féliciter
Monsieur Trudeau et le Parti
libéral pour le résultat de ce
soit. Je le félicite.
Je me suis entretenu avec
Monsieur Trudeau, le premier
ministre, et je lui ai dit que
nous allions travailler fort
pour qu'on puisse polariser
notre attention sur les
priorités des Canadiens et
Canadiennes, les vôtres.
Nous allons nous assurer
que l'énergie qui s'est
accumulée en août, toute la
stimulation et de l'enthousiasme
et le fait que nous ayons mis
l'accent sur les luttes au
quotidien parce que nous voulons
jouer un rôle positif dans ce
nouveau Parlement que les
Canadiens ont choisi ce soir.
J'aimerais que vous sachiez que
cela va toujours demeurer au
coeur de nos préoccupations, de
retour à Ottawa, chaque jour à
la chambre des communes, les
néodémocrates vont travailler
d'arrache-pied pour s'assurer
que votre vie soit meilleure,
que la vie des Canadiens et des
Canadiennes puissent
s'améliorer.
J'aimerais également féliciter
les autres chefs de parti,
Monsieur Scheer, Madame May et
Monsieur Blanchet.
J'aimerais féliciter toute
personne qui s'est présentée aux
tous les partis que ce soit,
c'est une chose fort difficile à
faire et j'aimerais vous
remercier.
Pour vous dire, je suis vraiment
fié d'avoir pu être à la tête
d'une équipe si diversifiée
avec des femmes, des
représentants de la communauté
LGBTQ.
Ça a été vraiment une équipe
avec tant d'apathie, de
compassion et de souci des uns
des autres et c'est un honneur
pour moi d'avoir pu diriger
cette équipe. J'aimerais
remercier les dizaines de
milliers de bénévoles
qui ont soutenu notre campagne
et nous équipe un peu partout au
Canada.
Il y a vraiment trop de gens
à nommer. Vous vous l'imaginez.
Mais peut-être un petit nombre.
Avant tout, quelqu'un qui a été
à mes côtés tout au long de
cette aventure, mon épouse.
(applaudissements)
Elle a volé la vedette déjà,
j'aimerais qu'elle refasse.
J'aimerais également remercier
ma famille, mes frères, mes
parents, ma soeur, chacun
m'a aidé tout au long de ma vie,
mes amis, mon équipe à Ottawa,
ici en Colombie-Britannique, mon
équipe partout au Canada. Merci
du fond du coeur.
De nouveau, il y a vraiment trop
de gens à remercie mais si je
pouvais mentionner deux noms qui
pourraient représenter toute
l'équipe, ce sont deux
personnes, j'aimerais les
reconnaître, ils ne savent pas
que je m'apprête à le faire,
mais de personnes que j'avais
nommées, de femmes incroyables
qui ont fait parti de la
campagne et je suis fié de
quelles sont des femmes, c'est
vraiment puissant dans notre
parti.
Ma directrice de campagne,
Jennifer Howard.
Et ma directrice nationale,
Mélissa Bruno.
Deux des postes les plus
puissants dans notre parti,
c'était de jeunes femmes...
on va oublier l'âge, de femme
surpuissante!
Mélissa et Jennifer, elles vont
être fâchées après moi après ce
que je viens de dire. Je le
garantis. J'aimerais également
remercier les gens incroyables
de Burnaby centre de m'avoir
réélu. Merci.
Je me sens humble
que vous m'ayez accordé votre
confiance continue de travailler
très fort avec vous et pour
vous. Je vous remercie.
Je dois vous avouer que tout au
long de la campagne, j'ai
rencontré des gens qui m'ont
vraiment inspiré. Je suis
inspiré par uueell, leurs
histoires restant moi, je les ai
rencontrés un peu partout au
pays, des gens qui inspirent le
travail qui est celui des
néodémocrates, un jeune garçon
par exemple d'à peine 10 ans qui
vit avec une maladie chronique.
Il m'a dit qu'il ne se préoccupe
pas de sa maladie ni des
médicaments et des injections
pas plus que s'il ne restait pas
du tout diligent, il pourrait
mourir. Non, la seule chose qui
le préoccupait, c'est que ces
médicaments coûtés chers à ses
parents. Il ne voulait pas être
un fardeau pour ses proches. Je
me rappelle de ce jeune garçon.
Je me rappelle de lui
et quelqu'un d'aussi jeune qui
pensait être un fardeau pour ses
parents dans un pays aussi riche
que le nôtre, c'est une des
raisons parmi d'autres pour
lesquels on se bat.
J'aimerais également mentionner
une communauté qui représente
l'injustice historique qui
continue face aux peuples
autochtones. Je pense au
Premières Nations de Grassing
Narrows. C'est un exemple d'être
vraiment délaissé.
On a mené la campagne nationale
dans cette communauté pour qu'il
sache qu'ils content pour nous
et qui sont dans notre coeur.
Et que la réconciliation
parfois, c'est aussi simple que
le respect de base et la
dignité. Par exemple, pourquoi
ne pas commencer avec l'eau
potable? L'eau propre à être bu
au quotidien.
Pourquoi ne pas... comment se
fait qu'on amène de jeunes
autochtones devant les
tribunaux? Ça veut dire du
financement égal pour bien des
enfants pour l'éducation, pour
des demeures résidentielles de
qualité.
Mes amis, j'ai rencontré des
jeunes de tous les milliers qui
me disaient qu'ils étaient
passés à travers des moments
difficiles. Ils étaient cyniques
face aux politiciens. Ils
n'étaient pas convaincus. Mais
ils m'ont dit : tu nous
ressembles. Tu parles comme
nous, tu nous vois.
Aux gens du Québec, je veux dire
merci.
(applaudissements)
Évidemment,
les résultats ne sont pas ce que
nous voulions, mais l'accueil
que j'ai reçu au Québec m'a fait
chaud au coeur. Ce premier
rendez-vous, ce premier rendez-
vous électoral, et nous a permis
de mieux nous connaître.
J'ai eu la chance de vous
démontrer que nous partageons
les mêmes valeurs. Je suis
reconnaissant pour le soutien
que nous avons reçu ce soir,
mais ça n'a pas été assez. On va
continuer à se battre pour vous.
(applaudissements)
Oui, merci. Nous n'allons pas
laisser tomber le combat. Nous
continuerons à y être présents.
Je continuerai d'être présent au
Québec.
J'ai dit que nous allions unir
les progressistes du Québec et
du reste du Canada et ensemble,
nous pouvons le faire et nous
allons le faire.
(applaudissements)
Jacques a commencé le travail.
Nous devons le continuer parce
que les progressistes, c'est
nous.
(applaudissements)
Merci mes amis et à très
bientôt. On ne lâche pas.
- Mes amis tout au long de la
campagne j'ai entendu histoire
sur les Canadiens qui ont du mal
à joindre les deux bouts
et qui trouve la vie de plus en
plus difficile et assez Canal D
je pourrais dire ceci : les
néodémocrates se rendent à
Ottawa pour se battre, se battre
pour vous.
(applaudissements)
Mes amis, dans les jours à venir
je vais rencontrer mon nouveau
caucus. Nous allons nous asseoir
et nous allons discuter
comment nous pouvons améliorer
la vie des Canadiens.
(applaudissements)
Parce que ce n'est pas un parti
ou un leader qui a gagné ce
soir. Le vrai gagnant devrait
être le peuple. Ça veut dire les
canadienne et que les Canadiens.
(applaudissements)
Et donc, l'électorat a envoyé un
message très clair à savoir
qu'il voulait un gouvernement
qui travaille pour eux, non pas
pour les riches pour les
puissants, non pas pour ceux qui
ont leurs entrées au pouvoir.
(applaudissements)
Exactement comme vous dîtes,
Monsieur. Nous en reparlerons,
désolé. Et si tous les députés
toutes les députées élus ce soir
entendent ce message et agissent
en conséquence, alors les vrais
gagnants seront les gens,
le peuple.
(applaudissements)
Les Canadiens et Canadiennes ont
envoyé un message clair ce soir.
Ils veulent un gouvernement qui
fonctionne pour eux, pas pour
les plus riches et les grandes
multinationales, pour les
Canadiens et les Canadiennes.
(applaudissements)
Et si tous les députés élus ce
soir entendent ce message
et agissent en conséquence, les
verrai gagnants de l'action
seront les gens.
(applaudissements)
J'aimerais que vous sachiez que
les néodémocrates vont
travailler fort pour offrir.
Nous allons nous concentrer pour
que les jeunes puissent avoir un
avenir qui est rempli d'espoir.
(applaudissements)
C'est ça, c'est exact!
Que les jeunes puissent vraiment
avoir espoir nous voulons nous
assurer que le Canada soit un
chef de file dans le combat
mondial a livré contre la crise
climatique.
(applaudissements)
Nous voulons que les familles
puissent avoir une vie plus
abordable.
(applaudissements)
Et nous voulons un Canada
qui est une nation qui prend
réellement la réconciliation au
sérieux.
(applaudissements)
Et vous savez, car la
réconciliation c'est plus que
des paroles pour nous, cela
fait appel à des gestes
concrets.
Par conséquent, voici ce que les
néodémocrates vont chercher à
faire, car nous allons
travailler avec d'autres parties
pour en arriver aux objectifs.
Voici ce que nous voulons
réussir.
Nous avons besoin de
médicaments, nous voulons que ça
passe sur la carte d'assurance-
maladie n'ont pas la carte de
crédit.
(applaudissements)
Ça veut dire un régime
d'assurance médicaments
universelle nationale pour tout
un chacun.
(applaudissements)
Nous voulons aider les Canadiens
à pouvoir trouver une maison
abordable.
(applaudissements)
Et ce que nous voulons dire
quand nous parlons d'abord
d'abordabilité, mais c'est le
fait de s'attaquer à
l'endettement des étudiants
en éliminant tous les intérêts
sur les prêts étudiants par
exemple.
(applaudissements)
Cela veut dire, cela veut dire
s'attaquer aux grandes
entreprises de
télécommunications et plafonner
les factures de cellulaires.
(applaudissements)
Des gestes concrets rapides et
réels. Par exemple, dans le
dossier du climat, finies les
subventions aux grandes sociétés
énergétiques et une fin plus
rapido carburants fossiles.
Où il faut investir dans le
logement et nous allons le
faire, absolument!
(applaudissements)
Nous allons également nous
assurer que nous allons dire
comme peu sont prêts à le dire,
nous allons nous assurer
que les grandes fortunes
commencent à payer leur juste
part.
(applaudissements)
- Taxer les riches,
dit la foule!
- C'est exactement ce que nous
allons faire, tout à fait!
Mes amis, c'est exactement ce
que nous allons faire,
croyez-moi.
- Jagmeet Singh qui dit que tout
ce qu'il voulait, révolu et
pendant la campagne pendant ce
discours, très long discours du
chef néodémocrates qui, je vous
le rappelle, si vous étiez avec
nous a la balance du pouvoir
aura un rôle. De l'autre côté
vous voyait le chat conservateur
qui rend avec sa dernière, sa
petite fille. Lui va parler dans
quelques minutes, M. Sheer
malgré le fait qu'il a mieux
fait dans le vote populaire,
35-33, vous le voyez ce retour
dans l'opposition officielle
avec 122. Est loin de l'objectif
que certains conservateurs
s'étaient donnés, c'est-à-dire
de sortir M. Trudeau du pouvoir.
Que dira-t-il ce soir?
On va savoir dans quelques
secondes je vous signale que M.
Trudeau, tout de suite après M.
Sheer doit prendre la parole,
c'est la tradition de parler en
dernier, de laisser les autres
parlers. Philippe Vincent,
atmosphère, j'imagine...
pardon, assez tendue chez les
conservateurs.
- Oui, ici on accueille le chef
Andrew Scheer. Ils sont
plusieurs. Debout sur leur
chaise. La salle sévit décathlon
avec les conservateurs avait
perdu l'élection.
Andrew Scheer va parler dans les
prochaines 50 compte dans
l'entourage qu'il reste en
poste. On se dit quand même
content parce qu'on ne regarde
pas uniquement les sièges mais
aussi les petites colonnes que
vous voyez, le vote, 35 %
environ pour les conservateurs
c'est plus que les libéraux.
Il a parlé à Justin Trudeau.
Elle va prendre la parole Alicia
Régina.
- Très bien merci on l'écoute.
- D'être de retour en
Saskatchewan.
(en anglais)
Avant tout, j'aimerais remercier
les électeurs et les électrices
de m'avoir réélu comme votre
député.
Merci à tous les bénévoles qui
ont travaillé d'arrache-pied au
bureau, qui ont connu au
Portugal qui ont installé des
pancartes. Merci beaucoup.
D'avoir dirigé la campagne
pendant ces longues semaines.
Le fait d'être votre député,
jamais je tiendrai ça pour
acquis, je travaillerai fort
pour être à la hauteur de votre
confiance. J'aimerais aussi dire
merci à tous les candidats,
aux 336 candidats du parti
progressiste conservateur,
vous avez travaillé très fort
tout au long de la campagne.
Et mes félicitations pour mon de
nouveaux collègues dans la
région...
(applaudissements)
Et à tous ceux qui se sont
joints à notre équipe pendant 40
jours...
- Merci mes amis!
Merci Montréal!
Quelle soirée incroyable!
(applaudissements)
(en anglais)
D'un océan à l'autre ce soir,
les Canadiens ont rejeté les
polarisation, la négativité.
Et ils se sont décidé être
contre les réductions de
services et ils ont voté pour
des gestes forts.
Vous êtes en train d'envoyer
notre équipe libérale de retour
au travail avec un mandat très
clair : nous allons rendre la
vie plus abordable. Nous allons
continuer de nous battre contre
le réchauffement planétaire.
Nous allons supprimer les armes
à feu de nos vies!
(applaudissements)
Les Canadiens nous ont confié la
responsabilité de continuer à
gouverner, mais rien de tout ça
n'aurait été possible sans les
efforts et les sacrifices
beaucoup, beaucoup de monde.
J'ai énormément de gens
remercier. Donc c'est ce que je
vais passer pas mal de temps
téléphone au cours des prochains
jours. Mais ce soir, il y a
quelques personnes en
particulier à qui je dois dire
merci. D'abord, ma Sophie.
(applaudissements)
On commence cette aventure
politique il y a plus de 10 ans
sans parce qu'on croyait en un
avenir meilleur, parce qu'on
savait que ça valait la peine de
se battre pour un Canada plus
fort et plus prospère. Sophie je
suis tellement chance de t'avoir
à mes côtés, merci.
(applaudissements)
Je t'aime!
Merci mon amour, je t'aime!
À mes enfants, Xavier, elle
agresse et Adrien, ils font dodo
maintenant.
À tous les jours vous
m'espéraient à faire plus et
faire mieux et tout ce que je
fais, je le fais pour vous et
votre génération.
(applaudissements)
Vous rappelez à tous les jours
de prendre des instants pour
apprécier la vie qu'on vit
ensemble et la chance qu'on a
et de tous les rôles que
j'assume être votre papa, c'est
celui que je préfère, je vous
aime tellement!
(applaudissements)
(en anglais)-
Et à la meilleure que l'équipe
de campagnes, notre candidat nos
bénévoles et notre personnel,
rien de tout ceci n'eut été
possible sans votre présence,
merci pour les lever à l'aube et
les couchers tardifs.
Merci d'avoir vraiment pu
vous consacrer avec tout ce que
vous êtes pendant cette
campagne. Je peux dire assez,
mais je peux vous dire ceci,
vous avez réussi, félicitations!
Aux chefs des autres parties, à
leur famille, merci!
Merci d'avoir participé cet
exercice essentiel de la
démocratie. Vous avez choisi de
servir, merci d'avoir su vous
manifester lors de cette
campagne.
Je dois bien sûr remercier...
(applaudissements)
Ça fait plus de 10 ans
que vous m'accordez votre
confiance, les gens de papillon,
c'est un grand privilège continu
de vous représenter et de
toujours être une voix forte
pour vous, merci, merci, merci
je peux toujours compter sur
vous!
Et bien sûr, à mes compatriotes.
Ça a été le plus grand honneur
de me de vous sauver depuis
quatre ans maintenant.
Et ce soir pour nous renvoyer au
travail, au boulot et nous
allons nous consacrer à vous.
Nous prenons cette
responsabilité au sérieux,
nous allons travailler jour et
nuit pour vous, pour vos
familles pour votre avenir.
À ceux qui ont voté pour notre
parti, merci de nous avoir
accordé votre confiance.
Merci de croire en nous,
de croire en notre capacité à
faire bouger le pays dans la
bonne direction.
Et à ceux qui n'ont pas voté
pour nous, sachez que nous
allons travailler tous les jours
pour vous, nous allons gouverner
pour chacun et pour chacune.
(applaudissements)
Quel qu'ait été votre choix
politique notre équipe va se
battre pour que les Canadiens
toutes les Canadiennes.
Mes chers Québécois, j'ai
entendu votre message ce soir,
vous voulez continuer d'avancer
avec nous, mais vous voulez
aussi vous assurer que la voie
du Québec se porte encore plus à
Ottawa et je vous donne ma
parole : mon équipe et moi
serons là pour vous.
(applaudissements)
Et aux Canadiens d'Alberta et en
Saskatchewan, sachez que vous
faites partie intégrante de
notre grand pays. J'ai entendu
votre frustration je vais être
la afin de vous soutenir,
travaillant tous ensemble
pour que nous puissions réunir
le pays.
(applaudissements)
Depuis quatre ans, on a fait
tout ce qu'on peut pour
améliorer la vie de tous et
c'est ce qu'on va continuer à
faire au cours des prochaines
années. Mes amis, vous nous
envoyez à Ottawa avec un mandat
clair : continuer à faire
avancer notre pays.
Vous nous avez demandé
d'investir dans les Canadiens,
de faire de la réconciliation
avec les peuples autochtones une
priorité.
(applaudissements)
De faire preuve d'encore plus de
vision et d'ambition alors que
nous nous attaquons plus grand
défis de notre époque :
les changements climatiques.
Eh bien, c'est exactement ce que
l'on va faire.
On sait qu'il y a encore
énormément de travail mais je
vous donne ma parole, on va
continuer ce qu'on a commencé.
(applaudissements)
Parce que les libéraux savent,
comme tous les Canadiens ça,
qu'il est toujours possible de
faire mieux.
(applaudissements)
Un de mes favoris premiers
ministre, Winfried Laurier,
laisse mentionner le patriotisme
et le pouvoir unificateur des
objectifs partagés et j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi depuis mon
entrée dans la vie politique, à
mes échanges avec les Canadiens
un peu partout au Canada, j'ai
vu qu'il y a tant qui nous unit,
beaucoup plus ce qui nous
divise. Les Canadiens
s'attendent de nous à ce qu'on
puisse vraiment partager une
vision de Canada plus fort. J'ai
l'intention de travailler fort
pour transformer ça en réalité.
(applaudissements)
Nous tous voulons des
communautés plus sures, nous ne
vous le voulons pour nous-mêmes,
pour nos enfants et nos petits-
enfants. Nous voulons vraiment
la prospérité pour tous et les
difficultés pour personnes.
Voilà le monde qui nous inspire
et si nous nous unissons autour
de ses objectifs communs. Je
sais que nous pouvons réussir le
coup.
Dans les années à venir notre
équipe a travaillé fort pour que
nous puissions nous inspirer des
progrès accomplis par les
Canadiens qui nous ont précédé.
Nous allons être le champion de
Canada des plus diversifiées,
nous avons des une voix ceux qui
n'ont pas de voix et dans chaque
décision que nous prendrons à
titre de votre gouvernement,
nous allons toujours mettre ce
pays sa population au premier
plan.
(applaudissements)
On va aider la veuve quiient
de perdre son mari après 48
heures de vie commune,
on va faire plus pour l'étudiant
qui a participé à la marche pour
le climat et on va être là pour
la mère qui a deux emplois et
trois enfants qui a besoin de
plus d'aide à la fin du mois.
Nous allons nous battre pour
tout le monde, y inclus des gens
comme Dean, ces quelques jours
que j'ai été dans des
rassemblements un peu partout
j'ai raconté l'histoire de Dean.
Il a voté conservateur toute sa
vie mais cette fois-ci il a
décidé de voter pour les
libéraux au nom de sa fille.
Voyez-vous, il a compris
que cette campagne électorale
aller chercher beaucoup plus que
quatre années.
Non, il est question des
prochaines 40 années,
Jean de Canada que nous
préparons pour sa fille et sa
cohorte sa génération ce soir
j'aimerais ça dire ceci à Dean.
Il me faut mériter votre vote
et non seulement le vote votre
fille. Et dans les années à
venir, je n'intention de faire
exactement cela.
Mes amis, cette campagne
électorale, ces élections
tournaient autour de vous.
Le monde que vos enfants vont
hériter. Et ce soir nous avons
décidé de faire avancer le pays
pour ce soir les Canadiens
on fixait un objectif, un cap.
Ensemble vers un avenir
meilleur!
Merci beaucoup tout le monde,
merci Montréal!
Merci
- Justin Trudeau qui félicite
les partisans. Il dit aussi
qu'il avait entendu le message
des gens qui n'avaient pas voté
pour lui dans l'Ouest. Il a
parlé aux albertain, il a parlé
aux gens des prairies en disant
: je ne vous oublie pas,
j'aurais un défi de rassembler
ce pays. Et au québécois : je
vous ai entendu également et je
vous promets que nous allons
prendre en compte les intérêts
du Québec.
Pendant que vous voyez ces
images il est arrivé quelque
chose d'inusité. Monsieur
Trudeau a commencé à parler
alors que Monsieur Scheer avait
à peine commencé, ce qui en
général ne se fait pas. On
attend que le chef de
l'opposition est fini de parler
pour ensuite prendre la parole.
Manifestement, il y a eu soit
des coups de téléphone manqué,
on ne fait pas compris.
Je vais aller voir Philippe
Vincent Foisy pendant qu'on voit
que Monsieur Trudeau est content
et embrasse les gens.
Philippe Vincent, qu'a-t-il dit
à Andrew Scheer que l'on doit
savoir dans son discours?
- Patrice, Andrew Shirai s'est
dit déçu mais en même temps très
content de la compagne qu'il a
menée, condensé des résultats.
Il dit : si vous regardez le
pays en ce moment ça va quand
même plutôt bien. Il y a des
gains conservateurs dans presque
toutes les provinces. Ils sont
en train de mener dans le vote
populaire. Ça aussi c'est vu
d'un côté très positif par les
conservateurs. Il est dit qu'en
ce moment Trudeau et dans le
corps : son leadership est
affaiblie. Les conservateurs
sont donc prêts à le remplacer.
Il dit que son parti est prêt à
remplacer juste être dos lorsque
le temps viendra.
Il compare ce qui s'était passé
en 2004 quand Paul Martin d'un
gouvernement minoritaire. Il a
parlé de ce que vous disiez, de
l'unité nationale en ce moment
en disant : il y a pas de
libéraux en Alberta ni en
Saskatchewan. Au Québec, le
bloc, le parti séparatiste, a eu
le vent dans les voiles. Il dit
que le pays est plus divisé que
jamais.
- Lui se croit et il est bien en
selle.
- Il est toujours chef de
l'opposition. Il s'en va à
Ottawa pour se battre contre
Justin Trudeau.
-. Philippe Vincent... j'allais
vous appeler Monsieur, ça va
bien!
Merci pour la campagne pour
toutes ces collaborations. Alors
on revient à Justin Trudeau
avant de finir.
Un petit mot. Effectivement il a
un énorme défi d'unité, de
cohérence dans ces pays. Il
regarde dans l'Ouest et il est
rayé de la carte en Alberta.
Il y a l'Ontario et Montréal et
le Québec.
- Quand il parle que tout le
monde a une vision commune de la
bonne qualité de vie, c'est là
où c'est la divergence. La
qualité de vie dépendant l'Ouest
des pipelines, d'une industrie
que les électeurs il est, les
électeurs progressistes
rejettent. Comment il va
concilier cela? Je vois mal
comment il va être capable de le
faire. J'ai prédit que dans deux
ans on va retourner aux urnes
parce que c'est un problème.
- La moyenne d'âge de
gouvernement minoritaire fait un
an et 10 mois.
- C'est un défi que la plupart
des pays riches et avancer
partage. Comment on fait pour
concilier les changements
climatiques et une partie de la
prospérité qui vient de
l'exploitation des ressources
naturelles? C'est accentué ici
parce qu'il y a des provinces
qui vivent pratiquement que de
ses ressources la. Pour une
fédération c'est un défi
supplémentaire.
- La carte Madeleine rapidement,
en un coup d'oeil, on comprend e
défi pour un chef national à
Ottawa.
- Voyez vous vraiment sa zone
d'influence à Justin Trudeau est
dans la banlieue de Toronto. On
ne la voit pas bien ici parce
que cette petite sur la carte.
Allons-y. On voit à quel point
ces sièges sont concentrés ici.
Il y a des sièges au Québec,
même si le Bloc québécois a
bloqué la majorité libérale.
Mais dans l'Ouest, en
Saskatchewan aucun siège. Même
scénario en Alberta où il n'y a
plus aucun siège. Alors
effectivement ça va être une
difficulté supplémentaire. Au-
delà de sa capacité de s'allier
peut-être avec le bloc ou avec
les libéraux-démocrates pour
faire tenir son gouvernement, il
y a cette question d'unité qui
sera une trame de fond de ce
gouvernement.
- Une lutte à finir. Il y en a
encore Mesdames et Messieurs,
malgré l'heure tardive.
Élisabeth Brière de Sherbrooke
qui est en avance de 500 voix.
C'est quand même une bonne
avance. C'est à surveiller. Dans
Châteauguay Lacolle, 619 voix
d'avance pour Brenda Shanahan.
C'est aussi une bonne avance.
Jean-Yves Duclos.
C'est plus serré.
- Il reste cependant seulement
trois boîtes de scrutin à
dépouiller.
- Très bien. Je presse le pas.
Gaspésie les îles, c'est plus
confortable. C'est réglé.
On les déclare.
Louis Blouin, pourquoi Monsieur
Trudeau n'a pas attendu que
Monsieur Scheer finisse?
- On nous dit que ce n'était pas
voulu. Il était prêt depuis une
dizaine de minutes et attendez
que Jagmeet Singh finisse. On
nous dit qu'on n'a pas eu des
signaux de la part du camp
conservateur. Une confusion
s'est installée. On nous dit
qu'il n'y avait rien de
prémédité, de voulu là-dedans.
- Je signale aux gens, si vous
voulez aller voir les discours.
Sur les internatde de Radio-
Canada. On a vu l'intégralité
des discours. Merci Louis!
Vous pourrez regarder cela,
analyser tout ça également. Taux
de participation.
On se demandait au début de la
campagne : est-ce que cette
campagne ne passera pas
l'histoire? 64,6 %.
Ce n'est pas si mal. Mais c'est
quand même plus bas que 2015.
Un tour de table extrêmement
rapide.
Il y aura des défis pour à peu
près tout le monde.
- Le principal défi va tourner
autour du débat sur la taxe sur
le carbone. Dès lors qu'il fait
cela, mécontentement majeur en
Alberta et en Saskatchewan. Et
quelles seront les conséquences
sur le parti conservateur? Est-
ce que Andrew Scheer sera assez
fort pour mener la barque ou
bien si la pression fera sorte
qu'on en voudra une autre?
- Saba ressemblait beaucoup à la
cacophonie qu'on a entendue dans
les débats en anglais. Les voies
vont venir de partout.
- Belle image.
- Belle victoire pour les
libéraux. Il y a quelques jours
et était nerveux. Il pensait
être derrière les conservateurs.
Andrew Scheer n'a peut-être pas
démissionné maintenant. Mais je
pense qu'il va y avoir de la
grogne et je pense qu'on n'a pas
entendu le dernier chapitre sur
cette histoire.
- Unité du pays. À 150 sièges,
le fardeau va être sur le
gouvernement de pas juste faire
fonctionner le Parlement mais
envoyer le message qu'il peut
poser des gestes pour rassembler
les Canadiens.
Je vous remercie infiniment pour
vos lumières. Vous avez été
extraordinaire. Merci de ce
côté-là aussi.
Madeleine, merci à vous. Merci
aux gens la régie, sur le
plateau.
On voulait une soirée électorale
avec de l'émotion. Je pense
qu'on a été servi.
Demain dans tous nos grands
rendez-vous on va décortiquer
tous les résultats. Il y a
encore quelques courses à
suivre.
Merci à vous de votre attention.
Depuis 18 heures 30 maintenant.
On se dit à très bientôt. Au
revoir!